decades ago the term artificial
intelligence was just another
frankenstein story but today it could be
a citizen in your next door
right from his genesis artificial
intelligence was programmed to probe
into human life and eliminate the
fortifications of the impossibilities in
many areas like healthcare
transportation communication and much
more
there are hundreds and thousands of
organizations tech communities and
engineers worldwide working round the
clock to make miracles a reality
and today we are going to discuss the
top 10 amongst those who are
contributing a significant part
so here we are the top 10 artificial
intelligence companies to watch in 2022.
at number 10 we have this ai
this ai is a revolutionary approach to
dramatically improvise the way
healthcare is delivered
with ai focuses on implementing
artificial intelligence to diagnose and
detect abnormalities in the human body
via ct cta mri x-ray ekg ultrasound etc
this ai coordinates both the patient and
healthcare professionals at the same
time
the patient reports are shared via
mobile to all the concerned medical
teams results are astonishing with
vis-a-i there is a significant
improvement in productivity and
reduction of time required for patient
treatment and discharge
this ai was founded in 2016 and
established in november 2021.
company runs with 223 employees and the
headquarters is in san francisco
this ai mainly focuses on improving and
filling all the gaps between patients
and healthcare professionals
this ai offers handsome salaries to its
employees
in india the salaries range from four
lakhs to 18 lakhs per annum and in
america the wages range from one ten
thousand dollars to two ten thousand
dollars per annum
so at number nine we have farm wise
ten years ago an automated wheat killing
robo was science fiction
now its rise of practical weed killing
robots with millimeter precision thanks
to farmwise the first product of the
californian based company was an
automated robo weeder based on ai
computer vision and also robotics
the robot would eliminate weeds from the
vegetable fields
farmvise intends to build innovative
systems and efficient procedures that
help farmers streamline farming with
efficiency
farmwise was established in the year
2020 the company functions with 50
employees on board and actively looking
for expansion
the company follows the procedure of
paying farming equipment employees and
contract personnel hourly
farm buys makes an annual turnover of
8.5 million us dollars
on average an aiml engineer at farmwise
earns anywhere around
113 000. per annum
up next we have amp robotics at number
eight we have amp robotics while others
are busy trying to revolutionize mankind
with ai amp robotics came up with an
innovative idea that happens to be a
kind gesture of gratitude towards nature
amp ai designed an artificial
intelligence robo that recycles e-waste
plastic waste and waste from
construction sites and much more the
robo precisely identifies paper plastics
and metals by learning and recognizing
them via color size shape and a few more
factors
the colorado based company is currently
operational with 137 employees in total
and looking forward to expand the idea
globally ap robotics aims to reimagining
recycling and to create a world without
waste through artificial intelligence
amp robotics pays handsome salaries to
their employees with an average salary
of an employee amp
robotics varies between ninety six
thousand dollars to one thirty one
thousand dollars per annum
coming up next is a giant at number
seven we have automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a global robotics
automation and software company founded
in the year 2003. the company's
headquarters is located in san jose
california
the global rpa leader offers
cloud-native web-based intelligent
automation solutions to the world's
leading cloud companies
automation anywhere's automation 360
offers a variety of intelligent tools
and self-learning systems to automate
every redundant task
automation anywhere is focusing on
transforming the companies to be rpa
oriented and the current covet
situations have triggered the need for
automation even more
a recent survey states the rpe adoption
rates will increase by 57
in just one more year
the globally recognized multinational
company works with more than 2
200 plus employees on board
the company pays decent salaries as well
at number six we have microsoft ai
microsoft integrated ai into cloud
computing microsoft's ai platform
provides robust solutions to
cloud-related problems microsoft's ai
division is headquartered in redmond
washington with around 5000 employees
specifically in the ai division and aims
to train and certify 15 000 employees by
2022.
microsoft ai is a robust framework
designed for developing ai solutions
using machine learning data science
robotics iot and more
ai enable services accelerate
productivity to a greater level
microsoft azure uses ai to get best of
breed infrastructure with enterprise
create security availability compliance
and manageability microsoft also pays
hands-on salaries to their employees the
average salary of an employee at the
microsoft ai division earns up to 160
thousand dollars per annum
at number five we have data robo
data robo has its headquarters in boston
it is one of the ai cloud leaders
providing a unified platform to its
cloud users to accelerate the delivery
of ai to the cloud
data robo aims to understand and
leverage the inherent capabilities of
the platform
data robo has the caliber to help
business analysts in building predictive
analytics with no knowledge of machine
learning
it uses automated ml to build and deploy
accurate predictive models in a short
span of time
the global cloud leader currently
operates with more than a thousand
employees worldwide
data robo compensates its employees with
handsome salaries an average employee at
data robo earns up to one sixty thousand
dollars per year and up to three like
four hundred thousand rupees in india
at number four we have amazon the alexa
maker amazon is one of the tech giants
interested in adopting ai into its
various divisions
amazon calls its ai services amazon lex
amazon poly amazon recognition and
amazon machine learning
these services are accessible through a
software api call or console the amazon
ai suite of services can have text or
voice conversations with an end user
using a conversational chat ops
interface
the seattle-based tech giant is
currently using ai for its smart home
solutions
ai companies like alexa and its business
intelligence needs amazon is also
conducting trials on drone delivery to
save time and efforts to deliver goods
and services to remote locations with
ease
amazon ai aims to provide biometric
payments to its customers at cash-free
stores
the approach is still in trials
amazon calls it just walk out technology
amazon has enormous teams and pays
decent salaries to its employees for
example an employee at amazon can earn
up to 20 lakh rupees per annum in india
and about a hundred thousand dollars per
annum in united states of america
at number three we have data bricks
databricks is one of the best data
driven companies
data bricks lake houses combine data
warehouses reliability performance and
governance with the openness and
flexibility of data lakes
data brick is headquartered in san
francisco california and has 15 office
locations across 11 countries
the company announces plans on
delivering keynote on data and machine
learning product innovations and the
rise of the lake house architecture
advancements
databricks currently operates with 2 000
plus employees globally
the organization compensates its
employees with handsome salaries an
average employee at databricks makes
about 154 000 us dollars and around 2.1
lakh rupees per annum in india
next we have meta at number two we have
meta
meta formerly known as facebook is
innovating in advanced way of social
interaction
meta has integrated artificial
intelligence and it's being called the
meta ai
meta ai has its headquarters in toronto
canada
meta-ai has redesigned a new material
and touch sensor with potential to boost
the development of metawars
a team of researchers at the metawars
have worked jointly with scientists at
carnegie mellon university to build
reskin a plastic three millimeter thick
membrane with magnetic particles capable
of measuring touch and sensation
a thrilling experiment meta has under
its sleeve i would say meta currently
operates remotely with about 350
employees on board
critics also state that meta pays a vast
salary to its ai experts with an average
salary of 1 lakh 750 000
paid to the employees at meta ai
at number one we have google ai
google ai is the division of google
dedicated to artificial intelligence
ceo sundar pichai announced it at google
i o 2017. google ai has its headquarters
in california
google ai is demonstrating its quantum
computing supremacy with its new and
powerful cinema processor google's ai is
one of the most widespread technologies
it's almost everywhere
from your language translations to
helping people with speech impairments
to have a successful conversation
social media interactions shopping lists
and assisting users with gps sending
alerts to its users about natural
calamities and saving them
google ai has announced that its
research team is designing next
generation ai chips for a smart future
in addition a new ai model allows
artificial intelligence to perform chip
design that more efficiently solves
unique aspects of any problem with an
artificial neural network
google ai currently works with our four
divisions with massive teams have you
ever wondered how google maps
autocorrect and chat bots work it is all
due to ai and deep learning
artificial intelligence is changing
business at a rapid rate ai and deep
learning are also impacting our lives
outside the office self-driving cars
smart assistants like amazon alexa and
disease mapping are a few examples of ai
that are impacting our personal lives
each and every day
companies like tesla and uber use ai and
machine learning to develop reliable
transportation solutions for everyone
everywhere ai and deep learning are
lurking in the background every time you
open your facebook news feed do a google
search get a movie recommendation from
netflix or book a hotel online on
revival artificial intelligence has
become an important part of the gaming
industry in recent years ai is a branch
of computer science that deals with
building intelligent machines capable of
performing complex tasks and taking
decisions by mimicking a human brain
deep learning on the other hand is a
subset of machine learning that is used
to build and train artificial neural
network deep in deep learning refers to
a neural network comprised of more than
three leaders john le cool the director
of ai research at facebook and professor
at new york university
says deep learning combined with
reasoning and planning is one area of
research making promising advances right
now ai and deep learning together can
solve repetitive problems data intensive
tasks and other superhuman jobs while ai
and deep learning bring more efficiency
into our lives we encounter new problems
developed by integrating ai into our
lives with this understanding of ai and
deep learning let's go ahead and learn
them in detail
so first we will learn the basics of
artificial intelligence with a short
animated video
then we will look at the future of ai
and understand ai in depth with hands-on
demonstrations in python
we will learn the top 10 artificial
intelligence technologies in 2021 and
shift our focus to understanding deep
learning in detail you will learn the
basics of deep learning followed by
neural networks
moving further you will get an idea
about the two most popular deep learning
frameworks tensorflow and keras
you will also get an idea about
recurrent neural network and generative
adversarial networks finally we will
understand computer vision using the
opencv library and look at the top deep
learning interview questions so let's
get started picture this a machine that
could organize your cupboard just as you
like it or serve every member of the
house a customized cup of coffee makes
your day easier doesn't it these are the
products of artificial intelligence but
why use the term artificial intelligence
well these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across
using the plank provided as an input the
robot is able to cross this stream so
our robot uses the given input and finds
the solution for a problem this is
problem solving these three capabilities
make the robot artificially intelligent
in short ai provides machines with the
capability to adapt reason and provide
solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
in ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain this
means through deep learning data and
patterns can be better perceived
ray kurzweil a well-known futurist
predicts that by the year 2045 we would
have robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us well
that is artificial intelligence for you
in short
[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai as we have been
to specifically target tasks that we
need or want done in place of ourselves
that's how ai will ultimately unfold
it is a renaissance it is a golden age
we are now solving problems with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanity has ever worked on and i think
of it as something more profound than
electricity or fire and anytime you work
with technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits
and while minimizing the downside
[Music]
[Applause]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and uh clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars there are
others
uh and we sort of see it as the mother
of all ai projects
there's a class of things like game
plane
or speech recognition or image
recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know mind blowing
certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery
these biological systems are very
complicated and so the fact that we have
you know vaccines for tb and hiv coming
that's partly enabled by this rich data
advance in biology and machine learning
when i look at
seeing ai which is an application we
just launched for anybody with visual
impairment they can go download this app
that uses the latest cutting edge
computer vision technology in our cloud
to give anyone the ability to see and in
fact angela mills was a colleague of
mine was just telling me about how it's
changed her life inside of microsoft she
can go into our cafeteria order food
using this app with confidence walk into
conference rooms with confidence because
she knows she's walking into the right
conference room or what we've done with
our onenote and word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use ai
to be able to read better the latest
release of windows 10 has this
capability called eye gaze which is
something that we learned working with
steve gleason and the als patients
saying if you all you have is the eye
muscle
and the gaze can we help you type
yeah you have to be careful uh when
there's advances in a sense we're all
better off if if the machines can make
all the food and the clothes and none of
us have to work
uh you know you think okay now we have
all the freedom if we want to stand
behind the
the counter and you know
make sandwiches okay you can if you want
but there's this other way to make those
goods and services but it will be very
disruptive
because you know say your mid-career
in manufacturing or driving
then it's a disruption now we've had
that in a slow way for hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers i said it's
right to be concerned absolutely you
have to worry about it otherwise you're
not going to solve it right and it's
important to understand tomorrow whether
google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress you know technology
has
this nature it's a it's going to evolve
i think
pulling back history shows pulling back
countries which pull back don't do well
with the change we know that
20 30 years ago you educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that so we have to
transform how we do education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done
you know on the back of
you know technology or you know is going
to be fundamentally vulnerable yeah so i
think uh technology in particular ai can
in fact bring more empowerment more
inclusiveness and at the same time we
should be clear-eyed about displacement
clear-eyed about unintended consequences
like any other technology and work both
skilling so that you know people can
find the jobs of the future
create new jobs and
lastly i think have a set of policy
decisions
that really help people
as they go through this change
the risks are
important and i think the way we solve
it is
we think ahead we worry about it
we
do things like from from be upfront uh
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one be very
transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there and figure out
global frameworks by which we can engage
just like paris agreement and climate
change you know using forums like this i
think we bring people together to engage
on the hard questions and i think ansys
will emerge
um you know i have exposure to the very
most cutting edge
ai um
and i think people should be really
concerned about it
um i keep sounding the alarm bell but
you know until
people see like robots going down the
street killing people like they don't
know how to react you know because it
seems so ethereal
and
i think we should be really concerned
about ai and i think we should
this ai is a rare case where i think we
need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive
because i think by the time we are
reactive in ai regulation it's too late
right now we have
machine learning
algorithms that can solve an incredibly
complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially complete idiots and
like two-year-olds and anything that's
not that problem they're dumb they're
like that you can give them this
enormous data set and they come up with
brilliant correlations and insights but
they're not going to plug into skynet
and you know like like like threaten us
anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic
and uh i don't think
artificial intelligence is a threat i
don't think that
artificial intelligence is something
terrible
but human beings are smart enough to
learn that
[Music]
what is artificial intelligence and
today's world is probably one of the
most exciting advancements that we're in
the middle of experiencing as humans so
what is artificial intelligence and here
we have a robot with nice little clampy
hands hey what am i you are what we call
artificial intelligence i am your
creator reminding him who programmed him
and who he's supposed to take care of
artificial intelligence is a branch of
computer science dedicated to creating
intelligent machines that work and react
like humans in today's place where we're
at with artificial intelligence i really
want to highlight the fact that they
work and react like humans because that
is where the development of artificial
intelligence is and that's what we're
comparing it to is how it looks like
next to a human thanks any tasks you
want me to do for you get me a cup of
coffee poof here you go he brings him a
cup of coffee that's my kind of robot i
love my coffee in the morning you'll see
there's kind of a side theme of coffee
today's uh tutorial so here we have a
robot that's able to bring him a cup of
coffee seems pretty far out there you
know that we have a walking robot that's
doing this but it's not as far out there
as you think we have automatic coffee
pots we have devices that can move an
object from one point to the other you
know anything from amazon delivering
packages or whatever you want all these
things are in today's world we're right
on the edge of all this that's what
makes this so exciting such an exciting
topic and a place of study so let's take
a look a real general look at types of
artificial intelligence in the really
big picture i mean we drill into it
there's like machine learning and all
kinds of different aspects but just a
generic level of artificial intelligence
so hi there discovered four different
types come have a look so we have our
kind of einstein looking guy or
professor at some college so the very
first part that we're really this is uh
as reactive machines they've been around
a long time this kind of ai are purely
reactive and do not hold the ability to
form memories or use past experiences to
make decisions these machines are
designed to do specific jobs remember i
talked about the programmable coffee
maker that makes coffee in the morning
it doesn't remember yesterday from
tomorrow it runs its program even going
back to our washing machines they have
automatic load balancers that have been
around for decades so reactive machines
we program to do certain tasks and they
have no memory but they're very
functional then we have limited memory
this is kind of right where we're at
right now this kind of ai uses past
experience and the present data to make
a decision self-driving cars are kind of
limited memory ai we bring up
self-driving cars because that's a big
thing especially in today's market they
have all these images that they brought
in and videos of what's gone on before
and they use that to teach the automatic
car what to do so it's based on a
limited memory limited memory means it's
not evolving new ideas they have to
actually when they need to make a change
they have the programming built on the
memory but then they have to make those
changes outside of that and then put the
new setup in there so it's continually
reprogramming itself theory of mind
these ai machines can socialize and
understand human emotions machines with
such abilities are yet to be developed
of course that's under debate there's a
lot of places that are working on the
theory of mind and having it be able to
cognitively understand somebody based on
the environment their
facial features all kinds of things and
evolve with them so their own they have
some kind of reflective ability to
evolve with that and finally
self-awareness this is the future of ai
these machines will be super intelligent
sentient and conscious so they'll be
able to react very much like a human
being although they'll have their own
flavor i'm sure achieving artificial
intelligence so how in today's world
right now are we going to achieve
artificial intelligence well the main
arena right now is machine learning
machine learning provides artificial
intelligence with the ability to learn
this is achieved by using algorithms to
discover patterns and generate insights
from the data they are exposed to and
here we have a computer as we get more
and more to the human realm of art and
official intelligence you see this guy
splits in two and he's inside his hidden
networks and machine learning programs
deep learning which is a subcategory of
machine learning deep learning provides
artificial intelligence the ability to
mimic a human brain's neural network it
can make sense of patterns noise and
sources of confusion in the data let's
try to segregate different kinds of
photos using deep learning so first we
have our pile of photographs much more
organized than my boxes in my closet of
photographs the machine goes through the
features of every photo to distinguish
them this is called feature extraction
bingo figures out the different features
in the photos and so based on those
different features labels of photos it
says these are landscapes these are
portraits these are others so it
separates them in there if you've ever
been on google uh photos a favorite of
mine i go through there and i type in
dog and i get all the images of my dog
it's pretty amazing how it's able to
pull those features out so when we're
achieving artificial intelligence and
the deep learning let's take a closer
look and see just how deep learning
works there are a lot of models out
there this is the most basic model used
this is a neural network there are three
main layers in a neural network the
photos that we want to segregate go into
the input layer and so we have a picture
of mona lisa it looks like and a couple
of people when it goes into the first
input layer the arrows are drawn to like
individual dots each one of those white
dots in the yellow layer or in the input
layer would be a pixel in the picture
maybe a value for that pixel so the
picture of the mountains goes in there
and it fills in that whole input layer
and then the next picture of the
nightscape goes in there the hidden
layers are responsible for all the
mathematical computations or feature
extraction on our inputs so when you see
here we have the two kind of orangish
red layers here and there's all these
lines in there those lines are the
weights each one of those represents a
usually a float number or a decimal
number and then it multiplies it by the
value in the input layer and you'll see
that as it adds all these up in the
hidden layer each one of those dots in
the hidden layer that has a value based
on the sum of the weights and then it
takes those and puts it into another
hidden layer and you might ask well why
do we have multiple hidden layers well
the hidden layers function as different
alternatives to some degree so the more
hidden layers you have the more complex
the data that goes in and what can they
can produce coming out the accuracy of
the predicted output generally depends
on the number of hidden layers we have
so there we go the accuracy is based on
how many hidden layers we have and again
it has to do with how complex the data
is going in the output layer gives us
the segregated photos so once it adds up
all these weights and you'll see there's
weights also going into the output layer
based on those weights it'll say yes
it's a portrait no it's a portrait yes
it's a landscape no it's a landscape and
that's how we get our setup in there so
now we were able to label our photos
let's take a look and see what that
looks like in another domain we have
photograph domain now let's look at it
in the airline ticket so let's predict
the airline ticket prices using machine
learning these are the factors based on
which we're going to make the
predictions and choosing your factors is
so important but for right here we'll
just go ahead and take a look what we
got we have airlines we have the origin
airport the destination airport the
departure date here are some historical
data of ticket prices to train the
machine so we pull in the old data this
is what's happened over the years now
that our machine is trained let's give
it new data for which it will predict
the prices if you remember from our four
different kinds of machines we have
machines with memory well this is the
memory part it remembers all the old
data and then it compares what you put
in to produce the new data to predict
the new prices the price is 1 000 that's
an expensive flight of course
if that is a us dollars if it's india i
don't know what the price range is on
that hopefully it's a good deal for
wherever you're going so we predict the
prices and this is kind of nice because
if you're looking way ahead it'd be nice
to know if you're planning a trip for
next year how much those tickets are
going to cost and they certainly
fluctuate a lot so let's take a look at
the applications of artificial
intelligence we're going to dive just a
little deeper because we talked about
photos we've talked about airline ticket
prices kind of very specific you get one
specific number but let's look at some
more things that are probably more
in-home more common right now speaking
of in-home this young gentleman is
entering his room of course makes a
comment like we all do we walk into a
room this room is dark isn't it let's
see what happens when i enter it the
sensors in my room detect my presence
and switch on the lights this is an
example of non-memory machines okay you
know it senses you it doesn't have a
memory of whether you've gone in or not
some of the new models start running a
prediction as to whether you're in the
room or not when you show up when you
don't so they turn things on before you
come down the stairs in the morning
especially if you're trying to save
energy you might have one of those fancy
uh thermostats which starts guessing
when you get up in the morning so it
doesn't start the heater until it knows
you're going to get up so here he comes
in here and this is one of the examples
of uh smart machine and that is one of
the many applications of artificial
intelligence one of the things we're
developing here in our homes okay bye
abruptly he leaves leaving his nice
steaming cup of coffee there on the
table and when he leaves the sensors
detect he's gone and turn off the lights
let's watch some tv did someone say tv
the sound sensors on the tv detect my
voice and turn on the tv sounds kind of
strange but with the google dongle and a
google home mini you can actually do
just that you can ask it to play a movie
downstairs on your downstairs tv true
also with the amazon fire stick and all
the different artificial intelligent
home appliances that are coming out
pretty amazing time to be alive and in
this industry here you have one more
application of artificial intelligence
and you can probably think of dozens of
others that are right now on the cutting
edge of development so let's jump into
my favorite part which is a use case
predict if a person has diabetes and in
the medical domain i mean if you read
any of these they say a predictive
person has diabetes but in the medical
domain we would want to restate this as
what is the risk is a person a high risk
of diabetes should just be something on
their radar to be looking out for and
we'll be helping out with the use case
there we are with a cup of coffee again
i forgot to shave as you can see we'll
start with the problem statement the
problem statement is to predict if a
person has diabetes or not and we might
start with this prediction statement but
if you were actually using this in real
case again you would say your high risk
of diabetes would be the proper way to
present that to somebody if you ran
their test data through here but that's
very domain specific which is outside of
the problem statement as far as the
computer programmers involved so we have
a look at the features these are the
things that have been recorded and they
already have this data from the
hospitals one of them would be number of
times pregnant obviously if you're a guy
that'd be zero glucose concentration so
these are people who've had their
glucose measured blood pressure age age
is a big factor an easy thing to look at
insulin level so if someone's on insulin
they probably have diabetes otherwise
they wouldn't be taking insulin but that
would affect everything else and we add
that in there if they're if they're
using insulin let's start off with the
code so we're going to start off by
importing parts of our data set and if
we're going to do this let's jump into
one of our favorite tools we're going to
use the anaconda jupiter notebook so let
me flip over there and we'll talk just
briefly about that and then we'll look
over this code so here we are in the
jupiter notebook and
this is an inline editor which is just
really cool for messing with python on
the fly you can do demos in it it's very
visual you can add pieces of code it has
cells so you can run each cell
individually you can delete them but you
can tell the cell to be a comment so
that instead of running it it just skips
over it there's all kinds of cool things
you can do with jupiter notebook we're
not going to go into that we're actually
going to go with the tensorflow and you
do have to import all the different
modules in your python now if you're in
a different python ide that's fine it'll
work in just about any of your python
ides and i'll point out the one
difference in code when we get to that
which is the inline for doing our graph
and in this code we're going to go
through we're going to load our data up
we're going to explore it we're going to
label it and then we'll use the
tensorflow and then we'll get down to
the end where we're going to take a look
at how good the model is does it work so
let's start with the top part here and
let me go ahead and let's paste that
code in there i've added a line in at
the top i've added the folder because i
didn't put it in the same folder as the
program that's running you don't need to
worry too much about that but if you
have a folder issue or says file doesn't
exist you probably have it in the wrong
folder or you need to add the folder
path and then we're going to import
pandas and let me just one of the cool
things since it's in internet chrome we
can just do that control plus and zoom
right in there and we have the import
pandas as pd so go ahead and draw a line
up there you can see that the pandas as
pd add a little drawing thing in there
to make it easier to see pandas is a
data set it's a really nice package you
can add into your python usually it's
done as pandas as pd that's very common
to see the pd here let's circle that
it's basically like an excel spreadsheet
it adds columns it adds some headers it
adds a lot of functionality to look at
your data and the first thing we're
going to do with that is we're going to
come down here and we're going to read
and this is a csv it's a csv file you
can open up the file on your computer if
you want if you need access to the file
you can either search it and download it
from the main thing or type a note in
down below on the youtube video and
simply learn will help you get that file
also and that's true of any questions
you have on this you can add comments
down there and somebody at simplylearn
actually keeps an eye on that and we'll
try to answer those questions for you i
put in the full path you don't have to
if you have your data files saved in the
same folder you're running your program
in and this is just a csv file
comma-separated variables and with the
pandas we can read it in there and we're
going to give it put it right in a
variable called diabetes and then
finally we take diabetes and you'll see
diabetes.head this is a pandas command
and it's really nice because it just
displays the data for us let me go ahead
and erase that and so we go up to the
run button up here in our jupyter
notebook which runs the script in this
that's a cell we're in and you can see
with thediabetes.head
since it's a pandas data frame it prints
everything out nice and neat for us this
is really great and if i go ahead and do
a control minus i can get it all to fit
on the same screen and this is the first
five lines when you do the head of the
data it just prints out the first five
lines in programming of course we start
with zero so we have zero one two three
and four there we go we have yeah here
we go we start with zero we have zero
one two three and four we have our
titles going across the top and of
course the first column is number of
pregnancies glucose concentration for
the second one blood pressure
measurements of triceps as we keep going
you'll see you can guess what most of
these things are group i'm not sure this
is probably the test group i didn't look
it up to see specifically what that is
anytime you start exploring data and for
this example we don't really need to get
too much in detail you want to know the
domain what does this information mean
are we duplicating information going in
that's beyond the scope of this for
right now though we're just going to
look at this data and we're going to
take apart the different pieces of this
data so let's jump in there and take a
look at what the next set of code is so
in our next setup or our next step we
got to start looking at cleaning the
data we got to start looking at these
different columns and how are we going
to bring them in which columns are what
i'm going to jump ahead a little bit and
also as we look at the columns we're
going to do our import our tensorflow as
tf that's a common import that's our
tensorflow model tensorflow was
developed by google and then they put it
into open source so that it's free for
everybody to use which is always a nice
thing so let's take a look at what these
two steps look like in our jupyter
notebook so let's paste this code in
here and
this is something that happens when
you're messing with data is you'll
repeat yourself numerous times we
already have diabetes head so i'm going
to put the little pound sign which tells
python that this is just going to be a
comment we're not going to run it a
second time in here we have
dot columns and then diabetes columns to
norm equals diabetes columns to
norm.apply lambda x let's talk about
that but let me first run that and let's
see that comes out with that and then
let's put the next set of code in also
and i'm going to run that let me just
hit the run button it doesn't really
have an output but we did a lot of stuff
here so let's go over what we did on
this so i've turned on my drawing
implement to help go through all this
there's a lot going on here the first
thing is we have all of our columns up
here all of our column names let me just
highlight that and draw a circle around
that like we did earlier and we want to
look at just specific columns and we're
going to start let me change the color
on this so it really sticks out i'll use
like a blue i'm going to look at these
columns and we're not going to do age
class or group we're going to look at
those in a different way and i'll
explain in a little bit what that's
about so we're looking at number of
pregnancies
basically anything that can be read as a
float number and you might say age could
be read as a float number we're going to
address that differently because when
you're doing statistics we usually take
the ages and we group them into buckets
and we'll talk about that and so we're
going to take these columns and we're
going to do what they call normalize
them call them to normalize what is
normalize if you're using the sk learn
module one of their neural networks they
call it scaling or scalar this is in all
of these neural networks what happens is
if i have two pieces of data and let's
say
one of them is in this case zero to six
and one of them is in insulin level is
zero to maybe point two would be a very
high level i don't know what they
actually go to a neural network we'll
look at this six and it'll go zero to
six and as you get into 0 6 here's an 8
even a higher number it will weight
those heavier and so it'll skew the
results based more on the number of
pregnancies than based on the insulin or
based on the blood pressure so we want
to level the playing field we want these
values to all be in the same area we do
that by normalizing it here and we use a
lambda function this is always a kind of
a fun thing we take the diabetes it's a
panda set up and let me just erase all
that so we can go down here put it back
to red and we take our diabetes which is
a panda data set and we only want to
look at the columns to normalize because
that's what we built we built a list of
those columns and we're going to apply
a lambda function and you'll see lambda
and all kinds of python programming it
just means it's a function we put x in
and whatever is outside of the x over
here it then takes that and returns that
value so
the new value is going to be whatever x
is
minus x min again it's a pandas data set
so we can get by with that which is
really cool makes it easy to read so we
take x we look for the minimum value of
x and then we divide that by the maximum
value x minus the x min or the width and
what this essentially does is if you're
going from 0 to 15
it's going to divide by 15 and then we
subtract it let's let's make this 2
instead of 0. or 20 20 to 115 there we
go first off we set this to zero so we
subtract x min so right off the bat the
minimal value is going to be zero and
then we divide it by the difference here
x min minus x max or x max minus x min
this basically sets all the values
between zero to one and that's very
important if we want to make sure that
it's not going to be a skew in the
results if it's not going to weight the
values one direction or the other zero
to one that's what this is doing and
again there's like so many different
ways to scale our data this is the most
basic scale it's standard scaling and
it's the most common and we spelled it
out in the lambda you can there's actual
um modules that do that uh but lambda is
just it's such an easy thing to do and
you can see really see what we're doing
here so now we've taken these columns
we've scaled them all and changed them
to a zero to one value we now need to
let the program know the tensorflow
model that we're going to create we need
to let it know what these things are so
to do that i create a variable called
number pregnancy keep it simple and
we've imported the tensorflow as tf one
line of code brings our tensorflow in
for us awesome love python so you get
number of pregnancies and tf.feature
column.numeric column we're going to
tell it's a numeric column so it knows
that this is a float value zero to one
and then number underscore pregnant so
we're taking that column we've reshaped
that column from zero to one and now
that doesn't mean you have a point one
pregnancy just means zero point one
equals one or something number pregnant
so we're just mapping this data so
tensorflow knows what to do with it and
we go through all of these we go through
all the way up to again we're not doing
age let me just separate age down here
these have all been adjusted age we're
going to handle differently we still put
it as a numerical column because it is
so let me just circle age and group we
didn't even touch group yet we're going
to look at group and h and we're going
to do some special stuff with that class
we're going to look at last why because
this is whether they have diabetes or
not that's what we're testing for so
this is our history we know these people
have diabetes or not and we want to find
out we want to create a model and then
we want to test that model predicting
whether somebody new has diabetes or not
so here i am still with my cup of coffee
working away refill number three let's
explore both the categorical group which
is going to be the a b c and d on the
end and also the age we're going to talk
about those a little bit more and then
we're going to combine all those
features and we'll jump into splitting
the data although that's kind of the
next step but we'll put that all
together what are we doing with the age
and what are we doing with the group
down there so let's flip on over and
take a look at our
jupiter notebook so the first thing is
let's put this new set of code in here
and run it and let's talk about what
we're doing on this set of code in i
actually want to go one more step
forward on the next set of code or part
of it there we go and i can go and just
run that well we have it that's fine
let's just scroll up a little bit here
and let's go through what we just did
with this set of code if we go back up
here to the top part we have group b c b
b c we learned from the header so when i
come down here we're going to create a
signed group and let me get my drawing
pad out so we're looking at this first
one up here assigned group tf feature
column categorical column with
vocabulary list that is a mouthful this
is saying that this is a categorical
list in this case we have a b c d you
see this a lot in tensorflow a lot of
times tensorflow is used to analyze text
or logs error logs and they're just full
of all this information and they take
these in this case a b c d but in other
cases it'd be words and they create
numbers out of them so it has zero this
is one column this is another column
this is another column this is another
column and it's just this way of being
able to look at this in a different
light and assigning them different
values you really don't want to assign
this a float value first thought might
be let's assign this 0 to 3 0 1 2 3 for
a b c d but if you did that it would try
to add 1 plus 2 to get 3 as part of its
math and functions and that just isn't
true c does not equal a plus b
c is just a categorical name it could
have been the frank group and laura's
group in a bids group but it's not you
know these are they're not float numbers
so very important you have that
distinction in your data the next step
we're looking at is our map plot and
we're going to do this this is a cool
useful tool we're going to import
matplot library dot pi plot as plt
that's standard import and this next
line here is really important we're
doing the map plot library we want it to
be inline that's because we're in a
jupiter notebook remember i told you
before that if you're running this in a
different ide you might get a different
result
this is the line you need if you want to
see the graph on this page and then we
do diabetes we're going to look at just
the age and dot hist bins equals 20.
what the heck is that well it turns out
that because this is remember it's a
pandas there's our pd pandas as pd
because this is a pandas panda
automatically knows to look for the
matplot library and a hist just means
it's going to be a histogram and we're
going to separate it into 20 bins and
that's what this graph is here so when i
take the diabetes and i do a histogram
of it it produces this really nice graph
we can see that at 22 most of the
participants in this probably around
174 of the people that were
recorded were of this age bracket
they're right here in this this first
column here and as they get further and
further down they have less and less and
less until when you're at 80 you can
actually see down here there's almost
none in a couple of these categories and
this is important to note because when
you're doing census you know the older
the the group is the more the people
have passed away so you're going to have
this in any of your senses you take
you're always going to have a much
larger group in the younger crowd and
then it gets lower and lower as they get
older and i mentioned the word buckets
here we go we're going to create an age
bucket we're going to put people in
buckets can you imagine people sitting
in buckets kind of a funny way of
looking at it this just makes it easier
for us to separate it when i go to the
doctor's office i don't want to be told
well your age 22 this is you know you'll
get a decent one at 22.
here we are back to my cup of coffee i
told you coffee was an underlying theme
these next couple steps are very
specific to tensorflow up until now we
had some tensorflow as we set the
categories up but you'd have to set that
up with any model you use to make sure
they're set correctly they'd be set up a
little differently but we run input
functions and in tensorflow this allows
for some really cool things to happen
and this is why tensorflow is so
predominant in a lot of areas so let's
take a look at these next couple lines
of code here we're going to create the
input function and we're going to go
ahead and create the model and let me go
ahead and put these codes in here i went
ahead and split it up so it's different
lines so we can talk a little bit about
that and then the actual model and let
me go ahead and
run this so we can see what that looks
like and in my particular environment it
just prints out a little bit of
information about the model not too
worried about looking at that but we do
want to take a closer look at what we
did here so we've created an input
function and again this is very specific
to tensorflow with the input function we
have our train we have our x equals x
train and our y equals y train because
we want to train it with a particular
information but we have these other
settings in here these two settings and
the number of epics is how many times
it's going to go over our training model
epic means large that means all the data
so we're going to go over it a thousand
times that's actually a huge overkill
for this amount of data usually it only
needs probably about 200 but you know
when we're putting it together and
you're trying things out you just kind
of throw the numbers in there and then
you go back and fine-tune it sometimes
the batch size is really important this
is where tensorflow does some really
cool things if you're processing this
over a huge amount of data and you try
to batch everything at once you end up
with a problem this means we're only
going to read 10 lines at a time through
our data so each one of those rows of
testing they've done we're only going to
look at 10 of them at a time and put
that through our model and train it and
then shuffle self-explanatory we're just
moving we're just randomly selecting
which data and what order we go in that
way if there's like you know five in a
row that are kind of weighted one way
and vice versa it mixes them up and then
finally we create our model so the model
goes in there and goes okay i have a tf
dot estimator dot linear classifier
we're going to put in the feature
columns equals feature columns we
defined all our columns up above and
then we have in classes equal to and
that just means we have our out result
is zero or one you have diabetes or you
don't have diabetes or in this case we
actually call it high risk of diabetes
and then i put one more line of code in
there which i forgot we've set up our
model we set up our feature columns now
we need to actually train it model.train
you'll see this
so common in so many different neural
network models this is like a standard
what's different though is we have to
feed it the function remember we created
this function with all this information
on it and then we have steps in
steps similar to number batches and
batch size it's more like a individual
lines we step through a thousand is a
lot more common for steps than epics but
steps is used you probably leave this
out in this particular example and let's
go ahead and run this all together
because it has a site when we start
training it we get a different output so
here we go i've run it it's given me the
information from when i created the
model and now it just starts going
through we get this information tensor
loss equals global step all kinds of
stuff going on here and if you're
following this it's just going through
the steps and training it it gives you
information you could dig deep into here
but for this particular setup we're not
going to go too deep on what's going on
just know that we've trained our model
this model now has the information we
need in it to start running predictions
so as we sip our next um take our next
step of coffee or maybe it's tea or if
you're one of those strange late night
workers maybe it's a sip of wine we go
into the next step and we actually want
to run some predictions on here but we
don't want to run the training we want
to run the test on there we want to take
our test data and see what it did and so
that's what we're going to do next is
we're going to run the test through and
actually get some answers so if you were
actually deploying it you would pull the
answers out of the data it's bringing
back let's take a look at that in our
jupyter notebook so here we go let's
paste it in there i'm going to go ahead
and run it and you'll see that as it
goes it's actually putting the answers
out if you remember correctly well we'll
walk through this here in just a second
but it goes through and it runs each
line and it gives you a prediction for
each line one at a time and prints them
out so let's take a look and see what
that actually looks like let's start
with this first part we've created
another function this is just like the
other function except for
x equals x test and there's no y why is
there no y because we don't know what
the answer is on this yet we don't want
to tell it the answer we wanted to guess
what the answer is so we can evaluate
that and see how good it did on that 33
of the data so this is our x test batch
size is 10 again so if we were watching
this roll down here we would see that it
actually processes it 10 lines at a time
it's only going to go through once it
goes through all the x test data one
time we don't need to have it predict
multiple times and shuffle equals false
very important we set the shuffle to
false because if we were tracking this
and actually giving people answers we'd
want to make sure it connects to the
right person so they get the right
results of course we're just doing this
to evaluate it so let's take a look down
here what it put out and as i scroll
down to my jupiter notebook we have some
information as far as the tensorflow
running and then the actual output and
if we look at the output we know by this
first bracket in python it's an array we
know um by this uh squiggly bracket that
this is a dictionary so that this is a
label the dictionary has logistic
probabilities class ids classes and so
this whole first part let me redo that
this whole first part is one
output and we know that because there is
the bracket there and there is this
bracket here for the dictionary and it's
a dictionary of terms so if i pulled
this out i looked at object 0 in here i
would go down to let me just find it
here it is classes remember how we
define classes we define classes as our
answer and so it's guessing our
tensorflow says based on all the
information you gave me i'm guessing
this first entry of our first test data
is high risk diabetes uh oh go get
tested change your diet watch what
you're eating you know high risk one and
if we go down far enough we can see down
here is another one where classes equal
zero i skipped a couple because they're
all ones up here the b
this particular output b
in front of the one means it's a binary
output it only comes out as zero or one
and there's a lot of other information
in here you can dig deep into tensorflow
and explain these different numbers
that's way beyond the scope of what
we're working on today so the basics of
it though is you get an output and we
have an output of whether the person has
diabetes or not well in this case it's
high risk of diabetes or not so now that
we've run our predictions take a sip of
coffee a little short break and we say
well what do we need to do well we need
to know how good was our predictions we
need to evaluate our model so if you're
going to publish this to a company or
something like that they want to know
how good you did let's take a look at
what that looks like in the code so
let's paste that in here and
just real quick go back over this by now
this function should look very uh this
is we're going to call it eval input
function it should be pretty
straightforward here we have our tf
estimator inputs pandas input function
and then we have our x test our y test
so this time we want to give it the
answer so it has something to see how
good it did on batch is 10 processing 10
at a time we're only going once through
the data we're not shuffling it although
it doesn't really matter with this and
then we're going to do results equals
model.evaluate and we put our evaluation
function in there this should all look
familiar because we're repeating the
same thing it's very similar with a
couple different changes as far as what
we're feeding it and the fact that we're
doing an evaluation let's see what that
looks like when we run it and we go up
here to our run model you'll see
warnings on some of these because i
didn't install this on its own install
so a lot of it is just temporary files
because i'm using the jupiter notebook
instead of setting it up on a regular
machine and we get our output and we'll
go ahead and just look at this output
real quick and then we'll flip over and
from here you'll see that it generates
an accuracy a baseline average loss the
mean gives you a precision prediction it
gives you all kinds of information on
here so let's flip over and see what's
important and we'll look at the slide
here we are in this slide and this
should be exciting because we just about
wrapped up our whole tensor flow and
tensorflow is one of the more
complicated models out there so give
yourself a pat on the back for getting
all the way through this when we look at
this output we have an accuracy of 0.716
that's really what we want to look at
that means that we have an accuracy if
you're just truncating it of 71 percent
that's quite good for our model you know
given a small amount of data we came up
with a 71 percent of letting people know
they're high risk or not with diabetes
so we created a model that can predict
if a person has diabetes based on some
previous records of people who were
diagnosed with diabetes and we've
managed to have an accuracy of 71
percent which is quite good the model
was implemented on python using
tensorflow again pat yourself on the
back because tensorflow is one of the
more complicated scripts out there it's
also one of the more diverse and useful
ones i am keefner and today we shall be
talking about the top 10 artificial
intelligence technologies
so
without further ado let's quickly jump
into the topic
in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices virtual agents speech
recognition
augmented reality
machine learning
robotic process automation
decision management
deep learning and
finally image recognition please note
that the list is in no particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence and is a trendy technology
that converts the structured data into a
native language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are a tvo
automated insights
sas cambridge semantics digital
reasoning narrative science
etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smart phones
smart speakers
etc
virtual agents they are
computer-generated intelligence that
provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our queries
in simple virtual agents are a
manifestation of a technology which aims
to create an effective
but digital impersonation of humans
virtual agents can make reservations
book an appointment
place an order and can even avail
product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant and amazon
alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are microsoft google amazon and
assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another sub
discipline of artificial intelligence
which is used to convert human speech
into a comprehensive and useful format
for computer applications to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used on interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are nuanced
communications open text nice and
variant systems
augmented reality yet another trendy
technology in the field of artificial
intelligence augmented reality is an
enhanced version of the real physical
world that is achieved using sound
digital visual elements and other
sensory stimuli delhi worldwide
technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
alters the perception of the real world
environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and furnishing much more fun
and interactive
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
machine learning
machine learning is an application and
an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machines
being able to learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis
big data and applications and training
tools
enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction
some of the sample vendors are amazon
fractal analytics google
microsoft etc robotic process automation
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
fields like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce human
talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are pika systems
automation anywhere blue prism
etc
next on the list we have decision
management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
insurance sector
e-commerce and many more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica advanced systems
concepts pica systems
mana
etc deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct fluid ai
math works
saffron technology
etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces detect license plates and
diagnose diseases the present-day image
recognition is compatible to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users
clarify gums and sensetime provide this
technology
what do you think is making our lives
easier off late and how do you think the
world is rapidly changing imagine
getting into a car feeding your
destination as the input and
automatically getting dropped off at
your destination at the same time you
sit back and relax through the ride
without having to do anything at all
physically whoa life has become so much
simpler with all kinds of automation
taking us through everyday life what do
you think is making all this possible
artificial intelligence thanks to
numerous advancements in technology
which is bringing about a lot of changes
in our day-to-day lives to drive
innovation ai is using machine learning
taking things one step further so what
exactly do you mean by artificial
intelligence
in simple terms ai refers to simulating
a machine with human intelligence and
programming the device to think and act
like humans artificial intelligence also
called machine intelligence is far
beyond roboz as portrayed by science
fiction from google search algorithm to
amazon's alexa to apple siri to
self-driven cars ai progresses rapidly
towards a harmonious future between
technology and man bringing together the
best of both worlds
since the machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence and perform tasks as we do
it's termed as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956.
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry solving algebra
word problems and much more between the
1950s and 1970s neural networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world now
is the era of deep learning the boons of
ai undoubtedly ai has changed our lives
in many ways at number one we have
safety factor there are many fields like
defense mining etc where human health is
at significant risk ai is the biggest
boon in these fields where a robo or a
drone does the work instead of a human
with the invention of self-driven cars
ai is aiding at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition ai helps in effective
communication by processing and
understanding the language spoken by
humans it is also capable of
comprehending the words spoken by humans
and reciprocate in the same way all this
is possible by the voice assistant
feature which the ai bots have at number
three we have daily needs
be it alexa or apple siri we are
surrounded by various applications that
run on ai fingerprint detection face
detection gps grammarly all these run on
artificial intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket buying a
product online and driving a car ai has
limited human interaction and provides
various services in all the unexpected
ways ai is helping humans in the
day-to-day needs
at number four we have healthcare ai is
a promising tool for supporting
healthcare administration it helps
healthcare workers and stakeholders to
manage vast amounts of data and
transform them into potentially
life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the core
with 19 coronavirus a who report
released said that er is a vital part of
the response to this disease ai systems
are being developed predicting people's
temperatures and survival rates with
more than 90 percent accuracy one
promising approach of ai in the field of
health care is it guides vaccine design
as covet 19 began to spread globally
machine learning tools were used to
search immunogenic components of the
virus that would make good vaccine
candidates yet another field where the
ml is significantly evolving is genomics
which is the study of the complete set
of genes within an organism ai can
sequence and analyze dna much faster
cheaper and accurate than the
researchers ever will at number five we
have robus one of the most amazing
inventions by humans that thinks
intelligently and acts autonomously the
disinfecting robots are playing a
significant role in these uncertain
times they rove around healthcare
facilities spreading uv light to
disinfect places contaminated with
viruses
the benefits of ai robust far exceed the
apprehensions
speaking of role of technology
advancements
artificial intelligence is rapidly
advancing with a lot of computers and
robots capable of doing miracles though
the machines and robots cannot have
human feelings they can think and act
like humans
companies use techniques like machine
learning and neural networks to
accomplish artificial intelligence which
is also called machine intelligence in
the present scenario considering the
total intelligence we can conclude that
95 of it is machine intelligence and the
remaining 5 is what we call human
knowledge
speaking of ai versus human ai has a
positive as well as a negative impact on
us and society according to some recent
studies seven million existing jobs will
be replaced by ai in the uk between 2017
and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created as well
a study from mckinsey global institute
states that by 2030 automation will
replace 400 to 800 million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cause fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries the
biggest challenge is how people would
make a living with these changes and
uncertainty
google ceo sundar pichai has claimed
that ai will be more transformative to
humanity than electricity ever will
google even launched an ai system which
bet some of the best atari 2600 game
players
also did you know that the best chess
player in the world is a machine how
would it be when the best doctor in the
world is a machine the best teacher is a
machine the best architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots ais and
robos will replace fast food joints and
radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
your robo will perform your surgery it
won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field warning by musk
this is extremely important
i think the danger of ai is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by a lot
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and mark my words
ai is far more dangerous than nukes
or
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways not everyone is ready to
welcome ai with open arms some ai
experts like stephen hawking and elon
musk have warned us about the looming
dangers that ai maker says to humanity
they have even suggested that ai is
likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species
elon musk says that he is close to the
cutting edge in ai which scares him a
lot ai is vastly more than almost anyone
knows and the rate of improvement is
exponential he also says that ai is far
more dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat ai can be
harmful to us in two different ways the
idea that ai will become conscious and
responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes
if the super intelligent ai more
intelligent than us becomes conscious we
will look at humans like how humans will
look at monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey where
one of the most well-known ais turned
terrible the terminator the matrix and
few others
these movies have speculated about ai
that far exceeds the expectations of its
creators and escapes their control
eventually targeting humans for
extinction
speaking of the real reasons to be
afraid of ai
there are doctors engineers accountants
judges architects who seek information
from an ei system they treat this
information as it is from a trusted
colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong ai researchers pride
themselves on the accuracy of results it
is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake these systems do not
fail gracefully one such incident is
when facebook had to shut down a
controversial chatbot experiment where
the two ais developed their own language
for communication a research was
conducted with two chatbots named alice
and bob focusing on how to negotiate
with each other unfortunately the
researchers found that the bots had
deviated from the actual script and had
started inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left unsupervised they developed
their machine language which was
otherwise developed to converse with
people that's the scary part of ai
neural networks and deep learning the
developers and researchers working on
this would have no idea what it's doing
this technology can get complicated and
we have to make sure what we are doing
with it holds value we must also handle
it cautiously because ai is a direct
reflection of us people should lead and
not follow so here's the question should
we be afraid of ai
we all know that ai is a transformative
technology that we have ever seen in the
history of humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power it
has the potential to be transformative
both for good reasons as well as for the
wrong however fear of the unknown has
always been the case with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what ai is
ai is defined by the algorithms that
dictate its behavior and operate under
definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness what if an
ai machine starts to have human feelings
and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas also we don't
think that is anywhere in our near
future
pretty much any type of machine can be
used for either good or bad reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop or pause
in a ted talk peter huss says
imagine you're driving up a mountain and
it's raining very heavily as you climb
into the mountains the rain is turning
into snow and pretty soon that snow is a
white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you you start skidding you
see some vehicle was coming to crash
into you all this wouldn't have happened
if you paused your journey as the rain
was getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now
that rain will turn into snow soon and
that snow could quickly become a
dangerous blizzard so we need to pause
check the conditions put in place safety
standards and ask ourselves how far we
want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people in
the loop
spot checking what the ai algorithms are
doing keeping people in the loop will
probably solve some of our most
significant challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier however evolved these am
machines are they still lack human
empathy and consciousness
so instead of running away from this
technology we should understand this
revolutionary technology and make sure
it is used in the right way to make our
lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning you can check
out simplylearn's postgraduate program
in ai and machine learning in
partnership with purdue university ever
wondered how google translates an entire
web page to a different language in a
matter of seconds or your phone gallery
group's images based on their location
all of this is a product of deep
learning but what exactly is deep
learning deep learning is a subset of
machine learning which in turn is a
subset of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a technique
that enables a machine to mimic human
behavior machine learning is a technique
to achieve ai through algorithms trained
with data and finally deep learning is a
type of machine learning inspired by the
structure of the human brain in terms of
deep learning this structure is called
an artificial neural network let's
understand deep learning better and how
it's different from machine learning say
we create a machine that could
differentiate between tomatoes and
cherries if done using machine learning
we'd have to tell the machine the
features based on which the two can be
differentiated these features could be
the size and the type of stem on them
with deep learning on the other hand the
features are picked out by the neural
network without human intervention of
course that kind of independence comes
at the cost of having a much higher
volume of data to train our machine
now let's dive into the working of
neural networks
here we have three students each of them
write down the digit nine on a piece of
paper
notably they don't all write it
identically the human brain can easily
recognize the digits
but what if a computer had to recognize
them
that's where deep learning comes in
here's a neural network trained to
identify handwritten digits
each number is present as an image of 28
times 28 pixels now that amounts to a
total of 784 pixels
neurons the core entity of a neural
network is where the information
processing takes place
each of the 784 pixels is fed to a
neuron in the first layer of our neural
network
this forms the input layer
on the other end we have the output
layer with each neuron representing a
digit with the hidden layers existing
between them
the information is transferred from one
layer to another over connecting
channels
each of these has a value attached to it
and hence is called a weighted channel
all neurons have a unique number
associated with it called bias
this bias is added to the weighted sum
of inputs reaching the neuron
which is then applied to a function
known as the activation function
the result of the activation function
determines if the neuron gets activated
every activated neuron passes on
information to the following layers
this continues until the second last
layer
the one neuron activated in the output
layer corresponds to the input digit the
weights and bias are continuously
adjusted to produce a well-trained
network so where is deep learning
applied in customer support when most
people converse with customer support
agents the conversation seems so real
they don't even realize that it's
actually a bot on the other side in
medical care neural networks detect
cancer cells and analyze mri images to
give detailed results self-driving cars
what seem like science fiction is now a
reality apple tesla and nissan are only
a few of the companies working on
self-driving cars so deep learning has a
vast scope but it too faces some
limitations the first as we discussed
earlier is data while deep learning is
the most efficient way to deal with
unstructured data a neural network
requires a massive volume of data to
train let's assume we always have access
to the necessary amount of data
processing this is not within the
capability of every machine and that
brings us to our second limitation
computational power training a neural
network requires graphical processing
units which have thousands of cores as
compared to cpus and gpus are of course
more expensive and finally we come down
to training time deep neural networks
take hours or even months to train the
time increases with the amount of data
and number of layers in the network so
here's a short quiz for you arrange the
following statements in order to
describe the working of a neural network
a the bias is added b the weighted sum
of the inputs is calculated c specific
neuron is activated d the result is fed
to an activation function leave your
answers in the comments section below
some of the popular deep learning
frameworks include tensorflow pytorch
keras deep learning 4j cafe and
microsoft cognitive toolkit considering
the future predictions for deep learning
and ai we seem to have only scratched
the surface in fact horus technology is
working on a device for the blind that
uses deep learning with computer vision
to describe the world to the users
replicating the human mind at the
entirety may be not just an episode of
science fiction for too long the future
is indeed full of surprises and that is
deep learning for you in short
there are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
cleaned it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from paris
because it is able to recognize the
eiffel tower so
the way it works internally if we have
to look a little bit under the heart as
these images are nothing but this is
digital information in the form of
pixels so each image could be a certain
size it can be 256 by 256 pixel kind of
a resolution and then each pixel is
either having a certain grade of color
and all that is fed into the neural
network and it then gets trained in and
it's able to based on these pixels pixel
information it is able to get trained
and able to recognize the features and
extract the features and thereby it is
able to identify these images and the
location of these images and then when
you feed a new image it kind of based on
the training it will be able to figure
out where this image is from so that's
the way a little bit under the hood how
it works so what are we going to do in
this tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural networks so
we will see what is neural network what
is a perceptron and how to implement
logic gates like and or nor and so on
using perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks
works so how do we do the training of
and
and we will end up with a small demo
code
which will take you through in
tensorflow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and tensorflow is one
of them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensorflow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
an example which is a very common one
which is like the hello world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at mnist database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see
in this particular
video so let's get started what is deep
learning deep learning is like a subset
of what is known as a high level concept
called artificial intelligence you must
be already familiar must have heard
about this term artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligence is like the
high level concept if you will and in
order to implement artificial
intelligence applications we use what is
known as machine learning and within
machine learning a subset of machine
learning is deep learning machine
learning is a little bit more
generic concept and deep learning is one
type of machine learning if you will and
we will see a little later in maybe the
following slides a little bit more in
detail how deep learning is different
from traditional machine learning but to
start with we can mention here that deep
learning uses one of the differentiators
between deep learning and traditional
machine learning is that deep learning
uses neural networks and we will talk
about what are neural networks and how
we can implement neural networks and so
on and so forth as a part of this
tutorial so little deeper into deep
learning deep learning primarily
involves working with complicated
unstructured data compared to
traditional machine learning with where
we normally use
structured data in deep learning the
data would be primarily images or voice
or maybe text files so and it is large
amount of data as well and deep learning
can handle complex operations it
involves complex operations and the
other difference between traditional
machine learning and deep learning is
that the feature extraction happens
pretty much automatically in traditional
machine learning feature engineering is
done manually the data scientists we
data scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as i mentioned one of
the secret
sources of deep learning is neural
networks let's see what neural networks
is neural networks is based on our
biological
neurons the whole concept of deep
learning and artificial intelligence is
based on human brain and human brain
consists of billions of tiny stuff
called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has
billions of biological neurons and we
are trying to simulate the human brain
using artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see what exactly
weights in biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on now in neural
network one of the very basic
units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron a perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs x 1 x 2 x 2 x n and
there is a summation function and then
there is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted if it is wrong if there is
an error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjusts the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth so that's what is known as
the training process of a neuron or a
neural network there's a concept called
perceptron learning so perceptron
learning is again one of the very basic
learning processes the way it works is
somewhat like this so you have all these
inputs like x1 to xn and each of these
inputs is multiplied by a weight and
then that sum this is the formula of the
equation so that sum w i x i
sigma of that which is a sum of all
these product of x and w is added up and
then a bias is added to that the bias is
not dependent on the input but are the
input values but the bias is common for
one neuron however the bias value keeps
changing during the training process
once the training is completed the
values of these weights w1 w2 and so on
and the value of the bias gets fixed so
that is basically the whole training
process and that is what is known as the
perceptron training so the weights and
biases keep changing till you get the
accurate output and the summation is of
course passed through the activation
function as you see here this w i x i
summation plus b
is passed through activation function
and then the neuron gets either fired or
not and based on that there will be an
output that output is compared with the
actual or expected value which is also
known as labeled information so this is
the process of supervised learning so
the output is already known and
that is compared and thereby we know if
there is an error or not and if there is
an error the error is fed back and the
weights and biases are updated
accordingly till the error is reduced to
the minimum so this iterative process
is
known as perceptron learning or
perceptron learning rule and this error
needs to be minimized so till the error
is minimized
this iteratively the weights and biases
keep changing and that is what is the
training process so the whole idea is to
update the weights and the bias of the
perceptron till the error is minimized
the error need not be zero the error may
not ever reach zero but the idea is to
keep changing these weights and bias so
that the error is minimum the minimum
possible that it can have so this whole
process is an iterative process and this
is the iteration continues till either
the error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
within these given conditions now in
1943 two scientists warren mccollux and
walter pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical gates which could take two
inputs like a and b and then
give a corresponding result so for
example in case of an and gate a
and b and then the output is a b in case
of an or gate it is a plus b and so on
and so forth and they were able to do
this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gates
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for xor and we will
see why that is in a little bit so this
is how an and gate works the inputs a
and b the output should be fired or the
neuron should be fired only when both
the inputs are one so if you have zero
zero the output should be zero for 0 1
it is again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 1 the
output should be
1. so how do we implement this with a
neuron so it was found that by changing
the values of weights it is possible to
achieve this
logic so for example if we have equal
weights like 0.7 0.7 and then if we take
the sum of the weighted products so for
example 0.7 into 0 and then 0.7 into 0
will give you 0 and so on and so forth
and in the last case when both the
inputs are 1 you get a value which is
greater than 1 which is the threshold so
only in this case the neuron gets
activated and the output is there is an
output in all the other cases there is
no output because the threshold value is
one so this is implementation of an and
gate using a single perceptron or a
single neuron similarly an or gate in
order to implement an or gate in case of
an or gate the output will be one if
either of these inputs is one so for
example zero one will result in one or
other in all the cases it is one except
for zero zero so how do we implement
this using a perceptron once again if
you have a perceptron with weights for
example 1.2 now if you see here if in
the first case when both are 0 the
output is 0 in the second case when it
is 0 and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0 and then 1.2
into 1 is 1. and in the second case
similarly the output is 1.2 in the last
case when both the inputs are 1 the
output is 2.4 so during the training
process these weights will keep changing
and then at one point where the weights
are equal to w1 is equal to 1.2 and w2
is equal to 1.2 the system learns that
it gives the correct output so that is
implementation of or gate using a single
neuron or a single layer perceptron now
xor gate this was one of the challenging
ones they tried to implement an xor gate
with a single level perceptron but it
was not possible and therefore in order
to implement an xr so this was like a
roadblock in the progress of
neural network however subsequently they
realize that this can be implemented an
xor gate can be implemented using
a multi-level perceptron or mlp so in
this case there are two layers instead
of a single layer and this is how you
can implement an xor gate so you will
see that x1 and x2 are the inputs and
there is a hidden layer and that's why
it is denoted as h3nh4 and then you take
the output of that and feed it to the
output at o5 and provide a threshold
here so we will see here that this is
the numerical calculation so the weights
are in this case for x1 it is 20 and
minus 20 and once again 20 and minus 20.
so these inputs are fed into h3 and h4
so you'll see here for h3 the input is 0
1 1 1 and for h4 it is 1 0 1 1 and if
you now look at the output final output
where the threshold is taken as 1 if we
use a sigmoid with the threshold one you
will see that in these two cases it is
zero and in the last two cases it is one
so this is a implementation of xor in
case of x or only when one of the inputs
is one you will get an output so that is
what we are seeing here if we have
either both the inputs are one or both
the inputs are zero then the output
should be zero so that is what is an
exclusive or gate so it is exclusive
because only one of the inputs should be
one and then only you will get an output
of one which is satisfied by this
condition so this is a special
implementation xor gate is a special
implementation of perceptron now that we
got a good idea about perceptron let's
take a look at what is the neural
network so we have seen what is a
perceptron we have seen what is a neuron
so we will see what exactly is a neural
network so neural network is nothing but
a network of these neurons and they are
different types of neural networks there
are about five of them these are
artificial neural network convolutional
neural network then recursive neural
network or recurrent neural network deep
neural network and deep belief network
so and each of these types of neural
networks have a special you know they
can
solve special kind of problems for
example convolutional neural networks
are very good at performing image
processing and image recognition and so
on whereas rnn are very good for speech
recognition and also text analysis and
so on so each type has some special
characteristics and they can they're
good at performing certain special kind
of tasks what are some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning is today used extensively in
gaming you must have heard about alphago
which is a game created by a startup
called deepmind which got acquired by
google and alphago is an ai which
defeated the human world champion lee
sedol in this game of go so gaming is an
area where deep learning is being
extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks a special type
called generative adversarial networks
which can be used for synthesizing
either images or music or text and so on
and they can be used to compose music so
the neural network can be trained to
compose a certain kind of music and
autonomous cars you must be familiar
with google google's self-driving car
and today a lot of automotive companies
are investing in this space and deep
learning is a core component of this
autonomous cars the cars are trained to
recognize for example the road
the lane markings on the road
signals any objects that are in front
any obstruction and so on and so forth
so all this involves deep learning so
that's another major application and
robots we have seen several robots
including sofia you may be familiar with
sophia who was given a citizenship by
saudi arabia and there are several such
robots which are very human like and the
underlying technology in many of these
robots is deep learning medical
diagnostics and health care is another
major area where deep learning is being
used and within healthcare diagnostics
again there are multiple areas where
deep learning and image recognition
image processing can be used for example
for cancer detection as you may be aware
if cancer is detected early on it can be
cured and one of the challenges is in
the availability of specialists who can
diagnose cancer using these diagnostic
images and various scans and and so on
and so forth so the idea is to train
neural network to perform some of these
activities so that the lord on the
cancer specialist doctors or oncologists
comes down and there is a lot of
research happening here and there are
already quite a few applications that
are claimed to be performing better than
human beings in this space can be
lung cancer it could be breast cancer
and so on and so forth so health care is
a major area where deep learning is
being applied let's take a look at the
inner working of a neural network so how
does an artificial neural network let's
say identify can we train a neural
network to identify the shapes like
squares and circles and triangles when
these images are fed so this is how it
works any image is nothing but it is a
digital information of the pixels so in
this particular case let's say this is
an image of 28 by 28 pixel and this is
an image of a square there's a certain
way in which the pixels are lit up and
so these pixels have a certain value
maybe from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that
it is
black or it is dark and 256 indicates it
is completely it is white or lit up so
that is like an indication or a measure
of the how the pixels are lit up and so
this is an image is let's say consisting
of information of
784 pixels so all the information what
is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into this 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so
we can train neural networks to use that
information and identify the images so
let's take a look how this works so each
neuron the value if it is close to one
that means it is white whereas if it is
close to zero that means it is black now
this is a an animation of how the
salting works so these pixels one of the
ways of doing it is we can flatten
this image and take this complete 784
pixels and feed that as input to our
neural network the neural network can
consist of probably several layers there
can be a few hidden layers and then
there is an input layer and an output
layer now the input layer take the 784
pixels as input the values of each of
these pixels and then you get an output
which can be
of three types or three classes one can
be a square a circle or a triangle now
during the training process there will
be initially obviously you feed this
image and it will probably say it's a
circle or it will say it's a triangle so
as a part of the training process
we then
send that error back and the weights and
the biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is a square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out here
now let's take a look at a circle same
way
so you feed these 784 pixels there is a
certain pattern in which the pixels are
lit up
and the neural network is trained to
identify that pattern
and during the training process once
again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back
and the weights and biases are adjusted
finally till it finally gets the image
correct
so that is the training process so now
we will take a look at
same way a triangle
so now if you feed another image which
is consisting of triangles so this is
the training process now we have trained
our neural network to classify these
images into
a triangle or a circle and a square so
now this neural network can
identify these three types of objects
now if you feed another image and it
will be able to identify whether it's a
square or a triangle or a circle now
what is important to be observed is that
when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that
the image or the the triangle is exactly
in this position now the neural network
actually
identifies the patterns so even if the
triangle is let's say positioned here
not exactly in the middle but maybe at
the corner or in the side it would still
identify that it is a triangle and that
is the whole idea behind
pattern recognition so how does this
training process work this is a quick
view of how the training process works
so we have seen that a neuron consists
of inputs it receives inputs and then
there is a weighted sum which is nothing
but this x i wi summation of that plus
the
bias and this is then fed to the
activation function and that in turn
gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights w1 w2 up to wn keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values it
could be 0.5 0.25 0.35 and so on it
could be positive or it could be
negative and the value that is coming
here is the pixel value as we have seen
it can be anything between 0 to 1 you
can scale it between 0 to 1 or 0 to 256
whichever way 0 being black and 256
being white and then all the other
colors in between so that is the input
so these are numerical values this
multiplication or the product w i x i is
a numerical value and the bias is also a
numerical value we need to keep in mind
that the bias is fixed for a neuron it
doesn't change with the inputs whereas
the weights are one per input so that is
one important point to be noted so but
the bias also keeps changing initially
it will again have a random value but as
a part of the training process the
weights the values of the weights w1 w2
wn and
the value of b
will change and ultimately once the
training process is complete these
values are fixed for this particular
neuron w1 w2 up to wn and plus the value
of the b is also fixed for this
particular neuron and in this way there
will be multiple neurons and each there
may be multiple levels of neurons here
and that's the way the training process
works so this is another example of
multi-layer so there are two hidden
layers in between and then you have the
input layer values coming from the input
layer then it goes through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the training
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model and
those values will be fixed once the
training is completed all right then
there is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be 0
or 1 is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum remember we talked about w
i x i plus b that weighted sum is fed as
an input to the activation function and
then the output can be either a zero or
a one and there are different types of
activation functions which are covered
in an earlier video you might want to
watch all right so as a part of the
training process we feed the inputs the
label data or the training data and then
it gives an output which is the
predicted output by the network which we
indicate as y hat and then there is a
labeled data because we for supervised
learning we already know what should be
the output so that is the actual output
and in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error and
the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so
and then
all the errors are added which can
sometimes be called as sum of squares
sum of square errors or sse and that is
then fed as a feedback in what is known
as backward propagation or back
propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function
is
minimum now there is a optimization
technique which is used here called
gradient descent optimization and this
algorithm
works in a way that the error which is
the cost function
needs to be minimized so there's a lot
of mathematics that goes behind this for
example they find the local minima the
global minima using the differentiation
and so on and so forth but the idea is
this so as a training process as the as
a part of training the whole idea is to
bring down the error which is like let's
say this is the function
the cost function at certain levels it
is very high the cost value of the cost
function the output of the cost function
is very high so
the weights have to be adjusted in such
a way and also the bias of course that
the cost function is minimized so there
is this optimization technique called
gradient descent that is used and this
is known as the learning rate now
gradient descent
you need to specify what should be the
learning rate and the learning rate
should be optimal because if you have a
very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
side on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimization
the error function is reduced and that's
like the end of
the training process all right so this
is another view of gradient descent so
this is how it looks this is your cost
function the output of the cost function
and that has to be minimized using
gradient descent algorithm and these are
like the parameters and weight could be
one of them so initially we start with
certain random values so cost will be
high and then the weights keep changing
and in such a way that the cost function
needs to come down and at some point it
may reach the minimum value and then it
may increase so that is where the
gradient descent algorithm decides that
okay it has reached a minimum value and
it will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradient descent and then this is
another example so you can have these
multiple local minima as you can see at
this point when it is coming down it may
appear like this is a minimum value but
then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient is
an algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensorflow and so
that's the reason we have this tutorial
we've created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using python and tensorflow is
an open source platform created by
google so let's just take a look at the
details of tensorflow and so this is a
library a python library so you can use
python or any other languages it's also
supported in other languages like java
and r and so on but python is the most
common language that is used so
it is a library for developing
deep learning applications especially
using neural networks and it consists of
primarily two parts if you will so one
is the tensors and then the other is the
graphs or the flow that's the way the
name that's the reason for this kind of
a name called tensorflow so what are
tensor sensors are like
multi-dimensional
arrays if you will that's one way of
looking at it so
usually you have a one-dimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one-dimensional
array something like this which means
this like a set of numbers so that is a
one-dimensional array then you can have
a dimensional array which is like a
matrix
and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three dimensional
array but tensorflow can handle many
more dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional
arrays that is the strength of
tensorflow and which makes computation
deep learning computation much faster
and that's the reason why tensorflow is
used for developing deep learning
applications so tensorflow is a deep
learning tool and this is the way it
works so the data basically flows in the
form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually
execute that particular graph in the
form of what is known as a session we
will see this in the tensorflow code as
we move forward so all the data is
managed or manipulated in tensors and
then the processing happens using these
graphs there are certain terms called
like for example ranks of a tensor the
rank of a tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just a one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one dimensional
vector in which case the rank is
supposed to be one and then you can have
a two-dimensional vector typically like
a matrix then in that case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store
multi-dimensional arrays in the form of
tensors so what are some of the
properties of tensorflow i think today
it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or library
it is open source
it's developed by google developed and
maintained by google but it is open
source one of the most important things
about tensorflow is that it can run
on cpus as well as gpus
gpu is a graphical processing unit just
like cpus central processing unit now in
earlier days gpu was used for primarily
for
graphics and that's how the name has
come and one of the reasons is that it
cannot perform generic activities very
efficiently like cpu
but it can perform
iterative actions or computations
extremely fast and much faster than a
cpu so they are really good for
computational activities and in deep
learning there is a lot of iterative
computation that happens so in the form
of matrix multiplication and so on so
gpus are very well suited for this kind
of computation and tensorflow supports
both gpu as well as cpu and there's a
certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we go into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is
just a suggestion but if you are already
familiar with how tensorflow works then
probably yeah you can go straight into
the neural networks part so in this
tutorial we will take the use case of
recognizing handwritten digits this is
like a hello world
of deep learning and this is a nice
little mnist database is a nice little
database that has images of handwritten
digits nicely formatted because very
often in deep learning and neural
networks we end up spending a lot of
time in preparing the data for training
and with mnist database we can avoid
that you already have the data in the
right format which can be directly used
for training and mnist also offers a
bunch of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have test just
like in any machine learning process and
then you have validation and all of them
are labeled so you have the images and
their label and these images they look
somewhat like this so they are hand
written images collected from a lot of
individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have handwritten these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and
the data is basically these images are
stored in the form of the pixel
information as we have seen in one of
the previous slides all the images are
nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler
neural network configurations called
softmax and for simplicity what we will
do is we will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are 784px
so pixel number one starts here it goes
all the way up to 28 then 29 starts here
and goes up to 56 and so on and the
pixel number 784 is here so we take all
these pixels flatten them out and feed
them like one single line into our
neural network and this is a what is
known as a softmax layer what it does is
once it is trained it will be able to
identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is strained
properly and
if you feed
a number 9 like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get
activated now let's say you fade one to
the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as softmax layer so that's what we
will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so
this is how the code would look we will
go into our lab environment in the cloud
and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks
and let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of
10 digits and let's say the number is
eight okay so in this case all the
remaining values there will be a bunch
of zeros so this is like array at
position zero this is at position one
position two and so on and so forth
let's say this is position 7 then this
is position 8 that will be 1 because our
input is 8 and again position 9 will be
0 okay so one hot encoding this one hot
encoding true will kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can
check how the data is looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and
this tells you how many images are there
in each set so the training there are 55
000 images in training and in the test
set there are 10 000 and then validation
there are 5 000 so all together there
are 70 000
all right so let's
move on and we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a
matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons
and similarly there are biases now
remember i mentioned bias is only one
per neuron so it is not one per input
unlike the weights so therefore there
are only 10 biases because there are
only 10 neurons in this case so that is
what we are creating a variable for
biases so this is something little new
in tensorflow you will see unlike our
regular programming languages where
everything is a variable here the
variables can be of three different
types you have placeholders which are
primarily used for feeding data you have
variables which can change during the
course of computation and then a third
type which is not shown here are
constants so these are like fixed
numbers all right so in a regular
programming language you may have
everything as variables or at the most
variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication tf you
remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmal function so
that is what is being used here in this
case so we are using the matrix
multiplication of tensorflow so that you
multiply your input values x with w
right this is what we were doing x w
plus b you're just adding b and this is
in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn soft max cross entropy with
logits is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a slide somewhat like
this and then you define what should be
the learning rate how fast you need to
come down that is the learning rate and
this again needs to be tested and tried
and to find out the optimum level of
this learning rate it shouldn't be very
high in which case it will not converge
or shouldn't be very low because it will
in that case it will take very long so
you define the optimizer and then you
call the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kickstart the training process
and so far we've been creating the graph
and in order to actually execute that
graph we create what is known as a
session and then we run that session and
once the training is completed we
specify how many times how many
iterations we want it to run so for
example in this case we are saying
thousand steps so that is a exit
strategy in a way so you specify the
exit condition so training will run for
thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can install tensorflow on your
local machine as well i'm showing this
demo on our existing cloud but you can
also install tensorflow on your local
machine and there is a separate video on
how to set up your tensorflow
environment you can watch that if you
want to install your local environment
or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can
use and
run then try the code okay so it has got
started
we will log in
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial
code and this is our tensorflow
environment
and
so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through
in the slides as well now you will see
the actual code in action so the first
thing we need to do is import tensorflow
and then we will import the data and we
need to adjust the data in such a way
that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array
of type float32
similarly
the number if you want to see what is
the number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5 000. now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55 000
and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is uh showing now we can take just uh
one image and just see what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now i
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
5 000
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
again 8. so basically by the way if
you're wondering uh how i'm executing
this code shift enter
in case you're not familiar with jupiter
notebooks shift enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between 1 and 0. now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10 actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value
so this is another placeholder we had x
as one placeholder and white underscore
true as a second placeholder and this
will have values in the form of uh 10
digit 10 digit arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to
view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have created the variables
how to load the data loaded the data
viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for
doing any execution in tensorflow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a node for initializing
so this is a node you still are not yet
executing anything here you just created
a node for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a width loop so you have a with
tf dot session as says and with the
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says dot
run init now says dot run will execute a
node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that
says and then we run
a node within that one of the nodes in
the graph so one of the nodes here is
init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w
is a variable and b is a variable so any
variables that we created you have to
run this code you have to run the
initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this with block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for
thousand steps and perform
the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of
performing deep learning training you
always do in batches so we have maybe 50
000 images but you always do it in
batches of 100 or maybe
500 depending on the size of your
system and so on and so forth so in this
case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of 100 images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches 1000 iterations in this
case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set right
so this is what we are trying to do here
the code may appear a little complicated
because if you're seeing this for the
first time you need to understand the
various methods of tensorflow and so on
but it is basically comparing the output
with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf.equal right and how
many of them are correct and so on and
so forth and based on that the accuracy
is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model is around 91
okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and
so that this accuracy can be increased
beyond 90 percent let's look at the
different types of artificial neural
networks and this is like the biggest
area growing is how these all come
together let's see the different types
of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain i feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a they call it a n a neural
network data travels only in one
direction input to output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into big data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them use this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a center point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the sesame street as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system cajon and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons so
they basically find a way to draw they
call them they say dimensions or vectors
or planes because they actually chop the
data in one dimension two dimension
three dimension four five six they keep
adding dimensions and finding ways to
separate the data and connect different
data pieces together applications used
to recognize patterns and data like in
medical analysis the hidden layer saves
its output to be used for future
prediction recurrent neural networks so
the hidden layers remember its output
from last time and that becomes part of
its new input you might use that
especially in robotics or flying a drone
you want to know what your last change
was and how fast it was going to help
predict what your next change you need
to make is to get to where the drone
wants to go applications text-to-speech
conversation model so i talked about
drones but you know just identifying on
lexus or google assistant or any of
these they're starting to add in i'd
like to play a song on my pandora and
i'd like it to be at volume 90
so you now can add different things in
there and it connects them together the
input features are taken in batches like
a filter this allows a network to
remember an image in parts convolution
neural network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know you ever seen
that on google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so they
can do a face recognition on each person
applications used in signal and image
processing in this case i use facial
images or google picture images as one
of the options modular neural network it
has a collection of different neural
networks working together to get the
output so wow we just went through all
these different types of neural networks
and the final one is to put multiple
neural networks together i mentioned
that a little bit when we separated
people in a larger photo in individuals
in the photo and then do the facial
recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are into the facial recognition
applications still undergoing research
this is a cutting edge you hear the term
pipeline and there's actual in python
code and in almost all the different
neural network setups out there they now
have a pipeline feature usually and it
just means you take the data from one
neural network and maybe another neural
network or you put it into the next
neural network and then you take three
or four other neural networks and feed
them into another one so how we connect
the neural networks is really just
cutting edge and it's so experimental i
mean it's almost creative in its nature
there's not really a science to it
because each specific domain has
different things it's looking at so if
you're in the banking domain it's going
to be different than the medical domain
then the automatic car domain and
suddenly figuring out how those all fit
together is just a lot of fun and really
cool so we have our types of artificial
neural network we have our feed forward
neural network we have a radial basis
function neural network we have our
cohenon self-organizing neural network
recurrent neural network convolution
neural network and modular neural
network where it brings them all
together and no the colors on the brain
do not match what your brain actually
does but they do bring it out that most
of these were developed by understanding
how humans learn and as we understand
more and more of how humans learn we can
build something in the computer industry
to mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem statement so this
is where we jump in this is my favorite
part let's use the system to identify
between a cat and a dog if you remember
correctly i said we're going to do some
python code and you can see over here my
hair is kind of sticking up over the
computer cup of coffee on one side and a
little bit of old school a pencil and a
pen on the other side yeah most people
now take notes
i love the stickies on the computer
that's great that's that is my computer
i have sticky notes on my computer in
different colors so not too far from
today's programmer so the problem is is
we want to classify photos of cats and
dogs using a neural network and you can
see over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat it's
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well i
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the dog we have a dog too that's
a dog i want to let in maybe i don't
want to let this other animal in because
it's a raccoon so you can see where you
could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python i am
actually in python 3.6 it's always nice
to tell people the version of python
because it does affect sometimes which
modules you load and everything and
we're going to start by importing the
required packages i told you we're going
to do this in keras so we're going to
import from keras models sequential from
the cross layers conversion 2d or conv
2d max pooling 2d flatten and dents and
we'll talk about what each one of these
do in just a second but before we do
that let's talk a little bit about the
environment we're going to work in and
you know in fact let me go ahead and
open a
the website cross's website so we can
learn a little bit more about karass so
here we are on the karass website and
it's a k-e-r-a-s dot io that's the
official website for karass and the
first thing you'll notice is that cross
runs on top of either tensorflow
cntk and i think it's pronounced thanos
or theano what's important on here is
that tensorflow and the same is true for
all these but tensorflow is probably one
of the most widely used currently
packages out there with the cross and of
course you know tomorrow this is all
going to change it's all going to
disappear and they'll have something new
out there so make sure when you're
learning this code that you understand
what's going on and also know the code i
mean look when you look at the code it's
not as complicated once you understand
what's going on the code itself is
pretty straightforward and the reason we
like cross and the reason that people
are jumping on it right now is such a
big deal is if we come down here let me
just scroll down a little bit they talk
about user friendliness modularity easy
extensibility work with python python is
a big one because a lot of people in
data science now use python although you
can actually access cross other ways if
we continue down here is layers and this
is where it gets really cool when we're
working with cross you just add layers
on remember those hidden layers we were
talking about and we talked about the
relu
activation you can see right here let me
just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big i can add in an
relu layer and then i can add in a soft
max layer the next instance we didn't
talk about soft max so you can do each
layer separate now if i'm working in
some of the other kits i use i take that
and i have one set up and then i feed
the output into the next one this one i
can just add hidden layer after hidden
layer with the different information in
it which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part i'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note i'm
using anaconda with python in it and i
went ahead and created my own package
and i called it the cross python 36
because i'm in python 36. anaconda is
cool that way you can create different
environments real easily if you're doing
a lot of different experimenting with
these different packages probably want
to create your own environment in there
and the first thing as you can see right
here there's a lot of dependencies a lot
of these you should recognize by now if
you've done any of these videos if not
kudos for you for jumping in today pip
install numpy scipy the scikit learned
pillow and h5py are both needed for the
tensorflow and then putting the cross on
there and then you'll see here and pip
is just a standard installer that you
use with python you'll see here that we
did pip install tensorflow sensor we're
going to do cross on top of tensorflow
and then pip install and i went ahead
and used the github so git plus git and
you'll see here github.com this is one
of their releases one of the most
current release on there that goes on
top of tensorflow you can look up these
instructions pretty much anywhere this
is for doing it on anaconda certainly
you'd want to install these if you're
doing it in ubuntu server setup you'd
want to get i don't think you need the
h5py and ubuntu but you do need the rest
in there because they are dependencies
in there and it's pretty straightforward
and that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to initially go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when i'm under my
anaconda navigator which i like you'll
see where i have environments and on the
bottom i created a new environment and i
called it cross python 36 just to
separate everything you can see i have
python 30.5 and python 36. i used to
have a bunch of other ones but it kind
of cleaned house recently and of course
once i go in here i can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure i'm using
the right environment that i just set up
this of course opens up my in this case
i'm using google chrome and in here i
can go and just create a new document in
here and this is all in your browser
window when you use the anaconda do you
have to use anaconda and jupyter
notebook no you can use any kind of
python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential it's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2d max pooling 2d
flatten dense and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly i talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the cross do
it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
jupiter is nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and i'll go
ahead and also zoom in there a little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee
if you're familiar with my other videos
you notice i'm always sipping coffee i
always have a my case latte next to me
an espresso so the next step is to go
ahead and initialize we're going to call
it the cnn or classifier neural network
and the reason we call it a classifier
is because it's going to classify it
between two things it's going to be cat
or dog so when you're doing
classification you're just picking
specific objects your specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so their sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and the next step is to add
in our convolution and let me just do a
let me shrink that down in size you can
see the whole line and let's talk a
little bit about what's going on here i
have my classifier and i add something
what am i adding well i'm adding my
first layer this first layer we're
adding in is probably the one that takes
the most work to make sure you have it
set correct and the reason i say that
this is your actual input and we're
going to jump here to the part that says
input shape equals 64 by 64 by 3. what
does that mean well that means that our
picture is coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64 by 64 pixels and
each pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches i mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that keras knows
what your shape is coming in here and it
knows what's coming out and so that
really sets the stage most important
thing is that input shape matches your
data coming in and you'll get a lot of
errors if it doesn't you'll go through
there and picture number 55 doesn't
match it correctly and guess what it
does it usually gives you an error and
then the activation if you remember we
talked about the different activations
on here we're using the relu model like
i said that is the most commonly used
now because one it's fast doesn't have
the added calculations in it it just
says here's the value coming out based
on the weights and the value going in
and
from there you know it's uh it's if it's
over one then it's good or over zero
it's good if it's under zero then it's
considered not active and then we have
this conversion 2d what the heck is
conversion 2d i'm not going to go into
too much detail in this because this has
a couple of things it's doing in here a
little bit more in-depth than we're
ready to cover in this tutorial but this
is used to convert from the photo
because we have 64 by 64 by three and
we're just converting it to two
dimensional kind of setup so it's very
aware that this is a photograph and that
different pieces are next to each other
and then we're going to add in a second
convolutional layer that's what the conv
stands for 2d so these are hidden layers
so we have our input layer and our two
hidden layers and they are
two-dimensional because we're doing with
a two-dimensional photograph and you'll
see down here that on the last one we
add a max pooling 2d and we put a pool
size equals 2 2. and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the big data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two dimensions by we actually
have 64 by 64 by three so now we're just
getting it down to a two by two just the
two dimension two dimensional instead of
having the third dimension of colors and
we'll go ahead and run these we're not
really seeing anything on our run script
because we're just setting up this is
all set up and this is where you start
playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes cross
so nice is i can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier add a flattened setup and
then we're going to also add a layer a
dense layer and then we're going to add
in another dense layer and then we're
going to build it we're going to compile
this whole thing together so let's flip
over and see what that looks like and
we've even numbered them for you so
we're going to do the flattening and
flatten is exactly what it sounds like
we've been working in a two-dimensional
array of picture which actually is in
three dimensions because of the pixels
the pixels have a whole nother dimension
to it of three different values and
we've kind of resized those down to two
by two but now we're just going to
flatten it i don't want to have multiple
dimensions being worked on by tensor and
by karas i want just a single array so
it's flattened out and then step four
full connection so we add in our final
two layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so once we take all those different
the two dimensions or three dimensions
as they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 2128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
plus 64 is 128. you could probably even
do this with 64 or 32. usually you want
to keep it in the same multiple whatever
the data shape you're already using is
in and we're using the activation the
relu just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
because we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog if you love both
dogs and cats
you're gonna have to choose and then we
use the sigmoid activation if you
remember from before we had the relu and
there's also the sigmoid the sigmoid
just makes it clear it's yes or no we
don't want any kind of in-between number
coming out and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it's still all in
setup and then finally we want to go
ahead and compile and let's put the
compiling our classifier neural network
and we're going to use the optimizer
atom and i hinted at this just a little
bit before where does adam come in where
does an optimizer come in well the
optimizer is the reverse propagation
when we're training it it goes all the
way through and says error and then how
does it readjust those weights there are
a number of them atom is the most
commonly used and it works best on large
data most people stick with the atom
because when they're testing on smaller
data see if their model is going to go
through and get all their errors out
before they run it on larger data sets
they're going to run it on atom anyway
so they just leave it on atom most
commonly used but there are some other
ones out there you should be aware of
that that you might try them if you're
stuck in a bind or you might floor that
in the future but usually atom is just
fine on there and then you have two more
settings you have loss and metrics we're
not going to dig too much into loss or
metrics these are things you really have
to explore cross because there are so
many choices this is how it computes the
error there's so many different ways to
on your back propagation and your
training so we're using the atom model
but you can compute the error by
standard deviation standard deviation
squared they use binary cross entropy
i'd have to look that up to even know
what that is there's so many of these a
lot of times you just start with the
ones that look correct that are most
commonly used and then you have to go
read the cross site and actually see
what these different losses and metrics
and what different options they have so
we're not going to get too much into
them other than to reference you over to
the karass website to explore them
deeper but we are going to go ahead and
run them and now we've set up our
classifier so we have an object
classifier and if you go back up here
you'll see that we've added in step one
we added in our layer for the input we
added a layer that comes in there and
uses the relu for activation and then it
pulls the data so this is even though
these are two layers the actual neural
network layer is up here and then it
uses this to pull the data into a two by
two so into two dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our adder
flatten and then we add another dense
what they call dense layer this dense
layer goes in there and it downsizes it
to 128 it reduces it so you can look at
this as we're mapping all this data down
the two-dimensional setup and then we
flatten it so we map it to a flattened
map and then we take it and reduce it
down to 128
and we use the relu again and then
finally we reduce that down to just a
single output and we use the sigmoid to
do that to figure out whether it's yes
no true false in this case cat or dog
and then finally once we put all these
layers together we compile them that's
what we've done here and we've compiled
them as far as how it trains to use
these settings for the training back
propagation so if you remember we talked
about training our setup and when we go
into this you'll see that we have two
data sets we have one called the
training set and the testing set and
that's very standard in any data
processing is you need to have that's
pretty common in any data processing is
you need to have a certain amount of
data to train it and then you got to
know whether it works or not is it any
good and that's why you have a separate
set of data for testing it or you
already know the answer but you don't
want to use that as part of the training
set so in here we jump into part two
fitting the classifier neural network to
the images and then from cross let me
just zoom in there i always love that
about working with jupiter notebooks you
can really see we're going to come in
here we do the cross pre-processing and
image and we import image data generator
so nice of course it's such a high-end
product right now going out and since
images are so common they already have
all this stuff to help us process the
data which is great and so we come in
here we do train data gin and we're
going to create our object for helping
us train it for reshaping the data so
that it's going to work with our setup
and we use an image data generator and
we're going to rescale it and you'll see
here we have one point which tells us
it's a float value on the rescale over
255. where does 255 come from well
that's the scale in the colors of the
pictures we're using their value from 0
to 255. so we want to divide it by 255
and it'll generate a number between 0
and 1. they have shear range and zoom
range horizontal flip equals true and
this of course has to do with if the
photos are different shapes and sizes
like i said it's a wonderful package you
really need to dig in deep to see all
the different options you have for
setting up your images for right now
though we're going to stick with some
basic stuff here and let me go ahead and
run this code and again it doesn't
really do anything because we're still
setting up the pre-processing let's take
a look at this next set of code and this
one is just huge we're creating the
training set so the training set is
going to go in here and it's going to
use our train data gen we just created
dot flow from directory it's going to
access in this case the path data set
training set that's a folder so it's
going to pull all the images out of that
folder now i'm actually running this in
the folder that the data sets in so if
you're doing the same setup and you load
your data in there and you're doing this
make sure wherever your jupyter notebook
is saving things to that you create this
path or you can do the complete path if
you need to you know see colon slash etc
and the target size the batch size and
class mode is binary so the classes
we're switching everything to a binary
value back size what the heck is batch
size well that's how many pictures we're
going to batch through the training each
time and the target size 64 by 64. a
little confusing but you can see right
here that this is just a general
training and you can go in there and
look at all the different settings for
your training set and of course with
different data we're doing pictures
there's all kinds of different settings
depending on what you're working with
let's go ahead and run that and see what
happens and you'll see that it found 800
images belonging to one classes so we
have 800 images in the training set and
if we're going to do this with the
training set we also have to format the
pictures in the test set now we're not
actually doing any predictions we're not
actually programming the model yet all
we're doing is preparing the data so
we're going to prepare a training set
and the test set so any changes we make
to the training set at this point also
have to be made to the test set so we've
done this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so i'm going to do the same
thing with that i'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale 1 over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found 2
000 images that's about right we're
using 20 of the images as test and 80 to
train it and then finally we've set up
all our data we've set up all our layers
which is where all the work is is
cleaning up that data making sure it's
going in there correctly and we're
actually going to fit it we're going to
train our data set and let's see what
that looks like and here we go let's put
the information in here and let's just
take a quick look at what we're looking
at with our fit generator we have our
classifier dot fit generator that's our
back propagation so the information goes
through forward with the picture and it
says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the air goes backward and
reprograms all those weights so we're
training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training set up
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8 000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 25 times
but we're going to look at each picture
during each epic 8 000 times so we're
really programming the heck out of this
and going back over it and then they
have validation data equals test set so
we have our training set and then we're
going to have our test set to validate
it so we're going to do this all in one
shot and we're going to look at that and
they're going to do 200 steps for each
validation and we'll see what that looks
like in just a minute let's go ahead and
run our training here and we're going to
fit our data and as it goes it says epic
1 of 25 you start realizing that this is
going to take a while on my older
computer it takes about 45 minutes i
have a dual processor and we're
processing uh 10 000 photos that's not a
small amount of photographs to process
so if you're on your laptop you know
which i am it's going to take a while so
let's go ahead and go get our cup of
coffee and a sip and come back and see
what this looks like so i'm back you
didn't know i was gone that was actually
a lengthy pause there i made a couple
changes and let's discuss those changes
real quick and why i made them so the
first thing i'm going to do is i'm going
to go up here and insert a cell above
and let's paste the original code back
in there and you'll see that the
original thing was steps per epic 8 000
25 epics and validation steps 2 000 and
i change these to 4 000 epics or 4 000
steps per epic
10 epics and just 10 validation steps
and this will cause problems if you're
doing this as a commercial release but
for demo purposes this should work and
if you remember our steps per epic
that's how many photos we're going to
process in fact let me go ahead and get
my drawing pin out and let's just
highlight that right here we have 8 000
pictures we're going through so for each
epic i'm going to change this to four
thousand cut that in half so it's going
to randomly pick 4 000 pictures each
time it goes through an epic and the
epic is how many processes so this is 25
and i'm just going to cut that to 10 so
instead of doing 25 runs through 8 000
photos each which you can do the math of
25 times 8 000. i'm only going to do 10
through 4 000. so i'm going to run this
40 000 times through the processes and
the next thing i know that you'll you'll
want to notice is that i also change the
validation step and this would cause
some major problems in releasing because
i dropped it all the way down to 10.
what the validation step does is it says
we have 2 000 photos in our trainings or
in our testing set and we're going to
use that for validation well i'm only
going to use a random 10 of those to
validate so not really the best settings
but let me show you why we did that
let's scroll down here just a little bit
and let's look at the output here and
see what that what's going on there so
i've got my drawing tool back on and
you'll see here it lists a run so each
time it goes through an epic it's going
to do 4000 steps and this is where the
4000 comes in so that's what we have we
have epic one of 10 4 thousand steps is
randomly picking half the pictures in
the file and going through them and then
we're gonna look at this number right
here that is for the whole epic and
that's 2411
seconds and if you remember correctly
you divide that by 60 you get minutes if
you divide that by 60 you get hours or
you can just divide the whole thing by
60 times 60 which is 3600. if 3600 is an
hour this is roughly 45 minutes right
here and that's 45 minutes to process
half the pictures so if i was doing all
the pictures we're talking an hour and a
half per epic times 36 or no 25 they had
25 up above 25. so that's roughly a
couple days a couple days of processing
well for this demo we don't want to do
that i don't want to come back the next
day plus my computer did a reboot in the
middle of the night so we look at this
and we say okay let's we're just testing
this out my computer that i'm running
this on is a dual core processor runs
0.9 gigahertz per second for a laptop it
was good about four years ago but for
running something like this is probably
a little slow so we cut the times down
and the last one was validation we're
only validating it on a random 10 photos
and this comes into effect because
you're going to see down here where we
have accuracy value loss
value accuracy and loss those are very
important numbers to look at so the 10
means i'm only validating across 10
pictures that is where here we have
value this is acc is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the epic what's our accuracy into
the epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important let's just put that up there
and bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means i'm
memorizing the photos i'm looking at i'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat i'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the cross
neural network is a lot of built-in
features like this that make that really
easy to track so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next set of code so here
we are into part three we're going to
make a new prediction and so we're going
to bring in a couple tools for that and
then we have to process the image coming
in and find out whether it's an actual
dog or cat we can actually use this to
identify it and of course the final step
of part three is to print prediction
we'll go ahead and combine these and of
course you can see me there adding more
sticky notes to my computer screen
hidden behind the screen and
last one was don't forget to feed the
cat and the dog
so let's go and take a look at that and
see what that looks like in code and put
that in our jupiter notebook all right
and let's paste that in here and we'll
start by importing numpy as np numpy is
a very common package i pretty much
imported on any python project i'm
working on another one i use regularly
is pandas they're just ways of
organizing the data and then np is
usually the standard in most machine
learning tools as a return for the data
array although you know you use the
standard data array from python and we
have cross pre-processing import image
fish that all look familiar because
we're going to take a test image and
we're going to set that equal to in this
case cat or dog one as you can see over
here and you know let me get my drawing
tool back on so let's take a look at
this we have our test image we're
loading and in here we have test image
one and this one hasn't data hasn't seen
this one at all so this is all new hope
let me shrink the screen down let me
start that over so here we have my test
image and we went ahead and the cross
processing has this nice image set up so
we're going to load the image and we're
going to alter it to a 64 by 64 print so
right off the bat we're going to cross
is nice that way it automatically sets
it up for us so we don't have to redo
all our images and find a way to reset
those and then we use also to set the
image to an array so again we're all in
pre-processing the data just like we
pre-processed before with our test
information and our training data and
then we use the numpy here's our numpy
that's from our right up here important
numpy as in p expand the dimensions test
image axes equals zero so it puts it
into a single array and then finally
all that work all that pre-processing
and all we do is we run the result we
click on here we go result equals
classifier predict test image and then
we find out well what is the test image
and let's just take a quick look and
just see what that is and you can see
when i ran it it comes up dog and if we
look at those images there it is cat or
dog image number one that looks like a
nice floppy eared lab
friendly with his tongue hanging out
it's either that or a very floppy eared
cat i'm not sure which but according to
our software says it's a dog and uh we
have a second picture over here let's
just see what happens when we run the
second picture we can go up here and
change this from dog image one to two
we'll run that and it comes down here
and says cat you can see me highlighting
it down there as cat so our process
works you are able to label a dog a dog
and a cat a cat just from the pictures
there we go cleared my drawing tool and
the last thing i want you to notice when
we come back up here to when i ran it
you'll see it has an accuracy of 1 and
the value accuracy of 1. well the value
accuracy is the important one because
the value accuracy is what it actually
runs on the test data remember i'm only
testing it on i'm only validating it on
a random 10 photos and those 10 folders
just happened to come up one now when
they ran this on the server it actually
came up about 86
this is why cutting these numbers down
so far for a commercial release is bad
so you want to make sure you're a little
careful of that when you're testing your
stuff that you change these numbers back
when you run it on a more enterprise
computer other than your old laptop that
you're just practicing on or messing
with and we come down here and again you
know we have the validation of cat and
so we have successfully built a neural
network that could distinguish between
photos of a cat and a dog imagine all
the other things you could distinguish
imagine all the different industries you
could dive into with that just being
able to understand those two difference
of pictures what about mosquitoes could
you find the mosquitoes that bite versus
mosquitoes that are friendly it turns
out the mosquitoes that bite us are only
four percent of the mosquito population
if even that maybe two percent there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of industries sprouting up
and i said it before i'll say it again
what an exciting time to live in with
these tools and that we get to play with
let's start with deep learning
frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled um justice
because it's just exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's a cross
which happens to sit on tensorflow so
they're very integrated there's
tensorflow
pie torches out there cafe piano dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow let's see
what is tensorflow what is tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
library released in 2015 by google brain
team for building machine learning and
deep learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow addresses and does a very
good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have so
you when you're working with other
people or showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company
you can give them a nice visual model so
they know what's going on what are they
paying for and let's take a glance at
some of the different uses or
applications for tensorflow when we talk
about tensorflow applications
uh clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term this is the programming side
and it's really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation
fraud detection video detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
uh think of complicated chaotic data
this is very different than if you have
a set numbers like you're looking at the
stock market you can use this on the
stock market but if you're doing
something where the numbers are very
clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks and
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor um that's what this is named
after so we talk about tensors in
tensorflow tensorflow is derived from
its core component known as a tensor a
tensor is a vector or a matrix of n
dimensions that represent all types of
data and you can see here we have the
scalar which is just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers
might be a number in a direction you
have a simple matrix and then we get
into the tensor i mentioned how a
picture is a very complicated tensor
because it has your x y coordinates and
then each one of those pixels
has three to four channels for your
different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point and then you have your
vector which would be a single list of
numbers
so it's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank three
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at
the basics of a neural network in
reverse propagation that is the basics
of tensorflow and then it goes through a
lot of different options and properties
that you can build into your different
tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs it has
nodes that represent the operations in
your model and if you
look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs b c and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus four
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because you can actually
one of the tensors is a neural network
with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic uh flow of
computations of the data going across
and you can see we can plug in the
numbers b equals 4 c equals 3 d equals 6
and you get x equals 4 plus 3
so x equals 7 y equals 6 minus 4 so y
equals 2 and finally a equals 7 times 2
or a equals 14. like i said this is a
very simplified version of how
tensorflow works each one of these
layers can get very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these different models to see how
they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.cross cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other
so everything's going in a sequential
order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensor 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model and then you can
add all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
uh so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version uh tensorflow
1 0 the python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word and you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction where you do
a linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like on the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of set up
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture
we have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 percent
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your premade estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you gonna run it
you're gonna be running it on just your
regular cpu are you gonna be running it
uh with the gpu added in like i have a
pretty high-end graphics card so it
actually grabs that gpu processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized tpu
setup in there that you paid extra money
for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package you
might need to run this on some really
high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
uh let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a
to give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of endpoints and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow setup so constants in
tensorflow in tensorflow constants are
created using the function constant in
other words they're gonna stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with
the syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way so you
can create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice uh
2x3
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have uh
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just a jupiter
notebook but with tabs for larger
projects we're going to stick with
jupiter notebook
pie charm whatever it is you're going to
use in here you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 36
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version three
six
if you have python version three seven
or three eight you're probably going to
get some errors in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your tensorflow or if you're in
anaconda you can do a conda install
tensorflow to make sure it's in your
package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just
demo for the right size go under new
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled let's
go ahead and import import tensorflow as
tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know uh what
version we're working with and we can do
that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf.underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4 3 6 1.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where i can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you'd surround it in print and
you can see it's a tf tensor it has the
shape the type and the and the array on
here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
and create a variable and this is also
going to be a two by two array and if we
go ahead and print the v out we'll run
that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
uh then we can also let's just go back
up here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
uh we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the v and
with the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
so those are a couple of things to note
in here
and just like any other array in math we
can do like a concatenate or concatenate
the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so let's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axes equals one this means
we're doing the columns so if you had a
longer array like right now we have an
array that is like you know has a shape
one whatever it is two comma two
axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes 1
is going to be your second one and it
translates as columns and rows
if we had a shape let me just put the
word shape here
so you know what i'm talking about is
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axes one you know zero one two that's
gonna be our columns uh and if you can
do columns then we also can do rows and
that is simply just changing the
concatenate uh we'll just grab this one
here and copy it we'll do the whole
thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and change this from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that
you'll see that now we concatenate by a
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format i find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes the second thing i want you to
notice is this says a numpy array so
tensorflow is utilizing numpy as part of
their format as far as python is
concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up uh more than
you would think is filling uh one of
these with zeros or ones and so you can
see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of
the shape three comma four of zeros one
of the things i want to highlight here
is integer 32 if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a tf float 16 in
this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32-bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with
zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand uh i use this for
masking you can do a lot of work with
masking you can also have it might be
that
one tensor row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of uh four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
we'll go ahead and run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that now i just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off
kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take this
same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor uh and then we're gonna go ahead
and print
our
tensor
let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
uh sorry integer 32 set up and uh
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
one of the things that is important to
be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is the same as
reshaping
so when you transpose you're just doing
a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so there are so many times you
have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors uh we'll go
ahead and create a
as a constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a 2 by 2 array
but instead
we're going to do just a 2 by 1 array
and the code for that is your dot mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times four plus nine times two
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
uh so the matrix or your matrix
multiplier is a very commonly used
back-end tool as far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 2032 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times 5 is 20 4
times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and zeros across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows
two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the scoops
the script for that got a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use
for that let's go back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new
python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you've got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full um
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports uh date times warning scipy sci
pi is your
math or the back end scientific math uh
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions um and so
sometimes when you get warnings you want
to go ahead and just suppress them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborne for our graphics and the
seaborn as sns is going to be set on top
of our matplot library which we import
as mpl and then of course we're going to
import our matplot library pie plot as
plt and right off the bat we're going to
set some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch add
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our matplot library is going to
be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library inline then
warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our
uh slide there was three different
options let me just flip back over there
so we can have a quick
recall on that and so in cross uh we
have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential
and then we have our layers and let's
talk a little bit about these layers
this is where cross and tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers uh
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short-term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer away so
there's a lot of stuff in here we have
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers
and our dense layers you have an input
layer a dense layer
and then we've added a more customized
one with the long term short term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is white cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality dot csv and let's go ahead and
take a quick look at that this is in
open office it's just a standard you
know like we do excel whatever you're
using for your spreadsheet and you can
see here we have a number of columns a
number of rows it actually goes down to
like 8 000.
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row
is bendung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
10 without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames equals pd.read csv
and then our the path to it just happens
to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bandung
the
date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done
three rows
uh five rows ten whatever you want to
put in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time it's come in in two
columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through the whole
setup and we're going to list tab append
df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
types date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df date time equals combined date
time
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this uh we
now have our setup on here and of course
it's added it on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the format's
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this we want to convert it into hourly
data so let's go ahead and do that
to do that to finish combining our date
time let's go ahead and create a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame how
do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up so that it
looks right on here and you know it just
takes time to to get through all that
but that is usually what the companies
are paying you for that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second data frame here let me just get
rid of the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time 03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date one two three and so on so
let's group the data together so there's
a lot more manageable and in the format
we want and in the right sequential
order
and if we go back to um there we go our
air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1
we can simply do the quantile 0.25
percent
which should match
our 25 up here and we'll be looking at
the min the max
and we're just going to do this it's
basically we're breaking this down for
each
different
variable in there
one of the things is kind of fun to do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here um clean out some of our um
we're going to drop a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values in the
first row is just our titles so that's
important it's important to drop those
rows in here and so this right here as
we look at our different quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each uh column individually and
so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science uh things we can look at
that's important
is uh use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now
we're looking at this and you can see
right here here's our attribute for our
o3 so we've broken it down uh we have
our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go back up
here here's our 5 8 we've rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go
q1 minus 1.5 times iqr and the iqr is
your q3 minus q1 so that's the
difference between our two different
quarters this is all uh data science um
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
uh that means something's going wrong
there and they usually in this case is
going to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outlier is found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know
crime detection what are we looking for
we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals min iqr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iq
are x equals
null we're going to set it to null why
because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x max
iqr is 100 percent
min iqr is men iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
h2m
you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it
we have our outliers um
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left
linear as it's going to fill that data
in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df-2i interpolate that's what we're
doing
again this is all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data uh
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and and use
a logarithmic function on the temp value
and uh
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you have to even know to
use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain
specific we're talking about being an
expert in air care i'm not an expert in
air care um you know it's not what i go
look at i don't look at air care data in
fact this is probably the first air care
data set up i've looked at but the
experts come in there and they come to
you and say hey in data science this is
a exponentially variable variable on
here so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way using a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side
and we'll just go ahead and do a quick
histogram and this is kind of nice plot
of figure figure size here's our plt
from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
sciences scientist the first thing i
note is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale
to 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjust it a little bit based on some
kind of a skew on there so let's jump
into we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set uh
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
uh and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size
and then if we go and print this let me
just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value that are going to be
for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
set up in here we create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back minus one
uh
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it uh
let me go ahead and just put that code
in here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um what
we're going to train the data with is
yesterday's data yesterday says hey the
humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there uh and so our
we're looking forward to the next piece
of data which says hey tomorrow's is
going to you know today's community is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data we
have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
so we're going to do is we're going to
add one more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension
and then we have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one again this
is our tr our x in and of course our
test x and then our y is just a single
column because we're just doing one
output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network uh and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model and we'll do this
sequential model
and if remember sequential means it just
goes in order that means we have if you
have two layers the layers go from layer
one to layer two or layer zero to layer
one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory
and we have our input shape which it
comes in again this is what all this
switching was we could have easily made
this one two three or four going back as
far as the end number on there we just
stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error or it does reverse propagation to
program the model uh so any of your
neural networks you've already looked at
that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different the real question that we want
to look at right now is where do you
find these models what kind of models do
you have available and so for that let's
go to the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api slash layers and i
always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those are set up and what we
want to do is we want to go ahead and if
you scroll down here you'll see your
core layers and here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing uh so trying
to find objects in a picture that kind
of thing uh we have pooling layers so as
you have the layers come together
usually bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on
long short term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat and the hat a
little kid's book there
it starts programming it and so you
really want to know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is now once we've built all
our different you know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these uh
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python uh you'll recognize
that we have to then fit the model
so what are we doing in here we're going
to send in our train x our train y
uh we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this um i'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow um if i'm
running this on a single machine and i
have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500 iterations uh
but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week
you know even with a a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will prail
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.8089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're retraining the
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals model predict
train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
seen the model's never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions
this helps us level it off a little bit
more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals an np
exponential m1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential m1
for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error so we have our train score
which is your math square root times the
mean square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test and let's take a look at
that because really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is and a lot of times you
actually want to put together like a
little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction and standard deviation
of data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
uh
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
um you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty like data set train predict
plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here
so we have our train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train
train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
i put it in here double no it's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
this is where the problem was is because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
test
predict plot length prediction setup on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the um the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're going to make
that red and label it test prediction
and so forth
set our ticks up this actually just put
ticks time axes gets its ticks
the little little marks there going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty does pretty good it's pretty
right on you can get a good idea what to
expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go um is this model here this
is what this is all about we worked
through all of those pieces
all the tensorflows and that is to build
this sequential model and we're only
putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well the data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course uh with any
data science putting out a pretty graph
so that your shareholders again we want
to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
in this video i will walk you through
the tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image io datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again we could go away all right and
then here onwards we do the model
preparation now what we're going to do
is we're going to use an existing neural
network model so we are not going to
chain a new one because that really will
take a long time and it needs a lot of
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the ssd with mobile net
that's the model that we are going to
use and this model is trained to detect
objects and it is readily available as
open source so we can actually use this
and if you want to use other models
there are a few more models available so
you can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are a
few more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and imported the
model and then once it is available
locally we will then load this into our
program all right so
we are loading this into memory and
the you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and we go down i'll skip
this section so this is the cell where
we are actually loading the video and
converting it into frames and then using
frame by frame we are detecting the
objects in the image so in this code
what we are doing basically is there are
a few lines of code what they do is
basically once they find an object a box
will be drawn around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image io so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
uh like car so let me just show you so
this is in this object detection folder
i have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and
you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original
traffic.mp4 and now you have here
traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car
seventy percent let us allow it to go a
little further it detects something on
top what is that truck okay so i think
because of the board on top it somehow
thinks there is a truck let's play it
some more and see if it detects anything
else so this is again a car looks like
so let us yeah so this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to cat the extension it will
automatically pick up because it is
given here and then it will run through
so very quickly once again what it is
doing is this video reader video
underscore reader has a neat little
feature or interface whereby you can say
for frame in video underscore reader so
it will basically provide frame by frame
so you're in a loop frame by frame and
then you take that each frame that is
given to you you take it and analyze it
as if it is an image individual image so
that's the way it works so it is very
easy to handle this all right so now
let's once again run just this cell the
rest of the stuff remains the same so i
will run this cell again it will take a
little while so the r classes come back
i will pause and then come back in a
little while all right so the processing
is done let's go and check the annotated
video go here so we have get annotated
mp4 let's play this all right so you can
see here it is detecting the cat and in
the beginning you also saw it detected
something else here there looks like it
detected one more object so let's just
go back and see what it has detected
here let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but uh it is
trying to detect something i think it is
saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is a cat and uh let's wait for some time
and see if it continues to detect it
when the cat turns around and moves as
well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
convolution neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image
don't worry we're going to get into the
details so we have our input layer
accepts the pixels of the image as input
in the form of arrays and you can see up
here where they've actually labeled each
block of the bird in different arrays so
we'll dive into deep as to how that
looks like and how those matrixes are
set up here hidden layer carry out
feature extraction by performing certain
calculations and manipulation so this is
the part that kind of reorganizes that
picture multiple ways until we get some
data that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs
operation to detect patterns in the
image and if you remember that
convolution means to coil or to twist so
we're going to twist the data around and
alter it and use that operation to
detect a new pattern there are multiple
hidden layers like convolution layer rel
u is how that is pronounced when that's
the rectified linear unit that has to do
with the activation function that's used
pooling layer also uses multiple filters
to detect edges corners eyes feathers
beak etc and just like the term says
pooling is pulling information together
and we'll look into that a lot closer
here so if you're if it's a little
confusing now we'll dig in deep and try
to get you squared away with that and
then finally there is a fully connected
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have a one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird
what's in it for you we're going to
cover an introduction to the cnn what is
convolution neural network how cnn
recognizes images we're going to dig
deeper into that and really look at the
individual layers in the convolutional
neural network and finally we do a use
case implementation using the cnn we'll
begin our introduction to the cnn by
introducing the pioneer of convolutional
neural network jan lecun he was the
director of facebook ai research group
built the first convolutional neural
network called lynette in 1988 so these
have been around for a while and have
had a chance to mature over the years it
was used for character recognition tasks
like reading zip code digits imagine
processing mail and automating that
process
cnn is a feed forward neural network
that is generally used to analyze visual
images by producing data with a
grid-like topology a cnn is also known
as a convent and very key to this is we
are looking at images that was what this
was designed for and you'll see the
different layers as we dig in near some
of the other some of them are actually
now used since we're using uh tensorflow
and keras in our code later on you'll
see that some of those layers appear in
a lot of your other neural network
frameworks but in this case this is very
central to processing images and doing
so in a variety that captures multiple
images and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers are two varieties orchid
and a rose i think the orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful i have a couple
rose bushes in my yard they go into the
input layer that data is in sent to all
the different nodes in the next layer
one of the hidden layers based on its
different weights and its setup it then
comes out and gives those a new value
those values then are multiplied by
their weights and go to the next hidden
layer and so on and then you have the
output layer and one of those nodes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how it was well it was
trained what separates the cnn or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms the basis of any
convolutional neural network in a cnn
every image image is represented in the
form of arrays of pixel values so here
we have a real image of the digit 8.
that then gets put on to
its pixel values represented in the form
of an array in this case you have a two
dimensional array and then you can see
in the final in form we transform the
digit eight into its representational
form of pixels of zeros and one where
the ones represent in this case the
black part of the eight and the zeros
represent the white background to
understand the convolution neural
network or how that convolutional
operation works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it we're
going to take two matrices a and b of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learned that
you want to focus just on the matrix
aspect of this and then we'll bring that
back together and see what that looks
like when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have uh in this case
are a single dimension matrix and we
have a equals five three seven five nine
seven and we have b equals one two three
so in the convolution as it comes in
there is going to look at these two and
we're going to start by doing
multiplying them a times b and so we
multiply the arrays element wise and we
get 5 6 6
where 5 is the 5 times 1 six is three
times two and then the other six is two
times three and since the two arrays
aren't the same size they're not the
same setup we're going to just truncate
the first one and we're gonna look at
the second array multiplied just by the
first three elements of the first array
now that it's going to be a little
confusing remember a computer gets to
repeat these processes hundreds of times
so we're not going to just forget those
other numbers later on we'll see we'll
bring those back in and then we have the
sum of the product in this case 5 plus 6
plus 6 equals 17. so in our a times b
our very first digit in that matrix of a
times b is 17. and if you remember i
said we're not going to forget the other
digits so we now have 3 2 five we move
one set over and we take three two five
and we multiply that times b and you'll
see that three times one is three two
times two is four and so on and so on we
sum it up so now we have the second
digit of our a times b product in the
matrix and we continue on with that same
thing so on and so on so then we would
go from three seven five to seven five
nine to five nine seven this short
matrix that we have for a we've now
covered all the different entities in a
that match three different levels of b
now in a little bit we're going to cover
where we use this math at this
multiplying of matrixes and how that
works
but it's important to understand that
we're going through the matrix of
multiplying the different parts to it to
match the smaller matrix with the larger
matrix i know a lot of people get lost
at as you know what's going on here with
these matrixes oh scary math not really
that scary when you break it down we're
looking at a section of a and we're
comparing it to b so when you break that
down your mind like that you realize
okay so i'm just taking these two
matrixes and comparing them and i'm
bringing the value down into one matrix
a times b we're reducing that
information in a way that will help the
computer see different aspects let's go
ahead and flip over again back to our
images
here we are back to our images talking
about going to the most basic
two-dimensional image you can get to
consider the following two images the
image for the symbol backslash when you
press the backslash the above image is
processed and you can see there for the
image for the forward slash is the
opposite so we click the forward slash
button that flips uh very basic we have
four pixels going in can't get any more
basic than that here we have a little
bit more complicated picture we take a
real image of a smiley face
then we represent that in the form of
black and white pixels so if this was an
image in the computer it's black and
white and like we saw before
we convert this into the zeros and one
so where the other one would have just
been a matrix of just four dots now we
have a significantly larger image coming
in so don't worry we're going to bring
this all together here in just a little
bit layers in convolutional neural
network we're looking at this we have
our convolution layer and that really is
the central aspect of processing images
in the convolutional neural network
that's why we have it and then that's
going to be feeding in and you have your
relu layer which is you know as we
talked about the rectified linear unit
we'll talk about that a little bit later
the relu isn't how it act is how that
layer is activated is the math behind it
what makes the neurons fire you'll see
that a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself it's for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the relu layer works great you
have your pooling layer that's where
you're pulling the data together pooling
is a neural network term it's very
commonly used i like to use the term
reduce so if you're coming from the map
and reduce side you'll see that we're
mapping all this data through all these
networks and then we're going to reduce
it we're going to pull it together and
then finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output is going
to come out so we have started to look
at matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following five by five image whose pixel
values are only zero and one now
obviously when we're dealing with color
there's all kinds of things that come in
on color processing but we want to keep
it simple and just keep it black and
white and so we have our image pixels uh
so we're sliding the filter matrix over
the image and computing the dot product
to detect the patterns and right here
you're going to ask where does this
filter come from this is a bit confusing
because the filter is going to be
derived
later on we build the filters when we
program or train our model so you don't
need to worry what the filter actually
is but you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have mini
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two dimensional matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here one times one one
times zero one times one we multiply
those all together then sum them and we
end up with the convolved feature of
four we're going to take that and
sliding the filter matrix over the image
and computing the dot product to detect
patterns so we're just going to slide
this so we're going to predict the first
one and slide it over one notch predict
the second one and so on and so on all
the way through until we have a new
matrix and this matrix which is the same
size as a filter has reduced the image
and whatever filter whatever that's
filtering out is going to be looking at
just those features reduced down to a
smaller matrix so once the feature maps
are extracted the next step is to move
them to the relu layer so the relu layer
the next step first is going to perform
an element-wise operation so each of
those maps coming in if there's negative
pixels so it sets all the negative
pixels to zero and you can see this nice
graph where it just zeros out the
negatives and then you have a value that
goes from zero up to whatever value is
coming out of the matrix this introduces
non-linearity to the network so up until
now we have a we say linearity we're
talking about the fact that the feature
has a value so it's a linear feature
this feature
came up and has let's say the feature is
the edge of the beak you know it's like
or the backslash that we saw um you'll
look at that and say okay this feature
has a value from negative 10 to 10 in
this case um if it was one it'd say yeah
this might be a beak it might not might
be an edge right there a minus five
means no we're not even going to look at
it to zero and so we end up with an
output and the output takes all these
features all these filtered features
remember we're not just running one
filter on this we're running a number of
filters on this image and so we end up
with a rectified feature map that is
looking at just the features coming
through and how they weigh in from our
filters so here we have an input of a
looks like a toucan bird
very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
relu layers for locating features and
you can see up here is turn it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
skip by two or three or four pixels to
speed up the process that's one of the
ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image you have multiple filters have
been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new matrix
one more aspect to note about the relu
layer is we're not just having one value
coming in uh so not only do we have
multiple features going through but
we're generating multiple relu layers
for locating the features that's very
important to note you know so we have a
quite a bundle we have multiple filters
multiple rail u uh which brings us to
the next step forward propagation now
we're going to look at the pooling layer
the rectified feature map now goes
through a pooling layer pooling is a
down sampling operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map that's
all we're trying to do we're trying to
take a huge amount of information and
reduce it down to a single answer this
is a specific kind of bird this is an
iris this is a rose so you have a
rectified feature map and you see here
we have our rectified feature map coming
in
we set the max pooling with a 2x2
filters and a stride of two and if you
remember correctly i talked about not
going one pixel at a time uh well that's
where the stride comes in we end up with
a two by two pooled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a step we skip a few there we go by
two we skip every other pixel and we
just do every other one and this reduces
our rectified feature map which as you
can see over here 16 by 16 to a four by
four so we're continually trying to
filter and reduce our data so that we
can get to something we can manage and
over here you see that we have the max
3 4 1 and 2 and in the max pooling we're
looking for the max value a little bit
different than what we were looking at
before so coming from the rectified
feature we're now finding the max value
and then we're pulling those features
together so instead of think of this as
image of the map think of this as how
valuable is a feature in that area how
much of a feature value do we have we
just want to find the best or the
maximum feature for that area they might
have that one piece of the filter of the
beak said oh i see a one in this beak in
this image and then it skips over and
says i see a three in this image and
says oh this one is rated as a four we
don't want to sum it together because
then you know you might have like five
ones and i'll say ah five but you might
have uh four zeros and one ten and that
ten says well this is definitely a beak
where the ones will say probably not a
beak a little strange analogy since
we're looking at a bird but you can see
how that pulled feature map comes down
and we're just looking for the max value
in each one of those matrixes pooling
layer uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak etc i
know i focus mainly on the beak but
obviously each feature could be each a
different part of the bird coming in so
let's take a look at what that looks
like structure of a convolution neural
network so far this is where we're at
right now we have our input image coming
in and then we use our filters and
there's multiple filters on there that
are being developed to kind of twist and
change that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a two by two we multiply it
by each piece of the image and if we
step two then it's every other piece of
the image that generates multiple
convolution layers so we have a number
of convolution layers we have
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the relu
setup and then once we've done through
the release setup and we have multiple
values going on multiple layers that are
related then we're going to take those
multiple layers and we're going to be
pooling them so now we have the pooling
layers or multiple poolings going on up
until this point we're dealing with
sometimes there's multiple dimensions
you can have three dimensions some
strange data setups that aren't doing
images but looking at other things they
can have four five six seven dimensions
uh so right now we're looking at 2d
image dimensions coming in into the
pooling layer so the next step is we
want to reduce those dimensions or
flatten them so flattening flattening is
a process of converting all of the
resultant two-dimensional arrays from
pooled feature map into a single long
continuous linear vector so over here
you see where we have a pooled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values 6847 and we want to just
flatten this out and turn it into 6847
or a single linear vector and we find
out that not only do we do each of the
pooled feature maps we do all of them
into one long linear vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we flatten them out and combine them
into a single linear vector going in so
after we've done the flattening we have
just a quick recap because we've covered
so much so it's important to go back and
take a look at each of the steps we've
gone through the structure of the
network so far is we have our
convolution where we twist it and we
filter it and multiply the matrixes we
end up with our convolutional layer
which uses the rel u to figure out the
values going out into the pooling as you
have numerous convolution layers that
then create numerous pooling layers
pulling that data together which is the
max value which one we want to send
forward we want to send the best value
and then we're going to take all of that
from each of the pooling layers and
we're going to flatten it and we're
going to combine them into a single
input going into the final layer once
you get to that step you might be
looking at that going boy that looks
like the normal intuit to most neural
network and you're correct it is
so once we have the flattened matrix
from the pooling layer that becomes our
input so the pooling layer is fed as an
input to the fully connected layer to
classify the image and so you can see as
our flattened matrix comes in in this
case we have the pixels from the
flattened matrix fed as an input back to
our toucan or whatever that kind of bird
that is i need one of these to identify
what kind of bird that is it comes into
our ford propagation network
and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case
even though it's not labeled the final
layer there in red is our output layer
our final output layer that says bird
cat or dog so quick recap of everything
we've covered so far we have our input
image which is twisted and multiplied
the filters are multiplied times the
matrix the two matrixes multiplied all
the filters to create our convolution
layer our convolution layers there's
multiple layers in there because it's
all building multiple layers off the
different filters then goes through the
relu as this activation and that creates
our pooling and so once we get into the
pooling layer we then and the pooling
look for who's the best what's the max
value coming in from our convolution and
we take that layer and we flatten it and
then it goes into a fully connected
layer our fully connected neural network
and then to the output and here we can
see the entire process how the cnn
recognizes a bird this is kind of nice
because it's showing the little pixels
and where they're going you can see the
filter is generating this convolution
network and that filter shows up in the
bottom part of the convolution network
and then based on that it uses the relu
for the pooling the pulling then find
out which one's the best and so on all
the way to the fully connected layer at
the end or the classification in the
output layer so that'd be a
classification neural network at the end
so we covered a lot of theory up till
now and you can imagine each one of
these steps has to be broken down in
code so putting that together can be a
little complicated not that each step of
the process is overly complicated but
because we have so many steps we have
one two three four five
different steps going on here with sub
steps in there we're going to break that
down and walk through that in code so in
our use case implementation using the
cnn we'll be using the cfar10 dataset
from canadian institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and very cutting edge as far as
what's coming out in the commercial
deployment i mean this is really cool
stuff we're starting to see this just
about everywhere in industry so great
time to be playing with this and
figuring it all out let's go ahead and
dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script
before we go on let's do uh one more
quick look at what we have here let's
just take a look at data batch one keys
and remember jupiter notebook i can get
by with not doing the print statement if
i put a variable down there it'll just
display the variable and you can see
under data batch one for the keys since
this is a dictionary we have the batch
one label data and file names so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the images using matte plot
library there's many ways to display the
images you can even well there's other
ways to drill into it but matplot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape
setup or shaping the data so you can
have a little glimpse into what that
means so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since i am doing jupyter notebook i need
to do the matplot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library.pipelot
as plt and if you remember matplot
library the pie plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign matplot library inline
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as np for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set
x equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data uh we need to
go a little bit of reshaping so in here
we have to go ahead and reshape the data
we have 10 000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to i had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32 by 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here so we
have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
i don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
going to break it up into 10 000 pieces
and those 10 000 pieces then are broken
into three pieces each and those three
pieces then are 32 by 32. you can look
at this like an old-fashioned projector
where they have the red screen or the
red projector the blue projector in the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32
by 32 bit so that's probably how this
was originally formatted was in that
kind of ideal things have changed so
we're going to transpose it and we're
going to take the 3 which was here and
we're going to put it at the end so the
first part is reshaping the data from a
single line of bit data or whatever
format it is into 10 000 by 3 by 32 by
32 and then we're going to transpose the
color factor to the last place so it's
the image then the 32 by 32 in the
middle that's this part right here and
then finally we're going to take this
which is three bits of data and put it
at the end so it's more like we do we
process images now and then as type this
is really important that we're going to
use an integer eight you can come in
here and you'll see a lot of these
they'll try to do this with a float or a
float 64. what you got to remember
though is a float uses a lot of memory
so once you switch this into
something that's not integer 8 which
goes up to 128 you are just gonna the
the amount of ram let me just put that
in here it's going to go way up the
amount of ram that it loads
so you want to go ahead and use this you
can try the other ones and see what
happens if you have a lot of ram on your
computer but for this exercise this will
work just fine and let's go ahead and
take that and run this so now our x
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we were
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that uh you'll see it doesn't oops i
said 128 is 255. uh you'll see it
doesn't go over 255 because it's
basically an ascii character is what
we're keeping that down to we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus float value which would
bring this up
exponentially in size and since we're
using the matplot library we can do
oops that's not what i wanted since
we're using the matplot library we can
take our canvas and just do a plt dot im
for image show and uh let's just take a
look at what x0 looks like and it comes
in i'm not sure what that is but you can
see it's a very low grade image
broken down to the minimal pixels on
there and if we did the same thing oh
let's do uh let's see what one looks
like hopefully it's a little easier to
see run on there not enter let's hit the
run on that
and we can see this is probably a semi
truck that's a good guess on there and i
can just go back up here instead of
typing the same line in over and over
and we'll look at three
that looks like a dump truck unloading
and so on you can do any of the 10 000
images and just jump to 55
looks like some kind of animal looking
at us there probably a dog and just for
fun let's do just one more uh
run on there and we can see a nice car
for our image number four uh so you can
see we pace through all the different
images it's very easy to look at them
and they've been reshaped to fit our
view and what the
matplot library uses for its format so
the next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we'll
start by a one hot encoder to help us or
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a class uh cfar helper so it's
going to have an init and a setup for
the images and then finally we'll go
ahead and run that code so you can see
what that looks like and then we get
into the fun part where we're actually
going to start creating our model our
actual neural network model so let's
start by creating our one hot encoder
we're going to create our own here uh
and it's going to return an out and
we'll have our vector coming in and our
values equal 10. what this means is that
we have the 10 values the 10 possible
labels and remember we don't look at the
labels as a number because a car isn't
one more than a horse maybe just kind of
bizarre to have horse equals zero car
equals one plane equals two cat equals
three so a cat plus a car equals what uh
so instead we create a numpy array of
zeros and there's going to be 10 values
so we have a 10 different values in
there so you have
0 or 1. 1 means it's a cat 0 means it's
not a cat
in the next line it might be that 1
means it's a car 0 means it's not a car
so instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to 1. that's what
the one hot encoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this in code in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper which is a class and this is
a lot in this class so we'll we'll break
it down here and let's just start oops a
little bit of space right in there there
we go that was a little bit more
readable at a second space so we're
going to create our class the cipher
helper and we'll start by initializing
it now there's a lot going on in here so
let's start with the uh init part uh
self dot i equals zero that'll come in a
little bit we'll come back to that in
the lower part we want to initialize our
training batches so when we went through
this there was like a meta batch we
don't need the meta batch but we do need
the data batch one two three four five
and we do not want the testing batch in
here this is just the self all train
batches so we're going to come make an
array of all those different images and
then of course we left the test batch
out so we have our self.test batch
we're going to initialize the training
images and the training labels and also
the test images and the test labels so
these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the
init part
since this is all just helper stuff but
breaking it up again makes it easier to
read it also makes it easier when we
start executing the different pieces to
see what's going on so that way we have
a nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here we're going to set up
the self training images at this point
and that's going to go to a numpy array
v stack and in there we're going to load
up uh in this case the data for d itself
all train batches again that points
right up to here so we're going to go
through each one of these uh files or
each one of these data sets because
they're not a file anymore we've brought
them in data batch one points to the
actual data and so our self training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and then it's
always nice to get the training length
and that's just a total number of uh
self training images in there and then
we're going to take the self training
images let me switch marker colors
because i am getting a little bit too
much on the markers up here oops there
we go bring down our marker change
so we can see it a little better and at
this point this should look familiar
where did we see this well when we
wanted to uh look at this above and we
want to look at the images in the
matplot library we had to reshape it so
we're doing the same thing here we're
taking our self training images and
based on the training length total
number of images because we stacked them
all together so now it's just one large
file of images we're going to take and
look at it as our three video cameras
that are each displaying a 32 by 32
we're going to switch that around so
that now we have each of our images that
stays the same place and then we have
our 32 by 32 and then by our three our
last are three different values for the
color and of course we want to go ahead
and they run this where we say divide by
255 that was from earlier it just brings
all the data into zero to one that's
what this is doing so we're turning this
into a zero to one array which is uh all
the pictures 32 by 32 by three and then
we're going to take the self training
labels and we're going to pump those
through our one hot encoder we just made
and we're going to stack them together
and
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals one dog equals two
and then horse plus dog would equal
three which would be cat
now it's going to be you know an array
of 10 where each one is 0 to 1. then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and when we're doing
this you're going to see it's the same
thing we just did with the rest of them
we just changed colors right here this
is no different than what we're doing up
here with our training set we're going
to stack the different images
we're going to get the length of them so
we know how many images are in there you
certainly could add them by hand but
it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand tends to throw me for a
little loop when i'm working with
tensorflow or cross or a lot of these we
have our data coming in if you remember
we had like 10 000 photos let me just
put 10 000 down here we don't want to
run all 10 000 at once so we want to
break this up into batch sizes and you
also remember that we had the number of
photos in this case length of test or
whatever number is in there we also have
32 by 32
by 3. so when we're looking at the batch
size we want to change this from 10 000
to
a batch of in this case i think we're
gonna do batches of a hundred so we
wanna look at just 100 the first hundred
of the photos and if you remember we set
self-i
equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create x we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialize we've already initialized it
for 0. so we're going to look at x from
0 to batch size which we set to 100 so
just the first 100 images and then we're
going to reshape that into
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100 by 32 by
32 by 3. now we've already formatted it
to the 32 by 32 by 3. this just sets
everything up correctly so that x has
the data in there in the correct order
in the correct shape and then the y just
like the x uh is our labels so our
training labels again they go from zero
to batch size in this case they do sell
five plus batch size because the cell
self is going to keep changing and then
finally we increment the self i because
we have 0 so we so the next time we call
it we're going to get the next batch
size and so basically we have x and y x
being the photograph data coming in and
y being the label and that of course is
labeled through one hot encoder so if
you remember correctly if it was say
horse is equal to zero it would be um
one for the zero position since this is
the horse and then everything else would
be zero in here let me just put lines
through there there we go there's our
array
hard to see that array so let's go ahead
and take that and we're going to finish
loading it since this is our class and
now we're armed with all this
our setup over here let's go ahead and
load that up and so we're going to
create a variable ch with the cfar
helper in it and then we're going to do
ch.setup images
now we could have just put all the setup
images under the init but by breaking
this up into two parts it makes it much
more readable and also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup i
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch because we have to run uh
batch equals ch next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
but we'll come back to that we're going
to use that just remember that that's
part of our code we're going to be using
in a minute from the definition we just
made so now we're ready to create our
model first thing we want to do is we
want to import our tensorflow as tf i'll
just go ahead and run that so it's
loaded up and you see we got a
warning here
that's because they're making some
changes it's always growing and they're
going to be depreciating one of the
values from float 64 to float type or is
treated as an np float 64. uh nothing to
really worry about this doesn't even
affect what we're working on because
we've set all of our stuff to a 255
value or zero to one and do keep in mind
that zero to one value that we converted
to 255 is still a float value but it'll
easily work with either the numpy float
64 or the numpy d type float it doesn't
matter which one it goes through so the
depreciation would not affect our code
as we have it and in our tensorflow uh
we'll go ahead and just increase the
size in there just a moment so you can
get a better view of the um what we're
typing in uh we're going to set a couple
placeholders here and so we have we're
going to set x equals tf placeholder tf
float 32. we just talked about the
float64 versus the numpy float we're
actually just going to keep this at
float32 more than a significant number
of decimals for what we're working with
and since it's a placeholder we're going
to set the shape equal to and we've set
it equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what that
first value is and then 32 by 32 by 3
that's what we've reshaped our data to
fit in and then we have our y true
equals placeholder tf float 32 and the
shape equals none comma 10. 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10. and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this a hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call drop out
if you remember from our theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a placeholder for that
also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensorflow when you use keras it does
some of this automatically but we're in
tensorflow direct kara sits on
tensorflow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each layer has
to have a bias going in we're going to
go ahead and work on our conversional 2d
our max pool so we have our pooling
layer our convolutional layer and then
our normal full layer so we're going to
go ahead and put those all into
definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
mnist the nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the
tensorflow so a lot of these already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our
init weights and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here now we're not going to be
doing that we're just going to recreate
them for our code and let's take a look
at this we have our weights and so it
comes in is going to be the shape and
what comes out is going to be
random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just admit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the tf variable init
random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with
the constant
in this case we're using 0.1 a lot of
times the bias is just put in as one and
then you have your weights add on to
that but we're going to set this as 0.1
so we want to return a convolutional 2d
in this case a neural network this is uh
would be a layer on here what's going on
with the con 2d is we're taking our data
coming in
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does
is that we have our data coming in as 32
by 32
by
3 and we want to change this so that
it's just this is three dimensions and
it's going to reformat this as just two
dimensions so it's going to take this
number here and combine it with the 32
by 32. so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down i'm just going to jump down one
here it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre-formatting and the setup and then
you have your actual convolution layer
that goes through on there and you can
see here we have init weights by the
shape and knit bias shape of three
because we have the three different uh
here's our three again and then we
return the tfnn relu with the convention
2d so this convolutional has this
feeding into it right there it's using
that as part of it and of course the
input is the x y plus b the bias so
that's quite a mouthful but these two
are the are the keys here to creating
the convolutional layers there the
convolutional 2d coming in and then the
convolutional layer which then steps
through and creates all those filters we
saw then of course we have our pooling
uh so after each time we run it through
the convectional layer we want to pull
the data if you remember correctly on
the on the pool side and let me just get
rid of all my marks it's getting a
little crazy there and in fact let's go
ahead and jump back to that slide let's
just take a look at that slide over here
uh so we have our image coming in we
create our convolutional layer with all
the filters remember the filters go um
you know the filter is coming in here
and it looks at these four boxes and
then if it's a step let's say step two
and then goes to these four boxes and
then the next step and so on uh so we
have our convolutional layer that we
generate or convolutional layers they
use the uh relu function there's other
functions out there for this though the
value is the
most the one that works the best at
least so far i'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was max
so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a 1 and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down reducing it down as small as
we can and then finally we're going to
flatten it out into a single array and
that goes into our fully connected layer
and you can see that here in the code
right here we're going to create our
normal full layer
so at some point we're going to take
from our pooling layer this will go into
some kind of flattening process and then
that will be fed into the full the
different layers going in down here and
so we have our input size you'll see our
input layer get shape which is just
going to get the shape for whatever's
coming in uh and then input size initial
weights is also based on the input layer
coming in and the input size down here
is based on the input layer shape so
we're just going to already use the
shape and already have our size coming
in and of course you have to make sure
you knit the bias always put your bias
on there and we'll do that based on the
size so this will return
tf.matimole
input layer w plus b this is just a
normal full layer that's what this means
right down here that's what we're going
to return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and create the layers
let's see what that looks like
now that we've done all the heavy
lifting and everything we get to do all
the easy part let's go ahead and create
our layers we'll create a convolution
layer one and two two different
convolutional layers and then we'll take
that and we'll flatten that out and
create a reshape pooling in there for
our reshape and then we'll have our full
uh layer at the end so let's start by
creating our first convolutional layer
then we come in here and let me just run
that real quick and i want you to notice
on here the 3
and the 32 this is important because
coming into this convolutional layer we
have three different channels and 32
pixels each
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 4 4 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have max toolbar 2x2 and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the x is
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up
so matches and we went ahead and ran
this already i think i read let me go
and run it again and if we're going to
do one layer let's go ahead and do a
second layer down here and it's uh we'll
call it convo 2.
it's also a convolutional layer on this
and you'll see that we're feeding
convolutional one in the pooling so it
goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional to
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer
let's go ahead and we'll do uh since we
have 64 coming out of here and we have a
four by four going in let's do eight by
8 by 64. so let's do 4096.
this is going to be the flat layer so
that's how many bits are coming through
on the flat layer and we'll reshape this
so we'll reshape our
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the combo 2 pulling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's 4096 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo 2 flat and then we have our first
full layer this is the final
neural network where the flat layer
going in and we're going to again use
the relu for our setup on there on a
neural network for evaluation and you'll
notice that we're going to create our
first full layer our normal full layer
that's our definition so we created that
that's creating the normal full layer
and our input for the data comes right
here from the this goes right into it uh
the convo to flat so this tells it how
big the data is and we're going to have
it come out it's going to have 10 24
that's how big the layer is coming out
we'll go ahead and run this so now we
have our full layer one and with the
full layer one we want to also define
the full one dropout to go with that so
our full layer one comes in uh keep
probability equals whole probability
remember we created that earlier and the
full layer one is what's coming into it
and this is going backwards and training
the data we're not training every weight
we're only training a percentage of them
each time which helps get rid of the
bias so let me go ahead and run that and
finally we'll go ahead and create a y
predict which is going to equal the
normal full 1 drop out and 10 because we
have 10 labels in there now in this
neural network we could have added
additional layers that would be another
option to play with you can also play
with instead of 10 24 you can use other
numbers for the way that sets up and
what's coming out going into the next
one we're only going to do just the one
layer and the one layer drop out and you
can see if we did another layer it'd be
really easy just to feed in the full one
drop out into full layer two and then
full layer two dropout would have full
layer two feed into it and then you'd
switch that here for the y prediction
for right now this is great this
particular data set is tried and true
and we know that this will work on it
and if we just type in y predict and we
run that
we'll see that this is a tensor object
uh shape question mark 10 d type 32 a
quick way to double check what we're
working on so now we've got all of our
we've done a setup all the way to the y
predict which we just did we want to go
ahead and apply the loss function and
make sure that's set up in there
create the optimizer and then
trainer optimizer and create a variable
to initialize all the global tf
variables so before we dive in to the
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehab over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups
we pointed out up here we can change the
4 4 and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
possibly a better fit you might overfit
and if you lower that number you'll use
less resources and generally you want to
use this in
the exponential growth an exponential
being 2 4 8 16 and in this case the next
one down would be 512. you can use any
number there but those would be the
ideal numbers when you look at this data
so the next step in all this is we need
to also create a way of tracking how
good our model is and we're going to
call this a loss function and so we're
going to create a cross entropy loss
function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it
we're going to feed it our labels and we
have our true labels and our prediction
labels so coming in here is where the
two different variables we're sending in
or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information theory the cross entropy
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this
and so the next step
is we're going to take the error we want
to know our cross entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it we feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used uh so our
optimizer is going to equal the tf train
atom optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop this back into here here's our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights and your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out
it has all its weights and then the
error is being prop sent back through in
reverse on our neural network so we take
this error we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by 0.001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our delta
w is only 0.001 of the actual delta w of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training uh variable or
function and this is going to equal our
optimizer minimize cross entropy and we
make sure we go ahead and run this
so it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more
variable in here and we're going to
create a variable to initialize all the
global tf variables and when we look at
this
the tf global variable initializer this
is a tensorflow
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensorflow and then
initializes those variables
so it's kind of like a magic wand
because it's all hidden in the backend
of tensorflow all you need to know about
this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation um and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this let's load
it up there and so now we're going to go
ahead and run the model by creating a
graph session graph session is a
tensorflow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because i always think of
graphics and spark and graph as just
general graphing uh but they talk about
a graph session so we're gonna go ahead
and run the model and let's go ahead and
walk through this uh what's going on
here and let's paste this data in here
and here we go so we're gonna start off
with it with the tf session as cess so
that's our actual tf session we've
created uh so we're right here with the
tf uh
session our session we're creating we're
going to run tf global variable
initializer so right off the bat we're
initializing our variables here and then
we have for i in range 500 so what's
going on here remember 500 we're going
to break the data up and we're going to
batch it in at 500 points each we've
created our session run so we're going
to do with tf session as session right
here we've created our variable session
and then we're going to run and we're
going to go ahead and initialize it so
we have our tf global variables
initializer that we created
that initializes our session in here the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to go for i in range of 500 batch
equals ch.nextbatch so if you remember
correctly this is loading up
100 pictures at a time and
this is going to loop through that 500
times so we are literally doing what is
that 500 times 100 is
50 000. so that's 50 000 pictures we're
going to process right there and the
first process is we're going to do a
session run we're going to take our
train we created our train variable or
optimizer in there we're going to feed
it the dictionary we had our feed
dictionary that we created and we have x
equals batch 0 coming in y true batch
one hold the probability point five
and then just so that we can keep track
of what's going on we're going to every
100 steps we're going to run a print so
currently on step format
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf dot equal tf
argument y prediction one tf dot arg max
y true comma one so we're going to look
at this is how many matches it has and
here our acc uh all we're doing here is
we're going to take the matches how many
matches they have it creates it
generates a chart we're going to convert
that to float that's what the tf cast
does and then we just want to know the
average we just want to know the average
of the accuracy and then we'll go ahead
and print that out
print session run accuracy feed
dictionary so it takes all this and it
prints out our accuracy on there so
let's go ahead and take this oops
screen's there let's go ahead and take
this and let's run it and this is going
to take a little bit to run
so let's see what happens on my old
laptop and we'll see here that we have
our current uh we're currently on step
zero it takes a little bit to get
through the accuracy and this will take
just a moment to run we can see that on
our step 0 it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.1028
and as it's running we'll go ahead you
don't need to watch it run all the way
but this accuracy is going to change a
little bit up and down so we've actually
lost some accuracy during our step two
but we'll see how that comes out let's
come back after we run it all the way
through and see how the different steps
come out it's actually reading that
backwards
the way this works is the closer we get
to one the more accuracy we have so you
can see here we've gone from a point one
to a point three nine um and we'll go
ahead and pause this and come back and
see what happens when we're done with
the full run all right now that we've
prepared the meal got it in the oven and
pulled out my finished dish here if
you've ever watched any of the old
cooking shows let's discuss a little bit
about this accuracy going on here and
how do you interpret that we've done a
couple things first we've defined
accuracy
the reason i got it backwards before is
you have
loss or accuracy and with loss you'll
get a graph that looks like this it goes
oops that's an s by the way there we go
you get a graph that curves down like
this and with accuracy you get a graph
that curves up this is how good it's
doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
means it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal in fact that's
pretty much you know unheard of and the
same thing with loss if you have a loss
of zero that's also unheard of the
zero's actually on this this axis right
here as we go in there so how do we
interpret that because you know if i was
looking at this and i go oh 0.51 that's
51 you're doing 50 50. no this is not
percentage let me just put that in there
it is not percentage uh this is log
rhythmic what that means is that 0.2 is
twice as good as 0.1 and when we see 0.4
that's twice as good as 0.2 real way to
convert this into a percentage you
really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50
we're just guessing equals 0.1 and if 50
roughly equals 0.1 that's we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.1028 the accuracy of 50
then 75
is about 0.2 and so on and so on don't
quote those numbers because it doesn't
work that way they say that if you have
point nine five that's pretty much
saying a hundred percent and if you have
uh anywhere between you'd have to go
look this up let me go and remove all my
drawings there
so the magic number is 0.5 we really
want to be over a 0.5 in this whole
thing and we have
both 0.504 remember this is accuracy if
we were looking at loss then we would be
looking the other way but 0.05 you know
instead of how high it is we want how
low it is uh but with accuracy being
over a 0.5 is pretty valid that means
this is pretty solid and if you get to a
0.95 then it's a direct correlation
that's what we're looking for here in
these numbers you can see we finished
with this model at 0.5135
so still good
and if we look at when they ran this in
the other end remember there's a lot of
randomness that goes into it when we see
the weights they got
.5251 so a little better than ours but
that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on just that randomness and so
we've gone through the whole model we've
created we trained the model and we've
also gone through on every 100th run to
test the model to see how accurate it is
welcome to the rnn tutorial that's the
recurrent neural network so we talk
about a feed forward neural network in a
feed forward neural network information
flows only in the forward direction from
the input nodes through the hidden
layers if any into the output nodes
there are no cycles or loops in the
network and so you can see here we have
our input layer i was talking about how
it just goes straight forward into the
hidden layers so each one of those
connects and then connects to the next
hidden layer connects to the output
layer and of course we have a nice
simplified version where it has a
predicted output the refer to the input
is x a lot of times in the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a feed
forward neural network doesn't know how
to handle sequential data it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever i put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any of that
it just looks at this is what's coming
in and it cannot memorize previous
inputs so it doesn't have that list of
inputs coming in solution to feed
forward neural network you'll see here
where it says recurrent neural network
and we have our x on the bottom going to
h going to y that's your feed forward
but right in the middle it has a value c
so there's a whole another process was
memorizing what's going on in the hidden
layers and the hidden layers as they
produce data feed into the next one so
your hidden layer might have an output
that goes off to y
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at general drawings
and solutions we should also look at
applications of the rnn image captioning
rnn is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair that's
very tough i mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using rnn and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the new york stock
exchange in the u.s produces somewhere
in the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades in fluctuations by the
second
it's like three terabytes a day of data
so we're gonna look at one stock just
analyzing one stock is really tricky in
here we'll give you a little jump on
that so that's exciting but don't expect
to get rich off of it immediately
another application of the rnn is
natural language processing text mining
and sentiment analysis can be carried
out using rnn for natural language
processing and you can see right here
the term natural language processing
when you stream those three words
together is very different than i if i
said processing language natural leap so
the time series is very important when
we're analyzing sentiments it can change
the whole value of a sentence just by
switching the words around or if you're
just counting the words you might get
one sentiment where if you actually look
at the order they're in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for stars both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language rnn can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output i myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking english you would say
big cat and if you're speaking spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in english and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in english in this
little diagram i guess that's denoted by
the flags i have a flag i own it no
but they're speaking in english and it's
getting translated into
chinese italian french german and
spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistically
challenged i can now travel into worlds
i would never think of because i can
have something translate my english back
and forth readily and i'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down i'll make more
sense and usually we have our
propagation forward neural network with
the input layers the hidden layers the
output layer with the recurrent neural
network we turn that on its side so here
it is and now our x comes up from the
bottom into the hidden layers into y and
they usually draw very simplified x to h
with c as a loop a to y where a b and c
are the perimeters a lot of times you'll
see this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the h and how it
works
going from left to right you'll see that
the c goes in and then the x goes in so
the x is going upward bound and c is
going to the right a is going out and c
is also going out that's where it gets a
little confusing so here we have xn
cn and then we have y out and c out and
c is based on ht minus one so our value
is based on the y and the h value are
connected to each other they're not
necessarily the same value because h can
be its own thing and usually we draw
this or we represent it as a function h
of t equals a function of c where h of t
minus 1 that's the last h output and x
of t going in so it's the last output of
h combined with the new input of x where
h t is the new state fc is a function
with the parameters c that's a common
way of denoting it h t minus 1 is the
old state coming out and then x of t is
an input vector at time of step t well
we need to cover types of recurrent
neural networks and so the first one is
the most common one which is a one to
one single output
one to one neural network is usually
known as a vanilla neural network used
for regular machine learning problems
why because vanilla is usually
considered kind of a just a real basic
flavor but because it's very basic a lot
of times they'll call it the vanilla
neural network which is not the common
term but it is kind of a slang term
people will know what you're talking
about usually if you say that then we
run one to many so you have a single
input and you might have a multiple
outputs in this case uh image captioning
as we looked at earlier where we have
not just looking at it as a dog but a
dog catching a ball in the air and then
you have many to one network takes in a
sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you're just adding up the words in
there and then the course if you're
going to do a one-to-one mini to one one
to many there's many to many networks
takes in a sequence of inputs and
generates a sequence of outputs example
machine translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in english and then
going out in all the different languages
uh you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations if
you're a translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages
one of the biggest things you need to
understand when we're working with this
neural network is what's called the
vanishing gradient problem while
training an rnn your slope can be either
too small or very large and this makes
training difficult when the slope is too
small the problem is known as vanishing
gradient and you'll see here they have a
nice
image loss of information through time
so if you're pushing not enough
information forward that information is
lost and then when you go to train it
you start losing the third word in the
sentence or something like that or it
doesn't quite follow the full logic of
what you're working on
exploding gradient problem oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem
time poor performance bad accuracy and
i'll add one more in there your computer
if you're on a lower end computer
testing out a model will lock up and
give you the memory error explaining
gradient problem consider the following
two examples to understand what should
be the next word in the sequence
the person who took my bike and blank a
thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the rnn must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief as singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the rnn must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the error to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a vanishing gradient the option
problem we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions we'll
look at that just minimally there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the lstms and we can make
adjustments to that so just like we can
clip the gradient as it comes out we can
also
expand on that we can increase the
memory network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's
setup is what they call long term
dependencies suppose we try to predict
the last word in the text the clouds are
in the and you probably said sky here we
do not need any further context it's
pretty clear that the last word is going
to be sky suppose we try to predict the
last word in the text i have been
staying in spain for the last 10 years i
can speak fluent maybe he said
portuguese or french no you probably
said spanish the word we predict will
depend on the previous few words in
context here we need the context of
spain to predict the last word in the
text it's possible that the gap between
the relevant information and the point
where it is needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior all recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent h
layer lstms's
also have a chain-like structure but the
repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default behavior ls tmss also have
a chain-like structure but the repeating
module has a different structure instead
of having a single neural network layer
there are four interacting layers
communicating in a very special way as
you can see the deeper we dig into this
the more complicated the graphs kit in
here i want you to note that you have x
of t minus 1 coming in you have x of t
coming in and you have x at t plus one
and you have h of t minus 1 and h of t
coming in and h of t plus 1 going out
and of course on the other side is the
output a
in the middle we have our tangent h but
it occurs in two different places so not
only when we're computing the x at t
plus one or we getting the tangent h
from x to t but we're also getting that
value coming in from the x at t minus
one so the short of it is as you look at
these layers not only does it does the
propagate through the first layer goes
into the second layer back into itself
but it's also going into the third layer
so now we're kind of stacking those up
and this can get very complicated as you
grow that in size it also grows in
memory too and in the amount of
resources it takes but it's a very
powerful tool to help us address the
problem of complicated long sequential
information coming in like we were just
looking at in the sentence and when
we're looking at our long short term
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing in the lstms that we look at
the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts of the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell state
values so we only want to update the
cell state values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever's coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like uh so step one decides how much of
the past it should remember first step
in the lstm is to decide which
information to be omitted in from the
cell in that particular time step it is
decided by the sigmoid function it looks
at the previous state h to t minus 1 and
the current input x of t and computes
the function so you can see over here we
have a function of t
equals the sigmoid function of the
weight of f the h at t minus one and
then x a t plus of course you have a
bias in there with any of our neural
network so we have a bias function so f
of t equals forget gate decides which
information to delete that is not
important from the previous time step
considering an stm is fed with the
following inputs from the previous and
present time step alice is good in
physics john on the other hand is good
in chemistry so previous output john
plays football well he told me yesterday
over the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the first
full stop compares with the current
input sentence of x a t so we're looking
at that full stop and then compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about john so the
information on alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with john then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to john and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only passing information on
john since that's now the new topic so
step two is then to decide how much
should this unit add to the current
state in the second layer there are two
parts one is the sigmoid function and
the other is a tangent h in the sigmoid
function it decides which values to let
through zero or one tangent h function
gives a weightage to the values which
are passed deciding their level of
importance minus one to one and you can
see the two formulas that come up uh the
i of t equals the sigmoid of the weight
of i h to t minus one x of t plus the
bias of i and the c of t equals the
tangent of h of the weight of c of h of
t minus one x of t plus the bias of c so
our i of t equals the input gate
determines which information to let
through based on its significance in the
current time step if this seems a little
complicated don't worry because a lot of
the programming is already done when we
get to the case study understanding
though that this is part of the program
is important when you're trying to
figure out these what to set your
settings at you should also note when
you're looking at this it should have
some semblance to your forward
propagation neural networks where we
have a value assigned to a weight plus a
bias very important steps than any of
the neural network layers whether we're
propagating into them the information
from one to the next or we're just doing
a straightforward neural network
propagation let's take a quick look at
this what it looks like from the human
standpoint as i step out of my suit
again consider the current input at x of
t john plays football well he told me
yesterday over the phone that he had
served as a captain of his college
football team that's her input input
gate analysis the important information
john plays football and he was a captain
of his college team as important he told
me over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute
but as a human being if i wanted to get
this information from a conversation
maybe it's a google voice listening in
on you or something like that um how do
we weed out the information that he was
talking to me on the phone yesterday
well i don't want to memorize that he
talked to me on the phone yesterday or
maybe that is important but in this case
it's not i want to know that he was the
captain of the football team i want to
know that he served i want to know that
john plays football and he was the
captain of the college football team
those are the two things that i want to
take away as a human being again we
measure a lot of this from the human
viewpoint and that's also how we try to
train them so we can understand these
neural networks finally we get to step
three decides what part of the current
cell state makes it to the output the
third step is to decide what will be our
output first we run a sigmoid layer
which decides what parts of the cell
state make it to the output then we put
the cell state through the tangent h to
push the values to be between -1 and 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate so when we talk about the
output of t we set that equal to the
sigmoid of the weight of zero of the h
of t minus one and back one step in time
by the x of t plus of course the bias
the a t equals the outer t times the
tangent of the tangent h of c of t so
our oft equals the output gate allows
the passed in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence john played
tremendously well against the opponent
and one for his team for his
contributions brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun john could be the best
output after brave thumbs up for john
awarded player of the match and if you
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
brave contributions or brave teen brave
player brave match um size in there this
and you can start to train this these
this neural network so it starts looking
at and goes oh no john is what we're
talking about so brave is an adjective
john's going to be the best output and
we give john a big thumbs up and then of
course we jump into my favorite part the
case study use case implementation of
lstm let's predict the prices of stocks
using the lstm network based on the
stock price data between 2012
2016. we're going to try to predict the
stock prices of 2017. and this will be a
narrow set of data we're not going to do
the whole stock market it turns out that
the new york stock exchange generates
roughly three terabytes of data per day
that's all the different trades up and
down of all the different stocks going
on in each individual one
second to second or nanosecond to
nanosecond but we're going to limit that
to just some very basic fundamental
information so don't think you're going
to get rich off this today but at least
you can give an eye you can give a step
forward in how to start processing
something like stock prices a very valid
use for machine learning in today's
markets
use case implementation of lstm
let's dive in we're going to import our
libraries we're going to import the
training set and get the scaling going
now if you watch any of our other
tutorials a lot of these pieces just
start to look very familiar because it's
very similar setup let's take a look at
that and just a reminder we're going to
be using anaconda the jupiter notebook
so here i have my anaconda navigator
when we go under environments i've
actually set up a cross python 36 i'm in
bayer architex and uh nice thing about
anaconda especially the newer version
remember a year ago messing with
anaconda in different versions of python
in different environments anaconda now
has a nice interface
and i have this installed both on an
ubuntu linux machine and on windows so
it works fine on there you can go in
here and open a terminal window and then
in here once you're in the terminal
window this is where you're going to
start
installing using pip to install your
different modules and everything now
we've already pre-installed them so we
don't need to do that in here but if you
don't have them installed in your
particular environment you'll need to do
that and of course you don't need to use
the anaconda or the jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python id you like i'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine i have specifically
installed one for cross since we're
going to be working with cross under
tensorflow we go back to home i've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment i've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch jupiter
notebook now i've already in my jupiter
notebook
have set up a lot of stuff so that we're
ready to go kind of like martha
stewart's in the old cooking show so we
want to make sure we have all our tools
for you so you're not waiting for them
to load and if we go up here to where it
says new you can see where you can
create a new python 3 that's what we did
here underneath the setup so it already
has all the modules installed on it and
i'm actually renamed this if you go
under file you can rename it we've i'm
calling it rnn stock and let's just take
a look and start diving into the code
let's get into the exciting part now
we've looked at the tool and of course
you might be using a different tool
which is fine
let's start putting that code in there
and seeing what those imports and
uploading everything looks like now
first half is kind of boring when we hit
the run button because we're going to be
importing numpy as np that's uh the
number python which is your numpy array
and the matplot library because we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
is pd and when i hit run it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick draw here oops shift alt
there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if i was to divide this
up oops i'm going to actually let's
overlap these here we go
this first part that we're going to do
is
our data
prep
a lot of prepping involved
in fact depending on what your system is
since we're using cross i put an overlap
here uh but you'll find that almost
maybe even half of the code we do is all
about the data prep and the reason i
overlapped this with uh cross let me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because cross has
like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple steps a lot of
times that are in the kara setup we'll
take a look at that to see what comes up
in our code as we go through and look at
stock and the last part is to evaluate
and if you're working with
shareholders or
classroom whatever it is you're working
with the evaluate is the next biggest
piece
so the actual code here crossed is a
little bit more but when you're working
with some of the other packages you
might have like three lines that might
be it all your stuff is in your
pre-processing and your data since cross
has is is cutting edge and you load the
individual layers
you'll see that there's a few more lines
here and crosses a little bit more
robust and then you spend a lot of times
like i said with the evaluate you want
to have something you present to
everybody else and say hey this is what
i did this is what it looks like so
let's go through those steps this is
like a kind of just general overview and
let's just take a look and see what the
next set of code looks like and in here
we have a data set train and it's going
to be read using the pd or pandas dot
read csv and it's a google stock price
train dot csv and so under this we have
training set equals data set train dot
ilocation and we've kind of sorted out
part of that so what's going on here
let's just take a look at let's look at
the actual file and see what's going on
there now if we look at this
ignore all the extra files on this i
already have a train and a test set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take
20 of the data out so we can test it and
then we train the rest of it that's what
we use to create our neural network that
way we can find out how good it is uh
but let's go ahead and just take a look
and see what that looks like as far as
the file itself and i went ahead and
just opened this up in a basic word pad
and text editor just so we can take a
look at it certainly you can open up an
excel or any other kind of spreadsheet
and we note that this is a comma
separated variables we have a date
open high low close volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock or the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download in this case
we downloaded it from google that's why
we call it the google stock price
and this specifically is google this is
the google stock values from as you can
see here we started off at 1 3 2012.
so when we look at this first setup up
here
we have a data set train equals pd
underscore csv and if you noticed on the
original frame
let me just go back there
they had it set to home ubuntu downloads
google stock price train i went ahead
and changed that because we're in the
same file where i'm running the code so
i've saved this particular python code
and i don't need to go through any
special paths or have the full path on
there and then of course we want to take
out
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using
our data set
and we're now in pandas
so pandas basically it looks like a
spreadsheet
and in this case we're going to do
ilocation which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
and the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we we start with zero which is the date
and we're going to be looking at open
and high which would be one and two
i'll just label that right there so you
can see now
when you go back and do this you
certainly can extrapolate and do this on
all the columns
but for the example let's just limit a
little bit here so that we can focus on
just some
key aspects of stock
and then we'll go up here and run the
code and again i said the first half is
very boring whenever we hit the run
button it doesn't do anything because
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up
now that we've loaded our data we want
to go ahead and scale it we want to do
what they call feature scaling and in
here we're going to pull it up from the
sk learn or the sk kit pre-processing
import min max scaler and when you look
at this you got to remember that biases
in our data we want to get rid of that
so if you have something that's like a
really high value let's just draw a
quick graph
and i have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value one stock has a
value of a hundred and another stock has
a value of five
you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100 is going to
be the max
and 5 is going to be the min
and then everything else goes and then
we change this so we just squish it down
i like the word squish so it's between
one and zero so 100 equals one or one
equals a hundred and zero equals five
and you can just multiply it's usually
just a simple multiplication we're using
uh multiplication
so it's going to be minus 5 and then 100
divided or 95 divided by 1. so or
whatever value is divided by 95.
and once we've actually created our
scale we've telling is going to be from
zero to one we want to take our training
set and we're gonna create a training
set scaled and we're gonna use our
scalar sc we're gonna fit we're gonna
fit and transform the training set uh so
we can now use the sc this this
particular object will use it later on
our testing set because remember we have
to also scale that when we go to test
our model and see how it works and we'll
go ahead and click on the run again
it's not going to have any output yet
because we're just setting up all the
variables
okay so we paste the data in here and
we're going to create the data structure
with the 60 time steps and output
first note we're running 60 time steps
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our x train and y train variables
we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for i in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there's nothing
below the 60. so if we're going to use
60 time steps we have to start at point
60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our x train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between 0 and 1 and then as
i is equal to 60 this value is going to
be
60 minus 60 is 0. so this actually is
0 to i so it's going to be 0 60 1 to 61.
let me just circle this part right here
1 to 61
2 to 62 and so on and so on and if you
remember i said 0 to 60 that's incorrect
because it does not count remember it
starts at 0 so this is a count of 60 so
it's actually 59. important to remember
that as we're looking at this
and then the second part of this that
we're looking at so if you remember
correctly here we go we go from
0 to 59 of i and then we have a comma a
0 right here and so finally we're just
going to look at the open value now i
know we did put it in there for one to
two
if you remember quickly it doesn't count
the second one so it's just the open
value we're looking at just open
and then finally we have y train dot
append training set
i to 0 and if you remember correctly i 2
or i comma 0. if you remember correctly
this is 0 to 59 so there's 60 values in
it so we do i down here this is number
60. so we're going to do this is we're
creating an array and we have 0
to 59
and over here we have number 60 which is
going into the y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a
0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12
58 that's where this value here comes in
that's the length of the data we're
loading
so we've loaded two arrays we've loaded
one array that has uh which is filled
with arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded
one array which is just the value and
what we're looking at you want to think
about this as a time sequence uh here's
my open open open open open open what's
the next one in the series so we're
looking at the google stock and each
time it opens we want to know what the
next one zero through 59 what's 60 1
through 60 what's 61. 2 through 62
what's 62 and so on and so on going up
and then once we've loaded those in our
for loop we go ahead and take x train
and y train equals
np.arrayxtrain.npray train we're just
converting this back into a numpy array
that way we can use all the cool tools
that we get with numpy array including
reshaping so if we take a look and see
what's going on here we're going to take
our x train
we're going to reshape it
wow what the heck does reshape mean uh
that means we have an array if you
remember correctly um so many numbers by
60.
that's how wide it is
and so we're when you when you do x
train dot shape that gets one of the
shapes and you get
x train dot shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by
this case where's that value 60 pi 11 99
12 58 minus 60 11.99 and we're making
sure that that is shaped correctly so
the data is grouped into
11.99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer
needs to be one value that's like the
leaf of a tree where this is the branch
and then it branches out some more um
and then you get the leaf np dot reshape
comes from and using the existing shapes
to form it we'll go ahead and run this
piece of code again there's no real
output and then we'll import our
different cross modules that we need so
from cross models we're going to import
the sequential model dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dents our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and i'll bring port porter modules
and you'll see we get an error on here
and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such cutting edge modules they're
completely being updated all the time
we're not going to worry too much about
the warning all it's saying is that the
h5py
module which is part of cross is going
to be updated at some point and if
you're running new stuff on cross and
you start updating your cross system you
better make sure that your h5pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the h5pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and i said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean i meant that and we're going
to start off with initializing the rnn
and then we'll start adding those layers
in and you'll see that we have the lstm
and then the dropout lstm then dropout
lstm then dropout what the heck is that
doing so let's explore that we'll start
by initializing the rnn regressor equals
sequential because we're using the
sequential model and we'll run that and
load that up and then we're going to
start adding our lstm layer and some
drop dropout regularization and right
there should be the q dropout
regularization and if we go back here
and remember our exploding gradient well
that's what we're talking about the
dropout drops out unnecessary data so
we're not just shifting huge amounts of
data through the network so and so we go
in here let's just go ahead and add this
in i'll go ahead and run this and we had
three of them so let me go and put all
three of them in and then we can go back
over them there's the second one and
let's put one more in let's put that in
and we'll go ahead and put two more in i
mean i said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time i run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50. the units is the positive integer
and it's the dimensionality of the
output space this is what's going out
into the next layer so we might have 60
coming in but we have 50 going out we
have a return sequence because it is a
sequence data so we want to keep that
true and then you have to tell it what
shape it's in well we already know the
shape by just going in here and looking
at x train shape so input shape equals
the x train shape of one comma one makes
it real easy you don't have to remember
all the numbers and put in 60 or
whatever else is in there you just let
it tell the regressor what model to use
and so we follow our stm with a dropout
layer now understanding the dropout
layer is kind of exciting because one of
the things that happens is we can over
train our network that means that our
neural network will memorize such
specific data that it has trouble
predicting anything that's not in that
specific realm to fix for that each time
we run through the training mode we're
going to take point two or twenty
percent of our neurons and just turn
them off so we're only gonna train on
the other ones and it's gonna be random
that way each time we pass through this
we don't over train these nodes come
back in in the next training cycle we
randomly pick a different 20. and
finally i see a big difference as we go
from the first to the second and third
and fourth the first thing is we don't
have to input the shape because the
shapes already the output units is 50
here this item the next step
automatically knows this layer is
putting out 50 and because it's the next
layer it automatically sets that and
says oh 50 is coming out from our last
layer that's coming up you know goes
into the regressor and of course we have
our dropout and that's what's coming
into this one and so on and so on and so
the next three layers we don't have to
let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had uh lstm
dropout and dents dens just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know i want to know the answer
at this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we bought in
our different modules we formatted the
data for training it we set it up you
know we have our white x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers where we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our cross
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
five total layers now cross is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in cross is cutting edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from cross so we brought in our dents we
have our full model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and i go ahead and run that and if
you've been looking at any of our other
tutorials on neural networks you'll see
we're going to use the optimizer atom
atom is optimized for big data there's a
couple other optimizers out there beyond
the scope of this tutorial but certainly
atom will work pretty good for this and
loss equals mean squared value so when
we're training it this is what we want
to base the loss on how bad is our error
we're going to use the mean squared
value for our error and the atom
optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
going to do our fit fitting the rnn to
the training set we have the
regressor.fit train y train epics and
batch size so we know where this is this
is our data coming in for the x train
our y train is the answer we're looking
for of our data our sequential input
epics is how many times we're going to
go over the whole data set we created a
whole data set of x trains so this is
each each of those rows which includes a
time sequence of 60. and bad size
another one of those things where cross
really shines is if you were pulling
this save from a large file instead of
trying to load it all into ram it can
now pick smaller batches up and load
those indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today because
this isn't big enough to cause the
computer too much of a problem to run
not too straining on the resources but
as we run this you can imagine what
happened if i was doing a lot more than
just one column in one set of stock in
this case google stock imagine if i was
doing this across all the stocks and i
had instead of just the open i had open
close
high low and you can actually find
yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 because there's a
time sequence suddenly you find yourself
with a gig of memory you're loading into
your ram which will just completely you
know if it's just if you're not on
multiple computers or cluster you're
gonna start running into resource
problems but for this we don't have to
worry about that so let's go ahead and
run this and this will actually take a
little bit on my computer it's an older
laptop and give a second to kick in
there there we go all right so we have
epic so this is going to tell me that's
running the first run through all the
data and as it's going through it's
batching them in 32 pieces so 32 lines
each time and there's 1198 i think i
said 11.99 earlier but it's 11.98 i was
off by one and each one of these is 13
seconds so you can imagine this is
roughly 20 to 30 minutes run time on
this computer like i said it's an older
laptop running at 0.9 gigahertz on a
dual processor and that's fine what
we'll do is i'll go ahead and stop go
get a drink of coffee and come back and
let's see what happens at the end and
where this takes us and like any good
cooking show
i've kind of gotten my latte i also had
some other stuff running in the
background so you'll see these numbers
jumped up to like 19 seconds 15 seconds
but you can scroll through and you can
see we've run it through 100 steps or
100 epics so the question is what does
all this mean one of the first things
you'll notice is that our loss can is
over here it kind of stopped at 0.0014
but you can see it kind of goes down
until we hit about 0.014 three times in
a row so we guessed our epic pretty
close since our losses remain the same
on there so to find out we're looking at
we're going to go ahead and load up our
test data the test data that we didn't
process yet and a real stock price data
set test eye location this is the same
thing we did when we prepped the data in
the first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing that we need to do is
go ahead and read the data in from our
test csv you see i've changed the path
on it for my computer and then we'll
call it the real stock price and again
we're doing just the one column here and
the values from i location so it's all
the rows and just the values from these
that one location that's the open stock
open let's go ahead and run that so
that's loaded in there and then let's go
ahead and create we have our inputs
we're going to create inputs here and
this should all look familiar because
this is the same thing we did before
we're going to take our data set total
we're going to do a little panda concat
from the data state train now remember
the end of the data set train is part of
the data going in let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put tr for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out we're looking at we're going to go
ahead and load up our test data the test
data that we didn't process yet and a
real stock price data set test eye
location this is the same thing we did
when we prepped the data in the first
place so let's go ahead and go through
this code and we can see we've labeled
it part 3 making the predictions and
visualizing the results so the first
thing we need to do is go ahead and read
the data in from our test csv you see
i've changed the path on it for my
computer and then we'll call it the real
stock price and again we're doing just
the one column here and the values from
i location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open stock open let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and create
we have our inputs we're going to create
inputs here and this should all look
familiar because this is the same thing
we did before we're going to take our
data set total we're going to do a
little panda concat from the datastate
train now remember the end of the data
set train is part of the data going in
let's just visualize that just a little
bit here's our train data let me just
put tr for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and this value here equals this one and
so we need these top 60 to go into our
new data because that's part of the next
data or it's actually the top 59 so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test.test location so
we're just looking at that first column
the open price and then our data set
total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our dataset test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set as open so pandas is great
that way lots of versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and you'll notice
this is the same as what we did before
we have our open data set where pended
our two different or concatenated our
two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that we didn't train
it with to see how well it graphs and we
have our inputs equals inputs dot
reshapes or reshaping like we did before
we're transforming our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between 0
and 1 and finally we want to go ahead
and take our x test and we're going to
create that x test and for i in range 60
to 80. so here's our x test and we're
appending our inputs i to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and i comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the first column
which is our open column and once again
we take our x test we convert it to a
numpy array we do the same reshape we
did before and then we get down to the
final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor dot predicts x test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want to take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put in between
zero and one well that's not going to
mean very much to me to look at a float
number between 001 i want the dollar
amounts i want to know what the cash
value is and we'll go ahead and run this
and you'll see it runs much quicker than
the training that's what's so wonderful
about these neural networks once you put
them together it takes just a second to
run the same neural network that took us
what a half hour to train add and plot
the data we're going to plot what we
think it's going to be and we're going
to plot it against the real data what
the google stock actually did so let's
go ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our plt that's our uh oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matte plot library.pie plot as plt
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and plt is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when i'm doing
graphs in python because i always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case plt is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done html5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title it's
always nice to give a title to your
graph especially if you're going to
present this to somebody you to your
shareholders in the office and the x
label is going to be time because it's a
time series and we didn't actually put
the actual date and times on here but
that's fine we just know they're
incremented by time and then of course
the y label is the actual stock price
plt.legend tells us to build the legend
on here so that the color red and
real google stock price show up on there
and then the plot shows us that actual
graph so let's go ahead and run this and
see what that looks like and you can see
here we have a nice graph and let's talk
just a little bit about this graph
before we wrap it up here's our legend i
was telling you about that's why we have
the legend to show the prices we have
our title and everything and you'll
notice on the bottom we have a time
sequence we didn't put the actual time
in here now we could have we could have
gone ahead and
plotted the x since we know what the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know that it's only the last
piece of data that we're looking at so
last piece of data which in somewhere
probably around
here on the graph i think it's like
about 20 of the data probably less than
that we have the google price and the
google price has this little up jump and
then down and you'll see that the actual
google instead of
a turn down here just didn't go up as
high and didn't go down so our
prediction has the same pattern but the
overall value is pretty far off as far
as um stock but then again we're only
looking at one column we're only looking
at the open price we're not looking at
how many volumes were traded like i was
pointing out earlier we talk about stock
just right off the bat there's six
columns there's open
high low close volume then there's
weather i mean volume shares then
there's the adjusted open adjusted high
adjusted low adjusted close they have a
special formula to predict exactly what
it would really be worth based on the
value of the stock and then from there
there's all kinds of other stuff you can
put in here so we're only looking at one
small aspect the opening price of the
stock and as you can see here we did a
pretty good job this curve follows the
curve pretty well it has like a little
jumps on it bins they don't quite match
up so this bin here does not quite match
up with that bin there but it's pretty
darn close we have the basic shape of it
and the prediction isn't too far off and
you can imagine that as we add more data
in and look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if i was running it across all
those different variables it might take
a little bit longer to train the data
not so good for doing a quick tutorial
like this in this video we will learn
about an important popular deep learning
neural network called generative
adversarial networks
yan lacoon one of the pioneers in the
field of machine learning and deep
learning described it as the most
interesting idea in the last 10 years in
machine learning in this video you will
learn about what are generative
adversarial networks and look in brief
at generator and discriminator
then we'll understand how gans work and
the different types of gans finally
we'll look at some of the applications
of gans so let's begin
so what are generative adversarial
networks
generative adversarial networks or gans
introduced in 2014 by ian j good fellow
and co-authors became very popular in
the field of machine learning
gan is an unsupervised learning task in
machine learning it consists of two
models that automatically discover and
learn the patterns in input data
the two models called generator and
discriminator compete with each other to
analyze capture and copy the variations
within a data set
gans can be used to generate new
examples that possibly could have been
drawn from the original data set
in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real
hundred rupee notes the generator which
is basically a neural network generates
fake hundred rupees notes the
discriminator network will identify if
the notes are real or fake let us now
understand in brief
about what is a generator a generator in
gans is a neural network that creates
fake data to be trained on the
discriminator
it learns to generate plausible data the
generated instances become negative
training examples for the discriminator
it takes a fixed length random vector
carrying noise as input and generates a
sample now the main aim of the generator
is to make the discriminator classify
its output as real the portion of the
gan that trains a generator includes
a noisy input vector
the generator network which transforms
the random input into a data instance
a discriminator network which classifies
the generated data and a generator loss
which penalizes the generator for
failing to dalt the discriminator
the back propagation method is used to
adjust each weight in the right
direction by calculating the weight's
impact on the output
the back propagation method is used to
obtain gradients and these gradients can
help change the generator weights now
let us understand in brief what a
discriminator is a discriminator is a
neural network model that identifies
real data from the fake data generated
by the generator the discriminator's
training data
comes from two sources
the real data instances such as real
pictures of birds humans currency notes
etc are used by the discriminator as
positive samples during the training
the fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process while
training the discriminator it connects
with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
the discriminator laws
in the process of training the
discriminator the discriminator
classifies both real data and fake data
from the generator the discriminator
loss penalizes the discriminator for
misclassifying a real data instance as
fake or a fake data instance as real now
moving ahead
let's understand how gans work now gans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as g of x and a
discriminator which is represented as d
of x they both play an adversarial game
where the generator tries to fool the
discriminator by generating data similar
to those in the training set
the discriminator tries not to be fooled
by identifying fake data from the real
data
they both work simultaneously to learn
and train complex data like audio video
or image files now you are aware that
gans consists of two networks are
generated g of x and discriminator d of
x now the generator network takes a
sample and generates a fake sample of
data the generator is trained to
increase the probability of the
discriminator network to make mistakes
on the other hand
the discriminator network decides
whether the data is generated or taken
from the real sample using a binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that gives the output
in the range 0 and 1.
here is an example of a generative
adversarial network trying to identify
if the 100 rupee notes are real or fake
so first a noise vector or the input
vector is fed to the generator network
the generator creates fake hundred rupee
nodes
the real images of hundred rupee notes
stored in a database are passed to the
discriminator along with the fake notes
the discriminator then identifies the
notes and classifies them as real or
fake we train the model calculate the
loss function at the end of the
discriminator network and back propagate
the loss into both discriminator and
generator now the mathematical equation
of training again can be represented as
you can see here now this is the
equation
and these are the parameters here g
represents generator
d represents the discriminator
now p data of x is the probability
distribution of real data
p of z is the distribution of generator
x is the sample of probability data of x
z is the sample size from p of z d of x
is the discriminator network and g of
said
is the generator network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
objective function such that d of x is
close to 1
and z of z is close to 0.
it simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from the
training set as real that is one
and all the generated images as fake
that is zero the generator wants to
minimize the objective function such
that
d of z of z is one this means that the
generator tries to generate images that
are classified as real that is one by
the discriminator network next
let's see the steps for training a
neural network so we have to first
define the problem
and collect the data
then we'll choose the architecture of
gan now depending on your problem choose
how your gans should look like
then we need to train the discriminator
in real data that will help us predict
them as real for n number of times next
you need to generate fake inputs for the
generator after that you need to train
the discriminator on fake data to
predict the generator data as fake
finally train the generator on the
output of discriminator
with the discriminator predictions
available train the generator to fool
the discriminator let us now look at the
different types of gans so first we have
vanilla gans
now vanilla gans have min max
optimization formula that we saw earlier
where the discriminator is a binary
classifier and is using sigmoid cross
entropy loss during optimization
in vanilla gans the generator and the
discriminator are simple multi-layer
perceptrons the algorithm tries to
optimize the mathematical equation using
stochastic gradient descent up next we
have deep convolutional gans or dc gans
now dc gans support convolutional neural
networks instead of vanilla neural
networks at both discriminator and
generator they are more stable and
generate higher quality images the
generator is a set of convolutional
layers with fractional strided
convolutions or transpose convolutions
so it unsamples the input image at every
convolutional layer the discriminator is
a set of convolutional layers with
strided convolutions so it down samples
the input image at every convolutional
layer moving ahead
the third type you have is conditional
gans or seagans vanilla gans can be
extended into conditional models by
using an extra label information to
generate better results in c gan an
additional parameter called y is added
to the generator for generating the
corresponding data
labels are fed as input to the
discriminator to help distinguish the
real data from fake data generated
finally we have super resolution gans
now sr gans use deep neural networks
along with adversarial neural network to
produce higher resolution images super
resolution gans generate a
photorealistic high resolution image
when given a low resolution image let's
look at some of the important
applications of gans
so with the help of dc gans you can
train images of cartoon characters for
generating faces of anime characters and
pokemon characters as well next
gans can be used on the images of humans
to generate realistic faces the faces
that you see on your screens have been
generated using gans and do not exist in
reality third application we have is
gans can be used to build realistic
images from textual descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals
we input a sentence and generate
multiple images fitting the description
here is an example of a text to image
translation using gans for a bird with a
black head yellow body and a sort beak
the final application we have is
creating 3d objects
so gans can generate 3d models using 2d
pictures of objects from multiple
perspectives gans are very popular in
the gaming industry
gans can help automate the task of
creating 3d characters and backgrounds
to give them a realistic feel so we're
going to dive right into what is cross
we'll also go all the way through this
into a couple of tutorials because
that's where you really learn a lot is
when you roll up your sleeves so we talk
about what is cross cross is a high
level deep learning api written in
python for easy implement implementation
of neural networks it uses deep learning
frameworks such as tensorflow pi torch
etc is back in to make computation
faster
and this is really nice because as a
programmer there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast
it can get confusing and having some
kind of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different
neural networks
is really powerful it's really powerful
to
have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going
so crossworks by using complex deep
learning frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch
ml played etc as a backend for fast
computation
while providing a user friendly and easy
to learn front-end
and you can see here we have the cross
api uh specifications and under that
you'd have like tf cross for tensorflow
thano cross and so on and then you have
your tensorflow workflow that this is
all sitting on top of
and this is like i said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensorflow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to
dig as deeply into the heavy end stuff
while still having a very robust package
you can get up and running rather
quickly
and it doesn't distract from the
processing time because all the heavy
lifting is done by packages like
tensorflow this is the organization on
top of it
so the working principle of cross
the working principle of keras is cross
uses computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical expressions
you can see here we put them in blue
they have the expression uh expressing
complex problems as a combination of
simple mathematical operators uh where
we have like the percentage or in this
case in python that's usually your left
your remainder or multiplication
you might have the operator of x to the
power of 0.3 and it uses useful for
calculating derivatives by using
back propagation so if we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it
this makes it really easy to do that
without
really having not banging your head and
having to hand write everything it's
easier to implement distributed
computation
and for solving complex problems
specify input and outputs and make sure
all nodes are connected
and so this is really nice as you come
in through is that as your layers are
going in there you can get some very
complicated
different setups nowadays which we'll
look at in just a second and this just
makes it really easy to start spinning
this stuff up and trying out the
different models
so we look across models across model we
have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next layer
and this if you've done anything else
even like the sk learn with their neural
networks and propagation and any of
these setups this should look familiar
you should have your input layer it goes
into your layer 1 layer 2 and then to
the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models
and you can see down here we have the
model equals across sequential this is
the actual code you can see how easy it
is
we have a layer that's dense your layer
one
has an activation they're using the relu
in this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense
relu name layer two and so forth
and they just feed right into each other
so it's really easy just to stack them
as you can see here and it automatically
takes care of everything else for you
and then there's a functional model
and this is really where things are at
this is new make sure you update your
cross or you'll find yourself running
this
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release
and he uses multi-input and multi-output
model the complex model which forks into
two or more branches
and you can see here we have our image
inputs equals your cross input shape
equals 32 by 32 by 3.
you have your dense layers dense 64
activation relu
this should look similar to what you
already saw before but if you look at
the graph on the right it's going to be
a lot easier to see what's going on
you have two different inputs
and one way you could think of this is
maybe one of those is a small image and
one of those is a full-sized image
and
that feedback goes into you might feed
both of them into one note because it's
looking for one thing
and then only into one note for the
other one and so you can start to get
kind of an idea that there's a lot of
use
for this kind of split and this kind of
setup
we have multiple information coming in
but the information is very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want to send it through the same neural
network
and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the date up
and how you fork the models coming down
and so here we do have the two complex
models coming in
we have our image inputs which is a 32
by 32 by three or three channels or four
if you're having an alpha channel
you have your dens your layers dense is
64 activation using the relu very common
x equals dense inputs x layers dense x64
activation equals relu x outputs equals
layers dense 10
x model equals cross model inputs equals
inputs outputs equals outputs name
equals minced model
so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at crust
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks
but it's always good to get on the same
page and for those people who don't
fully understand neural networks to dive
into them a little bit or do a quick
overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex mathical problems
and so just like the neuron one neuron
fires in and it fires out to all these
other neurons or nodes as we call them
and eventually they all come down to
your output layer
and you can see here we have the really
standard graph input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer
one of the biggest parts of any data
processing is your data pre-processing
so we always have to touch base on that
with a neural network like many of these
models
they're kind of
when you first start using them they're
like a black box you put your data in
you train it and you test it and see how
good it was
and you have to pre-process that data
because bad data in is
bad outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with keras the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age
we want to find the possibility of a
patient experiencing side effects due to
their age
and you can think of this in today's
world with covid
uh what's going to happen on there and
we're going to go ahead and do an
example of that in our
live hands-on like i said most of this
you really need to have hands-on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and uh open that up and
open up a jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your setups i just like
those for doing demos and showing people
especially shareholders
it really helps because it's a nice
visual so let me go and flip over to our
anaconda and the anaconda has a lot of
cool two tools they just added data lore
and ibm watson studio cloud into the
anaconda framework but we'll be in the
jupiter lab or jupiter notebook i'm
going to do jupiter notebook for this
because i use the lab for like large
projects with multiple pieces because
multiple tabs where the notebook will
work fine for what we're doing
and this opens up in our browser window
because that's how jupiter dope so
jupiter
notebook is set to run
and we'll go under new
create a new python 3 and it creates an
untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this a
cross
tutorial and let's change that to
capital there we go i'm going to just
rename that
and the first thing we want to go ahead
and do
is uh
get some pre-processing tools involved
and so we need to go ahead and import
some stuff for that like our numpy do
some random number generation
um i mentioned sklearn or your scikit if
you're installing sklearn the sk learn
stuff it's a
scikit you want to look
up that should be a tool of anybody who
is um
doing data science if you if you're not
if you're not familiar with the sklearn
toolkit
it's huge but there's so many things in
there that we always go back to
and we want to go ahead and create some
train labels and train samples for
training our data
and then
just a note of what we're we're actually
doing in here let me go ahead and change
this this is kind of a fun thing you can
do we can change the code to markdown
and then markdown code is nice for doing
examples once you've already built this
our example data we're going to do
experimental
there we go
experimental drug was tested on 2100
individuals between 13 to 100 years of
age
half the participants are under 65 and
95 of participants are under 65
experience no side effects well
ninety-five percent of participants over
sixty-five perc experience side effects
so that's kind of where we're starting
at um and this is just a real quick
example because we're gonna do another
one with a little bit more uh
complicated information
and so we want to go ahead and generate
our setup
so we want to do for i and range and we
want to go ahead and create if you look
here we have random integers
trading the labels append so we're just
creating some random data
let me go ahead and just run that
and so once we've created our random
data and if you if i mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from simplylearn they'll send you a copy
of this or you can
zoom in on the video and see how we went
ahead and did our train samples of pin
and we're just using this i do this kind
of stuff all the time i was running a
thing on uh they had to do with errors
following a bell-shaped curve on
a standard distribution error
and so what do i do i generate the data
on a standard distribution error to see
what it looks like and how my code
processes it since that was the baseline
i was looking for in this we're just
doing
generating random data for our setup on
here
and we could actually go in
print some of the data up let's just do
this print
we'll do train
samples
and we'll just do the first
five pieces of data in there to see what
that looks like
and you can see the first five pieces of
data in our train samples is 49 85 41 68
19.
just random numbers generated in there
that's all that is and we generated
significantly more than that
um let's see 50 up here 1 000 yeah so
there's 1 000 here 1 000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick
print the length of it
and
so or you could do a shape kind of thing
and if you're using numpy
although the link for this is just fine
and there we go it's actually 2100 like
we said in the demo setup in there
and then we want to go ahead and take
our labels oh that was our train labels
we also did samples didn't we
so we could also print
do the same thing
labels
and let's change this to
and labels
and run that just to double check and
sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one zero one zero one zero
i guess that's if they have symptoms or
not one symptoms zero none and so we
wanna go ahead and take our train labels
and we'll convert it into a numpy array
and the same thing with our samples
and let's go ahead and run that
and we also shuffle this is just a neat
feature you can do in numpy right here
put my drawing thing on which i didn't
have on earlier
i can take the data and i can shuffle it
uh so we have our so it's it just
randomizes it that's all that's doing
we've already randomized it so it's kind
of an overkill it's not really necessary
but if you're doing a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow
and you want to randomize it just to
make sure that that you know the input
doesn't follow a certain pattern
that might create a bias in your model
and we go ahead and create a scalar
the scalar range minimum max scalar
feature range zero to one
uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled trained samples so we're going to
go ahead and fit and transform the data
so it's nice and scaled
and that is the age
so you can see up here we have 49 85 41.
we're just moving that so it's going to
be between 0 and 1. and so this is true
with any of your neural networks
you really want to convert the data
to zero and one otherwise you create a
bias
so if you have like a hundred creates a
bias versus
the math behind it gets really
complicated um
if you actually start multiplying stuff
there's a lot of multiplication addition
going on in there
that higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model fits it and
then it will not fit as well and then
one of the fun things we can do in
jupyter notebook is that if you have a
variable you're not doing anything with
it it's the last one on the line
it will automatically print
and we're just going to look at the
first five samples on here it's just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 0.9195.791
so everything's between 0 and 1. and
that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print ups halfway through
you never know what's going to go on
there
i don't know how many times i've gotten
down and found out that the data is sent
to me that i thought was scaled was not
and then i have to go back and track it
down and figure it out on there
uh so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural network
and for doing that this is where we
start diving into tensorflow and cross
tensorflow
if you don't know the history of
it helps to jump into we'll just use
wikipedia
be careful don't quote wikipedia on
these things because you get in trouble
but it's a good place to start back in
2011 google brain built disbelief as a
proprietary machine learning setup
tensorflow became the open source for it
so tensorflow was a google product
and then it became
uh open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defactos when it
comes for neural networks as far as
where we're at
so when you see the tensorflow setup
it it's got like a huge following there
are some other setups like
the kit under the sk learn has their own
little neural network
but the tensorflow is the most robust
one out there right now
and cross sitting on top of it makes it
a very powerful tool so we can leverage
both the cross
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup
on top of tensorflow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensorflow
and then we have the rest of this is all
cross here from number two down
uh
we're gonna import from tensorflow the
cross connection
and then you have your tensorflow cross
models import sequential it's a specific
kind of model we'll look at that in just
a second if you remember
from the files that means it goes from
one layer to the next layer to the next
layer there's no funky splits or
anything like that
and then we have from tensorflow across
layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense layer
and we have our optimizer atom
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atoms as good as any atom is
usually there's a number of optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple of main ones but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data
uh it works fine usually the lower data
does it just fine but atom is probably
the mostly used but there are some more
out there and depending on what you're
doing with your layers your different
layers might have different activations
on them and then finally down here
you'll see
our setup where we want to go ahead and
use the metrics
and we're going to use the tensorflow
cross metrics
for categorical cross entropy
so we can see how everything performs
when we're done that's all that is a lot
of times you'll see us
go back and forth between tensorflow and
then scikit has a lot of really good
metrics also for measuring these things
um again it's the end of the you know at
the end of the story how good does your
model do and we'll go ahead and load all
that and then comes the fun part um i
actually like to spend hours messing
with these things
and
four lines of code you're like oh you're
gonna spend hours on four lines of code
no we don't spend hours on four lines of
code that's not what we're talking about
when i say spend hours on four lines of
code uh what we have here i'm going to
explain that in just a second we have a
model and it's a sequential model if you
remember correctly we mentioned the
sequential up here where it goes from
one layer to the next and our first
layer is going to be your input
it's going to be what they call dense
which is uh
usually it's just dense and then you
have your input and your activation
how many units are coming in we have 16
uh what's the shape
what's the activation and this is where
it gets interesting um because we have
in here
uh relu
on two of these and softmax activation
on one of these
there are so many different options
for
what these mean
and how they function how does the relu
how does the soft max function
and they do a lot of different things
we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
and just
some of it is just uh um almost like
you're playing with it
like an artist you start getting a fill
for like a uh inverse tangent activation
or the tanh activation
takes up a huge processing amount
so you don't see it a lot
yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing word documents and
you're tokenizing the words
and so you'll see this shift from one to
the other because you're both trying to
build a better model
and if you're working on a huge data set
you'll crash the system it'll just take
too long to process
and then you see things like soft max
softmax
generates an interesting
setup
where a lot of these when you talk about
rayleigh it lets me do this
rayleigh there we go raylu has
a setup where if it's less than zero
it's zero and then it goes up
and then you might have what they call
lazy
setup where it has a slight negative to
it so that the errors can translate
better same thing with softmax it has a
slight laziness to it so that errors
translate better all these little
details
make a huge difference on your model
so one of the really cool things about
data science that i like
is you build
your
what they call you build to fail and
it's an interesting
design setup oops i forgot the end of my
code here
the concept to build a file is you want
the model as a whole to work so you can
test your model out
so that you can do
uh
you can get to the end and you can do
your let's see where was it
over shot down here
you can test your test out the quality
of your setup on there
and
see where did i do my tensorflow oh here
we go it was right above me there we go
we start doing your cross-entropy and
stuff like that is you need a full
functional set of code so that when you
run it
you can then test your model out and say
hey it's either this model works better
than this model and this is why
and then you can start swapping in these
models and so when i say spend a huge
amount of time on pre-processing data
it's probably 80 of your programming
time
well between those two it's like 80 20.
you'll spend a lot of time on the models
once you get the model down once you get
the whole code and the flow down
set
depending on your data your models get
more and more robust as you start
experimenting with different inputs
different data streams and all kinds of
things and we can do a simple model
summary here
here's our sequential here's a layer
output a parameter
this is one of the nice things about
cross is you just you can see right here
here's our sequential one model boom
boom boom everything's set and clear and
easy to read
so once we have our model built
the next thing we're going to want to do
is we're going to go ahead
and train that model
and so the next step is of course model
training
and when we come in here
this a lot of times is just paired with
the model because it's so
straightforward
it's nice to
print out the model setup so you can
have a tracking
but here's our model
the keyword in cross is compile
optimizer atom learning rate another
term right there that we're just
skipping right over
that really becomes the meat of
the setup is your learning rate uh so
whoops i forgot that i had an arrow but
i'll just underline it
a lot of times the learning rate set to
0.00
set to 0.01
depending on what you're doing
this learning rate
can overfit and underfit
so you'd want to look up
i know we have a number of tutorials out
on overfitting and underfitting that are
really worth reading once you get to
that point and understanding and we have
our
loss sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is going to tell keras how far
to go until it stops
and then we're looking for metrics of
accuracy so we'll go ahead and run that
and now that we've compiled our model
we want to go ahead and
run it fit it so here's our model fit
we have our scaled train samples
our train labels our validation split
in this case we're going to use 10
percent of the data for validation
uh batch size another number you kind of
play with not a huge difference as far
as how it works
but it does affect how long it takes to
run and it can also affect the bias a
little bit uh most of the time though a
batch size is between 10 to 100
depending on just how much data you're
processing in there we want to go ahead
and shuffle it we're going to go through
30 epics
and
uh put a verb rose of two let me just go
ahead and run this
and you can see right here here's our
epic here's our training
um here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss let's
see where was it
compiled our data
there we go loss so it's looking at the
sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here the lower
the number the better it just keeps
going down
and vice versa accuracy we want let's
see where's my accuracy
value accuracy at the end
and you can see 0.619 0.69 0.74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if it made it all the way to 1
but we also the loss is more important
because
it's a balance
you can have a hundred percent accuracy
and your model doesn't work because it's
over fitted
again you won't look up
over fitting an and underfitting models
and we went ahead and went through 30
epics it's always fun to kind of watch
your code going
to be honest i
usually
the first time i run it i'm like oh
that's cool i get to see what it does
and after the second time of running it
i'm like i like to just not see that and
you can repress those of course in your
code
repress the warnings in the printing
and so the next step is going to be
building a test set and predicting it
now uh so here we go we want to go ahead
and build our test set
and we have just like we did our
training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set
but we'll go ahead and do a separate set
on here
and this is just what we did above
there's no difference as far as
the randomness that we're using to build
this set on here
the only difference is that
we already
did our scalar up here well it doesn't
matter because the the data is going to
be across the same thing but this should
just be just transformed down here
instead of fit transform
because you don't want to refit your
data
on your
testing data
there we go now we're just transforming
it because you never want to transform
the test data
easy to mistake to make especially on an
example like this where we're not doing
you know we're randomizing the data
anyway so it doesn't matter too much
because we're not expecting something
weird
and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict
and we're going to do here's our x scale
data batch size 10 verbose
and now we have our predictions in here
and we could go ahead and do a
oh we'll print
predictions
and then i guess i could just put down
predictions in five so we can look at
the first five of the predictions
and what we have here is we have our
age
and uh the prediction on this age versus
what is what we think it's going to be
but what we think is going to they are
going to have
symptoms or not
and the first thing we notice is that's
hard to read because we really want to
yes no answer
so we'll go ahead and just
round off the predictions
using the arg max
the numpy arg max for prediction so it
just goes to 001
and
if you remember this is a jupiter
notebook so i don't have to put the
print i can just put in
rounded predictions and we'll just do
the first five
and you can see here zero one zero zero
zero so that's what the predictions are
that we have coming out of this
is no symptoms symptoms no symptoms
symptoms no symptoms
and just as we were talking about at the
beginning we want to go ahead and
take a look at this there we go
confusion matrix is for accuracy check
most important part
when you get down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the scikit
the sk learn metrics
site kit being where that comes from
import confusion matrix
some iteration tools and of course a
nice matte plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
have a nice graph to look at a
picture is worth a thousand words
and then we'll go ahead and call it cm
for confusion matrix why true equals
test labels why predict rounded
predictions
and we'll go ahead and load in our cm
and i'm not going to spend too much time
on the plotting
going over the different plotting code
you can spend
like whole we have whole tutorials on
how to do your different plotting on
there
but we do have here is we can do a plot
confusion matrix there's our cm our
classes normalize false title confusion
matrix
c map is going to be in blues
and you can see here we have to the
nearest c map titles all the different
pieces whether you put tick marks or not
the marks the classes the color bar
so a lot of different information on
here as far as how we're doing the
printing of the of the confusion matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
matrix into a seaborn and real quick get
an output
it's worth knowing how to do all this
when you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders
you don't want to do this on the fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice like our guys in the back
did and let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our cm plot
labels
we'll go ahead and run that
and then we'll go ahead and call the
little the
definition
for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
matrix that's our the little script we
just wrote and we're going to dump our
data into it
so our confusion matrix
our classes title confusion matrix and
let's just go ahead and run that
and you can see here we have our basic
setup
no side effects 195
had side effects 200
no side effects that had side effects so
we predicted the 10 of them
who actually had side effects and that's
pretty good i mean i i don't know about
you but you know that's five percent
error on this and this is because
there's 200 here that's where i get five
percent is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a hundred uh
you can do the same kind of math up here
not as quick on the fly because it's 15
and 195 not an easily rounded number but
you can see here where they have 15
people
who predicted to have no
with the no side effects but had side
effects
kind of set up on there and these
confusion matrix are so important at the
end of the day
this is really where where you show
whatever you're working on comes up and
you can actually show them hey this is
how good we are or not how messed up it
is
so this was a
i spent a lot of time on some of the
parts but you can see here is really
simple
we did the random generation of data but
when we actually built the model coming
up here
here's our model summary
and we just have the layers on here that
we built with our model on this and then
we went ahead and trained it and ran the
prediction
now we can get a lot more complicated
let me flip back on over here because
we're going to do another uh demo
so that was our basic introduction to it
we talked about the uh oops there we go
okay so implementing a neural network
with keras after creating our samples
and labels we need to create our cross
neural network model we will be working
with a sequential model which has three
layers and this is what we did we had
our input layer our hidden layers and
our output layers and you can see the
input layer coming in
was the age factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not
so we're going to go ahead and go with
something a little bit more complicated
training our model is a two-step process
we first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set
so we have compiling compiling converts
the code into a form of understandable
by machine
we used the atom in the last example a
gradient descent algorithm to optimize a
model and then we trained our model
which means it let it
learn on training data
and i actually had a little backwards
there but this is what we just did is we
if you remember from our code we just
had let me go back here
[Music]
here's our model that we created
summarized
we come down here and we compile it
so it tells it hey we're ready to build
this model and use it
uh and then we train it this is the part
where we go ahead and fit our model and
and put that information in here and it
goes through the training on there and
of course we scaled the data which was
really important to do and then you saw
we did the creating a confusion matrix
with keras
as we are performing classifications on
our data we need a confusion matrix to
check the results a confusion matrix
breaks down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the accuracy
and so you can see here this is what we
did with the true positive false
positive true negative false negative
and that is what we went over let me
just scroll down here
on the end we printed it out and you can
see we have a nice printout of our
confusion matrix
with the true positive false positive
false negative true negative
so the blue ones
we want those to be the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then
we have our false predictions on here
as far as this one so had no side
effects but we predicted let's see no
side effects predicting side effects and
vice versa if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now uh saving and loading models with
karass we're going to dive into a more
complicated demo
and you're going to say oh that was a
lot of complication before well if you
broke it down we randomized some data we
created the
cross setup we compiled it we trained it
we predicted and we ran our matrix
uh so we're going to dive into something
a lot a little bit more fun is we're
going to do a face mask detection with
cross so we're going to build a cross
model to check if a person is wearing a
mask or not in real time and this might
be important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today which is
um
might be very useful as far as some of
our you know making sure people are safe
and so we're going to look at mask and
no mask and let's start with a little
bit on the data
and so in my data i have with a mask you
can see they just have a number of
images showing the people in masks and
again
if you want some of this information uh
contact simply learn and they can send
you some of the information as far as
people with and without masks so you can
try it on your own and this is just such
a wonderful example of this setup on
here so before i dive into the mass
detection talk about being in the
current with a covid and seeing if
people are wearing masks
this particular example i had to go
ahead and update to a python 3.8 version
it might run in a 3.7 i'm not sure i
haven't i kind of skipped three seven
and installed three eight
uh so i'll be running in a three python
and then you also want to make sure your
tensorflow is up to date because the um
they call functional
layers with that's where they split if
you remember correctly from back
oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them a very powerful
tool
very popular right now in the edge of
where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so i've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and
go through
our next example which includes
multiple layers
programming it to recognize whether
someone wears a mask or not and then
saving that model so we can use it in
real time so we're actually almost a
full
end-to-end development of a product here
of course this is a very simplified
version and it'd be a lot more to it
you'd also have to do like recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this
so let's go ahead and jump into that
code and we'll open up a new python
three oops python three
it's working on it there we go
and then we wanna go ahead and train our
mask we'll just call this train mask
and we wanna go ahead and train mask
and save it
uh so it's it's uh it's safe mask train
mask detection
not to be confused with masking data a
little bit different we're actually
talking about our physical mask on your
face
and then from the cross stand point we
got a lot of imports to do here
and i'm not going to dig too deep on the
imports
we're just going to go ahead and notice
a few of them uh so we have in here
we go alt d there we go
i have something to draw with a little
bit here
we have our
image processing
and the image processing right here let
me underline that
uh deals with how do we bring images in
because most images are like a
a square grid and then each value in
there has three values for the three
different colors cross and tensorflow do
a really good job of
working with that so you don't have to
do all the heavy listening and figuring
out what's going to go on
and we have the mobilenet average
pooling 2d
this again is
how do we deal with the images and
pulling them uh dropout's a cool thing
worth looking up
if you haven't when you as you get more
and more into cross and tensorflow
it'll auto drop out certain notes that
way you'll get a better
the notes just kind of die and they find
that they actually create more of a bias
and help
and they also add processing time so
they remove them
and then we have our flatten that's
where you take that huge array with the
three different colors and you find a
way to flatten it so it's just a one
dimensional array instead of a two by
two by three
uh dense input we did that in the other
one so that should look a little
familiar
oops there we go
our input
our model again these are things we had
on the last one
here's our optimizer with our atom
we have some pre-processing on the input
that goes along with bringing the data
in
more pre-processing with image to array
loading the image
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of works you have to import all
these different modules in here but the
truth is is it does everything for you
you're not doing a lot of pre-processing
you're letting the software do the
pre-processing
um and we're gonna be working with the
setting something to categorical
again that's just a conversion from a
number to a category
0 1 doesn't really mean anything it's
like true false
label binarizer the same thing
we're changing our labels around and
then there's our train test split
classification report
our
im utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here a notch for these
this is something a little different
going on down here this is not part of
the
tensorflow or the sklearn this is the
site kit set up in tensorflow above
the path this is part of
opencv
and we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the opencv so if you want
to know more about opencv you'll get a
glance on it in this software especially
the net the second piece when we reload
up the data and hook it up to a video
camera we're going to do that on this
round
but this is part of the opencv thing
you'll see cv2 is usually how that's
referenced but the im utilities has to
do with how do you rotate pictures
around and stuff like that
uh and resize them and then the matte
plot library for plotting because it's
nice to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight os
access wow so that was a lot of imports
like i said i'm not going to spend i
spent a little time going through them
but we didn't want to go too much into
them
and then i'm going to create
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize
we have the learning rate number of
epochs to train for and the batch size
and if you remember correctly we talked
about the learning rate uh to the
negative 4.0001
a lot of times it's 0.001 or 0.001
usually it's in that
variation depending on what you're doing
and how many epochs and they kind of
play with the epics
the epics is how many times we're going
to go through all the data
now i have it as two
the actual setup is for 20 and 20 works
great the reason i have it for two is it
takes a long time to process
one of the downsides of jupiter
is that jupiter isolates it to a single
kernel so even though i'm on an eight
core processor
with 16 dedicated threads only one
thread is running on this no matter what
so it doesn't matter
so it takes a lot longer to run even
though
tensorflow really scales up nicely and
the batch size is how many pictures do
we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to run
and this just has images of mass and not
masks
and if we go in here you'll see data
set um and then you have pictures with
mess they're just images of people with
mass on their face
and then we have the opposite let me go
back up here
without masks so it's pretty
straightforward they look kind of askew
because they tried to format them into
very similar uh setup on there so
they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here
and that's kind of important thing to do
on a lot of these data sets
get them as close as you can to each
other and we'll we actually will run in
the in this processing of images up here
and the cross layers and importing and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
so you have a couple things going on
there
and so we're now going to be this is now
loading the
images and let me see
and we'll go ahead and create data and
labels here's our
uh here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out
and then for categories in our list
directory directory and if you remember
i just flashed that at you it had
face mask or or no face mask those are
the two options
and we're just going to load into that
we're going to append the image itself
and the labels so we'll just create a
huge array
and you can see right now this could be
an issue if you had more data at some
point thankfully i have a 32 gig hard
drive or
ram
even that
you could do with a lot less of that
probably under 16 or even 8 gigs would
easily load all this stuff
and there's a conversion going on in
here i told you about how we are going
to convert
the size of the image so it resizes all
the images that way our data is all
identical the way it comes in
and you can see here with our labels we
have without mask without mask without
mask
the other one would be with mask those
are the two that we have going in there
and then we need to change it to the one
not hot encoding
and this is going to take our
up here we had was it labels and data
we want the labels to be categorical so
we're going to take labels and change it
to categorical and our labels then equal
a categorical list
we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because
minus 10 to the end there we go just so
we can see where the other side looks
like we now have one that means they
have a mask one zero one zero so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask
and if we did this in reverse
i just realized that this might not make
sense if you've never done this before
let me run this
0 1.
so 0
is
do they have a mask on zero do they not
have a mask on one so this is the same
as what we saw up here without mask one
equals
um the second value is without mass so
with mass without mask
and that's just a with any of your data
processing
we can't really zero if you have a zero
one output
it causes issues as far as training and
setting it up so we always want to use a
one hot encoder if the values are not
actual
uh linear value or regression values
they're not actual numbers
if they represent a thing
and so now we need to go ahead and do
our train x test x train y test y
train split test data
and we'll go ahead and make sure it's
going to be random and we'll take 20
percent of it for testing
and the rest for
setting it up as far as training their
model
this is something that's become so cool
when they're training these set
they realize we can augment the data
what does augment mean well if i rotate
the data around and i zoom in i zoom out
i rotate it
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally
fill mode as i do all these different
things to the data it
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples i have
so if i have all these perfect samples
what happens when we only have part of
the face or the face is tilted sideways
or all those little shifts cause a
problem if you're doing just a standard
set of data so we're going to create an
augment
in our image data generator
which is going to rotate zoom and do all
kinds of cool things and this is worth
looking up this image data generator and
all the different features it has
a lot of times i'll the first time
through my models i'll leave that out
because i want to make sure there's a
thing we call build to fail which is
just cool to know
you build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
so you can better train your model and
so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um i haven't run it myself because the
guys in the back did this
we take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net v2
and this we this is a big thing right
here include the top equals false
a lot of data comes in with a label on
the top row
so we want to make sure that that is not
the case
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model
we want to go ahead and set that up
and you'll see a warning here i'm kind
of ignoring the warning because it has
to do with the
size of the pictures and the weights for
input shape
so they'll switch things to defaults to
say hey we're going to auto shape some
of this stuff for you you should be
aware that with this kind of imagery
we're already augmenting it by moving it
around and flipping it and doing all
kinds of things to it
so that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different domain
and so we're going to go back here and
we're going to have we have our base
model we're going to do our head model
equals our base model output
and what we got here is we have an
average pooling 2d pool size 77 head
model
head model flatten
so we're flattening the data
so this is all
processing and flattening the images and
the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
level in this processing it
um and then we have our dents we've
already talked a little bit about a
dense just what you think about and then
the head model has a drop out
of 0.5
what we can do with a drop out
the dropout says that we're going to
drop out a certain amount of nodes while
training
so when you actually use the model
it will use all the nodes but this drops
certain ones out and it helps
stop biases from performing so it's
really a cool feature in here they
discovered this a while back
we have another dense mode and this time
we're using soft max activation
lots of different activation options
here soft max is a real popular one for
a lot of things and so is a relu
and you know there's we could do a whole
talk on activation formulas
and why what their different uses are
and how they work
when you first start out you'll you'll
use mostly the relu and the softmax for
a lot of them
just because they're some of the basic
setups it's a good place to start
and then we have our model equals model
inputs equals base model dot input
outputs equals head model so again we're
still building our model here we'll go
ahead and run that
and then we're going to loop over all
the layers in the base model and freeze
them so they will not be updated during
the first training process
so for layer and base model layers
layers dot trainable equals false
a lot of times when you go through your
data
you want to kind of jump in part way
through
i
i'm not sure why in the back they did
this for this particular example
but i do this a lot when i'm working
with series and
specifically in stock data i wanted to
iterate through the first set of 30 data
before it does anything
i would have to look deeper to see why
they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model
so compiling the model atom
init layer decay
initial learning rate over epics
and we go ahead and compile our loss is
going to be the binary cross entropy
which we'll have that print out
optimizer for opt metrics is accuracy
same thing we had before not a huge jump
as far as
the previous code
and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model
so train the head of the network print
info training head run
now i skipped a little time because it
you'll see the run time here is at 80
seconds per epic takes a couple minutes
for it to get through on a single kernel
one of the things i want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the processing
is that we have up here our augment
going on so
anytime the train x and train y go in
there's some randomness going on there
it is jiggling it around what's going
into our setup
uh of course we're batch sizing it so
it's going through whatever we set for
the batch values how many we process at
a time
and then we have the steps per epic uh
the train x the batch size validation
data here's our
test x and test y where we're sending
that in
uh this again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is
our
when both our training data and our test
data have about the same accuracy that's
when you want to stop that means that
our model isn't biased
if you have a higher accuracy on your
testing
you know you've trained it and your
accuracy is higher on your actual test
data then something in there is probably
has a bias and it's overfitted
so that's what this is really about
right here with the validation data and
validation steps
so it looks like it's let me go ahead
and see if it's done processing looks
like we've gone ahead and gone through
two epics again you could run this
through about 20
with this amount of data and it would
give you a nice refined model at the end
we're going to stop at two because i
really don't want to sit around all
afternoon and i'm running this on a
single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate
our model and see how good it is and to
do that we need to go ahead and make our
predictions
these are predictions on our test x
to see what it thinks are going to be
so now it's going to be evaluating the
network and then we'll go ahead and go
down here
and we will need to
turn the index in because remember it's
it's either 0 or 1 it's a
0 1 0 1 so you have two outputs
not wearing uh wearing a mask not
wearing a mask
and so we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a
zero or one coming out and then
to finish that off we want to go ahead
and let me just put this right in here
and do it all in one shot we want to
show a nicely formatted classification
report so we can see what that looks
like on here
and there we have it we have our
precision uh it's 97 with a mask
there's our f1 score support without a
mass 97 percent
um so that's pretty
high
set up on there you know you three
people are going to sneak into the store
who
are without a mask and
thinks they have a mask and there's
going to be three people with a mask
that's going to flag the person at the
front to go oh hey look at this person
you might not have a mask
that's if i guess it's just set up in
front of a store um so there you have it
and of course one of the other cool
things about this is if someone's
walking in to the store and you take
multiple pictures of them
um
you know this is just an it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're gonna this is just
cool i love doing this stuff uh so we're
gonna go ahead and take our model and
we're gonna save it
so model save mass detector.model we're
going to give it a name
we're going to save the format
in this case we're going to use the h5
format
and so this model we just programmed has
just been saved so now i can load it up
into say another program what's cool
about this is let's say i want to have
somebody work on the other part of the
program well i just saved the model they
upload the model now they can
use it for whatever and then if i get
more information
and we start working with that at some
point
i might want to update this model and
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where i take this model
and maybe i'm running a prediction on
making money for a company and as my
model gets better
i want to keep updating it and then it's
really easy just to push that out to the
actual end user
uh here we have a nice graph you can see
the training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics
we only did the you know only shows just
the one epic coming in here but you can
see right here as the
value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're
i know when i work in the
psy kit with sk learn neural networks
this is what they're talking about a
convergence
is our
loss and our accuracy come together and
also up here and this is why i'd run it
more than just two epochs as you can see
they still haven't converged all the way
so that would be a cue for me to keep
going
but what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and create a new
python 3
program
and we just did our train mask so now
we're going to go ahead and import that
and use it and show you in a live action
get a view of both myself in the
afternoon along with my background of an
office which is in the middle still of
reconstruction for another month
and we'll call this a mask
detector
and then we're going to grab a bunch of
a few items coming in
uh we have our
mobilenet v2 import pre-processing input
so we're still going to need that
we still have our tensorflow image to
array we have our load model that's
where most of stuff's going on
this is our cv2 or opencv again i'm not
going to dig too deep into that we're
going to flash a little opencv code at
you
and we actually have a tutorial on that
coming out
our numpy array our im utilities which
is part of
the opencv or cv2 setup
and then we have of course time and just
our operating system so those are the
things we're going to go ahead and set
up on here and then we're going to
create
this takes just a moment
our module here which is going to do all
the heavy lifting
so we're going to detect and predict a
mask we have frame face net mass net
these are going to be generated by our
open cv we have our frame coming in and
then we want to go ahead and create a
mask around the face it's going to try
to detect the face and then set that up
so we know what we're going to be
processing through our model
and then there's a frame shape here this
is just our height versus width that's
all hw stands for
they've called it blob which is a cv2
dnn blob form image frame
so this is reformatting this frame
that's going to be coming in literally
from my camera
and we'll show you that in a minute that
little piece of code that shoots that in
here
and we're going to pass the blob through
the network and obtain the face
detections
so face net dot set import blob
detections face net forward
print detections shape
uh so these is this is what's going on
here this is that model we just created
we're going to send that in there and
i'll show you in a second where that is
but it's going to be under face net
and then we go ahead and initialize our
list of faces their corresponding
locations and the list of predictions
from our face mask network
we're going to loop over the detections
and this is a little bit more work than
you think
as far as looking for different faces
whatever the view of a crowd of faces
so we're looping through the detections
and the shapes going through here
and probability associated with the
detection
here's our confidence of detections
we're going to filter out weak detection
by ensuring the confidence is greater
than the minimum confidence
so we've said it remember 0 to 1 so 0.5
would be our minimal confidence probably
is pretty good
[Music]
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if i'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open cv and i really want
to stick to just the cross part
and so i'm i'm just kind of jumping
through all this code you can get a copy
of this code from simply learn and take
it apart or look for the opencv coming
out
and we'll create a box uh the box sets
it around the image
ensure the bounding boxes fall within
the dimensions of the frame
so we create a box around what's going
to what we hope is going to be the face
extract the face roi convert it from bgr
to rgb channel
again this is an open cv issue not
really an issue but it has to do with
the order i don't know how many times
i've forgotten to check the order colors
working with opencv
because there's all kinds of fun things
when red becomes blue
and blue becomes red
and we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it
face frame
setup again the face the cbt color we're
going to convert it
we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input
pin the face locate face start x dart y
and x
boy that was just a huge amount and i
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face
and that box because the open cv does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on it
and so that's what that's what all this
is doing on here and then finally we get
down to this where it says predictions
equals mass net dot predict faces batch
size 32.
uh so these different images where we're
guessing where the face is are then
going to go through and
generate an array of faces if you will
and we're going to look through and say
does this face have a mask on it and
that's what's going right here is our
prediction that's the big thing that
we're working for
and then we return the locations and the
predictions the location just tells
where on the picture it is
and then the
prediction tells us what it is is it a
mask or is it not a mask
all right so we've loaded that all up
so we're going to load our serialized
face detector model from disk
and we have our the path that it was
saved in obviously you're going to put
it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it
then we have our weights path
and so finally our face net here it is
equals
cb2.dnn dot read net
prototext path weights path and we're
going to load that up on here so let me
go ahead and run that
and then we also need to i'll just put
it right down here i always hate
separating these things in there
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from disk this is
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling on all the different pieces
we need for our model
and then the next part
is we're going to create open up our
video
and this is just kind of fun because
it's all part of the opencv
the video set up
and we just put this all in as one
there we go
uh so we're going to go ahead and open
up our video we're going to start it and
we're going to run it until we're
done
and this is where we get some real like
kind of live action stuff which is fun
this is what i like working about with
images and videos
is that when you start working with
images and videos it's all like right
there in front of you it's visual and
you can see what's going on
so we're going to start our video
streaming this is grabbing our video
stream source zero start
that means it's grabbing my main camera
i have hooked
up and then you know starting video
you're going to print it out
here's our video source equals 0 start
loop over the frames from the video
stream
oops a little redundancy there
let me close
i'll just leave it that's how they
headed in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
from our visual
stream
we're going to resize it
and then we have we're returning
remember we returned from the our
procedure the location and the
prediction so detect and predict mask
we're sending it the frame
we're sending it the face net and the
mast net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on here
and then it returns our location and
predictions and then for our box
and predictions in the location and
predictions
and the boxes is again this is an open
cv set that says hey this is a box
coming in from the location
because you have the two different
points on there
and then we're going to unpack the box
in predictions and we're going to go
ahead and do mask without a mask equals
prediction
we're going to create our label
no mask and create color if the label
equals mask l0 225 and you know it's
going to make a lot more sense when i
hit the run button here
but we have the probability of the label
we're going to display the label and
bounding box rectangle on the output
frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
show the output from the frame cb2 i am
show frame frame and then the key equals
cp2 weight key one we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our feed
and we're going to do this until
we hit the stop button pretty much
so you're ready for this to see if it
works we've distributed our
our model we've loaded it up into our
distributed uh code here we've got a
hooked into our camera and we're going
to go ahead and run it
and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
pop-up
and there i am in my office with my
funky headset on
uh
and you can see in the background my
unfinished wall and it says up here no
mask oh no i don't have a mask on
i wonder if i cover my mouth
what would happen
you can see my no mask
goes down a little bit i wish i brought
a mask into my office uh it's up at the
house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98
chance that i don't have a mask on and
it's true i don't have a mask on right
now and this could be distributed this
is actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat uh
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store or a public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask
let me go ahead and stop that
now if you want a copy of this
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into opencv in another one so i
skipped a lot of the opencv
code in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the cross
saving the model uploading the model and
then processing a streaming video
through it so you can see it that the
model works we actually have this
working model that hooks into
the video camera
which is just pretty cool a lot of fun
so i told you we're going to dive in and
really roll up our sleeve and do a lot
of coding today we did the basic uh
demo up above for just pulling in across
and then we went into a cross model
where we pulled in data to see whether
someone was wearing a mask or not so
very useful in today's world as far as a
fully running application and we're
going to be going over the open cv
tutorial and it's going to throw in some
cross and we're actually going to be
covering a lot of ground
in this tutorial so i'll speed up for
some of it and slow down as we focus on
important aspects
we talk about opencv
we're really talking about computer
vision so what is computer vision
and i would say
opencv goes way beyond
computer vision it goes into graphic
editors and all kinds of other things
but we're going to be focusing a little
bit on computer vision and we're going
to cover the whole slew of the editors
and all the other cool stuff that's in
there
computer vision is a field of machine
learning whose goal is to help computers
see
its end goal is to make intelligent
systems which can understand digital
images
and you can there's all kinds of
different examples from handwriting
identification categorizing of pictures
is that a dog or a cat in the picture
and all that different things those are
all part of the computer vision
cars the the new automated cars and
being able to drive down the road they
usually use aspects of computer vision
to do that for our ais
so
what is opencv
opencv is a huge open source library for
computer vision machine learning and
image processing it can be used to
process images and videos to identify
objects faces or even handwriting of a
human
and one of the cool things is it's um
the opencv project is outside of python
but it has a high integration with
python so you can use it in other
programming languages you're not set to
just python with it and there's a huge
community behind it which is really nice
that's what makes the open cv project so
great
we'll start with installing the opencv
it's pretty straightforward in python
you do a pip install opencv python
you can pip install opencv can trip
python headless
opencv can be installed in windows mac
os or any and gnu linux distribution by
using the pip command
the first one the first command we went
over is to install the main module
packages and the second one is for the
full package and usually you want the
full package
once you start digging into it it's so
easy to use there's so much fun things
you can play with
so the most common thing is reading in
uh image in opencv and we'll do this
also in code so if i go a little quick
on the slides it's so that we can roll
up our sleeves and actually open up and
do the coding on there
so when we reading an image in an opencv
given an image to load it in we can use
the opencv function i am read the image
can be displayed using the function i am
show
and so these are your two main
categories on here
uh and so your basic thing is to read an
image in then you can manipulate it and
then you can display it depending on
what you're using it for
and then when we talk about manipulating
it the most common thing is probably
resizing images and videos so you can
read in videos and we'll look at the
command for that also and how you can
process them frame by frame
resizing is uh helpful in all kinds of
aspects obviously on the display you
might want to resize it so it fits the
display a certain way a lot of times
that's handled
for the size of the image if you're
uploading it to the web you might want
to have a smaller image so you're not
taking up a huge amount of memory
not as big of a deal anymore and then a
lot of times the actual web page would
handle the size of the image once you
upload it uh but what if you want to
process all the images under the same um
neural network well they're going to
look for the same size and that's also
as huge as to be able to resize your
images to go into that neural network so
you're not looking at different sized
images and images read in might not be
of correct size or might not fit the
screen correctly to overcome this we can
resize the image and you can see it's a
real simple command in the
cv and we're actually using what they
call cv2 a lot of times people just
they'll import
cv2 as or open cv2 as cv
just to make it easy
because they might have old code or
something like that it's easy to swap
things in and move forward
and you can see here we just resize we
have our image we have our new
dimensions and then how do we resize it
the interpolation is kind of a function
in there
as far as how to guess the colors
because you're combining colors and
different things
and we can use a drawing with the opencv
we can draw images in opencv allows us
to draw various things like a rectangle
circles lines
you add text into the images and that
kind of thing so there's a whole slew of
different things we can do with the
opencv and we'll look at these commands
we'll glance through them
and show you how they work in the actual
software and they have basic image
functions
and
this is just so cool because so much of
this is built in you go back 10 years
and people are writing the code to do
this stuff and now it's all built in
and people are continually optimizing it
so you can do a lot of things without
having to lift the hood up and
really do the heavy lifting underneath
uh so opencv has built-in functions
which allow us to perform various
operations on our images such as
blurring resizing cascading edge
detection and cropping and there's also
motion detection and videos there's all
kinds of things
and you can see here we have blurring we
can take an image and blur it slightly
we can resize it
it's easy to crop it you know that we
can do the round
head face cropping on a web page or
whatever
or identify where the object is and crop
the background out kind of thing and you
have image transformation we talked a
little bit
just a second ago on blurring
uh we can also do things like rotating
it um we can transform the image
various ways you can see here we can
shift it so we can shift it left shift
it right flip it crop it
all these are very easy to do in the
opencv package
and then i mentioned a little bit about
we start looking at motion detection and
detecting different things
there's contour detection which is built
into the opencv package which is really
nice and again this is stuff
that
usually was somebody in the back in
programming this and now you have opencv
which does almost everything for you
so a contour is a curve or a line
joining all points which have the same
color intensity contours help us find
the points which lie on the same plane
and assist in edge detection
and you can see here we've taken the cat
and done a contour detection and it kind
of looks it makes it look almost like
someone
stenciled it in there that sounds kind
of cool little zen art going on there
this is how if the computer might using
contour detection see the cat on the
black background
and then you also can adjust the color
channels
so you can play with all the colors any
image is basically a combination of
three main colors red green blue the rgb
sometimes
a quick note which
we won't cover in the programming is
when you see that rgb it's not always in
that order uh there's different formats
for it and so there's also sometimes the
alpha channels you might have rgb a
where a is how
transparent it is so you might actually
have four channels which
i like to work with when trying to take
the background out because the edges of
images actually have reflections
um and light is also a curve and wraps
around so there's some cool things to
know when you're messing with these
things
and opencv allows us to split our image
into its respective color channels
and you can see here we've taken the
image of a
little landscape and we've sorted it out
into different channels and you can see
how you have it all in the blues the
reds and the greens
and there's also color spaces
color spaces are a way to represent the
color channels present in an image
they tell us the various color channels
which are contributing to a particular
hue
so again we can pull things out based on
the hue and the images and colors on
there
and blurring blurring
is very popular right now because it's
easy to find someone's face and then
blur out the background
without having to play with alpha
channels and different things for the
coloring around the you know you have
the edging of the head and the coloring
so blurring is a method used to remove
noise from an image by applying a low
pass filter over an image we smooth out
the edges and make the transition from
one color to another very smooth
and you might not be able to see the
difference in the cat video but you
start seeing smoothness and sharpness
have always been a mainstay of editing
images and things like that over the
years and so this is all built into
opencv and then there's bitwise
operations
bitwise operations are
the and or zore etc in image processing
they are used to create
a new image or for masking
and we'll
glance at masking but masking is huge
so when we get into the code we'll talk
a little bit more about masking i'll
probably
maybe offshoot for a minute on that the
operation is done between each pixel of
two images
and so you can see here we have the
square
plus the circle so if it's an and
only where the white is so where it's in
both images it then equals a new image
with just the white parts
in masking
masking is used to bring certain parts
of an image into focus by lowering the
definition over other parts this is done
by reducing the picture quality of other
parts of the image
kind of a little short on the on the
masking of what it is
uh so in this case the masking would
either be the background
might be all ones and the cat in the
fence might be zeros or vice versa we
might put the cat as one in the
background as zeros
and then you can do a transformation
on either the background or the
foreground to maybe you want to blur the
background out and make the foreground
sharper
or maybe you want to make the the little
circle with the cat in it
take the colors out so it's one color
masking allows you to separate your
image out and do those different things
and that's where the masking comes in
and it has a lot of uses and then
there's histograms uh histograms in an
image processing histograms typically
refer to a graph of pixel intensity
values the intensity of each pixel is
plotted in a histogram again we start
with these histograms are the beginning
of doing different identifications and
can be used for different things
you don't really
publish a histogram onto your web page
of the cats because it's just kind of
silly but you can use that data in data
processing to look at different things
and pull different things out of the
picture
thresholding another important aspect of
uh image processing a method of image
segmentation it is used to convert an
image
of binary by setting a
threshold intensity value and deeming
all values above it as one converted to
white and below a zero black
and you can see here we were talking
about masks
in the threshold we're able to actually
create a mask of the image in this case
you have the
cats which are mostly white stand out
because we put whatever the value is
to pull those cats out and put the
background further back
edge detection just like threshold it's
another tool we can use to bring out
an image
so we can find different things on there
a lot of cool things we can do with that
you can see here we've taken a landscape
same one
we had before
and we can find the boundaries of an
image by consistency and brightness it's
used for image segmentation and data
extraction
and you can see with this image of the
buildings how
powerful it is just to pull the whole
sky out i mean you know where the sky is
there's no debate on it
so finding edge detection has a lot of
cool things it can do when you're
processing images and pulling the images
apart so
with that
really the hands-on there's so much
hands-on on this
so
we're going to start with a real uh
basic open cv setup in python
we'll then take a look at some motion
detection i usually don't put the video
on here because my office is under
construction you can see the partially
finished wall in the back
but when we do the motion detection
we'll have the video up and show you how
to pull this video in just like i'm
doing here and utilize that in a program
you can actually start detecting motions
you could think of a wilderness webcam
or something like that all kinds of fun
things you can do with motion detection
and then we'll get into
melding a little bit with the opencv and
write a a short cross
neural network that will train and do
facial
identification so we're going to cover
just a slew of really cool tools that
you can do with opencv
so here's my favorite package to work in
the anaconda
i'm going to be in python 3.8
and then if you haven't yet you need to
go under environments
you can either
install them through anaconda here
or you can open up
let's see where is it 38 you can open up
your terminal and do the pip install
like we discussed earlier in the slide
and that was this slide right here pip
install opencv contrib python headless
i would just go right for the second one
because it installs everything
so it's a full package and you just go
ahead and open up in this case pi 38
there's my terminal window and i can
simply do my pip command in here
you can also
if you're in anaconda
we can go in here let's do all search
the packages for opencv
and you can see here's your opencv
library opencv python opencv and i
actually installed all of these all
these are installed on my my anaconda
for the use of this
setup didn't want to miss anything uh
and then once we open this up
we're going to go in here to new
and create a new python window
python 3 in this case we're in 3.8 as i
told you which is what's set up in here
and we'll start with just uh opencv
general
so let's put that in here open cv
that's just a general setup on there for
doing our opencv
and uh
of course some people like to
i'm not big and looking at my own face
the whole time during these but we're
going to put my video back up there
and when we talk about the opencv
we want to go ahead and import all of
our different aspects of what we're
going to be working on in here
and you'll see on this we have our
import cv2 and i mentioned earlier that
a lot of people when they see the import
cv2 they just go ahead and automatically
do it as cv that way if you're using
older code
it doesn't bother me too much to use cv2
but a lot of people prefer to just keep
that as an open someday they'll probably
have cv3 who knows
we want our numpy for our numbers array
sometimes that comes in we have our
matplot library
kind of by default and we'll do our map
plot library in line just because we're
in jupiter notebook that way if we do
any plotting
it's not really going to affect what
we're working on i just do it as a
standard
pretty straightforward
and then before we get started let me go
ahead and pull over
we have a file set up on here with some
images in it and some videos
and just like any of our other
setups and simply learn if you need a
copy of some of these images of course
it's pretty easy to come up with your
own images in your own videos nowadays
but if you want to rerun this and set
this up you can certainly have them send
the information over there with in this
case we have the cat which is going to
be an image
we have a dog which is going to be an
mp4
video
and then we have we do facial
recognition we took some of our
very well known actors out there like
ben affleck elton john the musician
jerry seinfeld and other people so we
can actually train a cross setup on
there and do a
facial recognition on there and again
all of this you can send to simply learn
and say hey can i get a copy of some of
this information
and so we're going to start out the
first thing we want to do is just the
most basic thing which is
read in an image and display it
and then i'm going to go ahead and let's
see
i'm going to cut this in half
i used to have this in windows 10 where
i just hit a button and it dropped my
background and everything
so we're going to look at the horrible
blue color of the windows default
um
you'll just have to ignore my icons up
there and so we're going to be reading
images and the reason i did a half
screen here is because
when they pop up they don't necessarily
pop up by default in front in the
jupiter notebook
so you're not even going to see them
they'd be hidden behind there
the first thing you want to do is just a
basic reading of an image in this case
we're just going to read the file
cat.jpg
there's no path in here because i went
ahead and saved it in the same folder
that the program is running in but if
you have it in a separate folder you
want to put that full path in there
and so it's real simple we have image we
have cm dot im read or red i i don't
know which one they use um i am red
and then cv i am show and that just
stands for image show and cats and then
image
cats is the title of the window that's
going to pop up and let's go ahead and
run that and you can see here we have
our window that pops up and there's our
cat
so that's really straightforward
if you're looking at that
it's there's nothing
really difficult this is why i like um
opencv so much because it's so easy to
use
and if we're going to do the image if
you remember we had dog
video going on maybe my image up a
little bit there we go
we can go ahead and play a movie and
that's that that is really cool and by
the way
when i was messing with this it does
actually store the sound file with the
mp4 so if you have the video playing and
the microphone going it will store both
of those as a second there's like
another channel that stores in the cv
when it's reading these things
in this case we're going to go ahead and
capture
uh we need to go ahead and tell it where
what file we're capturing
um in in the next video we'll actually
do
one of the next two sections we'll show
you how to capture the camera you're
actually looking at
but in this one we have capture cd video
capture dog.mp4 pretty straightforward
it just says here's the file we're going
to capture
and then it says while true
and this if you're doing
a lot of programming in python you
should recognize this
instead of
setting is true to true and then letting
it switch each time
we just say hey if not is true break and
that will break the
loop
and so what we're doing here is we're
going to read each frame
of the video as it goes is true frame
equals capture dot red
um if is true is false it breaks so
we're done we've hit the end of the
video and then we're going to show the
video in this case of the dog cute
little puppy
and it's going to be by frame so each
frame
is showing
and you see we have a weight key here
this has to do with uh the end code in
the back so
you could probably leave it out in here
but it's usually good to leave these
particular things in
this particular key in there because it
does actually there are times when that
can affect the run time and you can see
here's our little puppers
you know
smiling and having
fun and it is it's playing each of those
frames so as you're watching it uh it's
going through i don't know how many
frames per second probably 30 frames per
second and so it's displaying 30 frames
one after another
um and if you have sound with it it by
default will play the soundtrack with
there just so you know um
we don't we're not doing too much in
sound on this one that we're just
focusing on the opencv video
and then when you're done with something
uh you'll see me flash this up a bunch
of times we're gonna have the destroy
all windows from the cv which closes
everything we got going um
when we're dealing with videos
one of the issues is you have a buffer
in your video
and so you'll see us you'll see this
kind of coding where it says weight key
60 and it's just waiting an extra period
of time to make sure everything's
cleared out of memory that's all that
does and so you can see we just closed
all the windows that came in on there
and then one of the cool things we can
do
and we're going to do a bunch of stuff
with images in just a minute but let's
start with the video we can do resizing
and so we have a rescale the frame we're
going to submit the frame we're going to
send it the scale and it's going to
compute the
height
the width and the height based on what
we send for a scale
we'll put it into dimensions and this
right here is our resize um
cf resize the frame and this could also
be an image it's not you're not stuck
with just a frame when you do this kind
of resize
and then they have this is a code they
use for resizing
not a whole lot to look in there
it does come up sometimes because there
are a couple different mathematical
codes of how to blend the colors
together and make it smaller without it
becoming really chunky or really i mean
they used to just delete like if you cut
it in half you just delete every other
pixel
and then of course you're deleting
information instead of melding it
together and this moves it over that's
what this is doing right here this
interpolation equals cv inter area
and then we have the change the res
we're going to be doing a live video so
when you change the res the resolution
again there's not a whole lot to look in
here it's just um
helping us so that the resolution keeps
it looking nice on there
and then we have our this should look
familiar from above we do our capture we
need to set up where the video is coming
from we gotta let the cv the opencv know
what the video which uh file it's using
and then it says while true this is
again just like above
if not true
if not is true break
and here's our frame
resize
and then we're going to do a cv im show
frame and we're going to do cv i am show
framed resize this should look just like
you saw before
and then we have our
this extra code here in case we need to
re break early
now i'm going to run this and we're
going to get
if you have if you're looking at this
you should say oh we have
two different videos going
one of them is labeled video and it's
based on frame and one is video resized
based on frame so we're going to end up
with two completely separate videos
playing at the same time
and let's go ahead and run and see what
that looks like
you'll know one of the videos is
obviously going to be the dog because we
saw him before and you can see right
here
there the dog is resized
and we could easily take this
scale
yeah we'll go this way just a little bit
and instead of 0.5 maybe we want to do
0.25 because we want it to be like a
little little um thumbnail on there let
me run that and you can see how it
nicely rescales it down to a quarter of
the size
and then i'm going to keep the split
screen
you'll see why in just a second let me
go ahead and destroy the windows and
clean up our desktop that we're working
on and we're going to go back to image
editing uh so we're going to go through
a bunch of image
different editings you can do on here
now this next part
we're zooming through uh there are so
many things you can do with
the cv
uh first we're going to just draw a
blank box we'll go ahead and run this
here's my blank box it's got nothing in
it
and we can take if you notice i've
created blank oops there's my blank we
filled it with zeros so this is a 500 by
500 by three channel
there's actually can be four channels if
you have the alpha which is the see
through uh and this will handle an alpha
channel but you have the three channels
in here and you create a nice blank box
that's just playing black and in there
and then if we're gonna do a blank box
we can actually take go back in here
there we go we're gonna take this blank
box and we're just going to uh fill it
i'll leave it called blank
we'll run this and i'm putting in from
200 to 300 that's actual pixel counts
remember this is a
500 by 500 box
and we're going to do from 200 to 300
and 300 to 400 that's the upper left and
bottom right corners
of the array and we're going to send to
0 0 255 which happens to be green
and this is rbg
be a little careful because the some of
the formats switch the order from red
blue green to different colors
and if we run this
you can see here we've actually added oh
i guess i did a
a red box for some reason i thought that
was a green color i must have it
switched around on there
but you can see right here that we can
actually go in and we can change any
pixel in here and it works like a numpy
array which is really nice because now i
can edit
uh
my blank box here and do different
things in the blank box and fill it in
there and draw lines we'll go ahead and
do
a rectangle like i said some of this
is going to be quicker to pasting in
here and showing you
we're going to take a rectangle and
oops it's hard to see here
create the shape let me open this up a
little wider there we go
and in the rectangle
we're going to use blank
i'm going to
show it we're going to give it a new
window that's what this is doing down
here if i left this blank it just put
the rectangle on top of everything
and we're going to use blank as our
basis
starting at 0 0
and you can see our different dimensions
um and thickness minus one and there's
my weight key on the bottom and let me
go ahead and run that
oops i should have done an i am show
uh which it did but it was behind our
chrome
you can set where it appears on the
window we should probably do that on
here uh but you can see it opened up a
new window this window is called
rectangle this one's called blank and so
these are two completely different
windows that we've set up on here if i
change this to blank it would have just
put the rectangle on top just like it
did the
red square earlier
and we can do a lot with this we can go
ahead and draw let's see a circle a line
and then put some text on here and we'll
take the same blank setup
since that's our basis right here is
blank
and we'll go ahead and create all of
those and let me go ahead and paste that
in here and you can see here we have
our cv circle it's going in on the blank
we have our dimensions of the circle let
me just
bring these down a line so you can see a
little bit better what we're looking at
there we go
and then we're going to do the color on
this the thickness minus one and this is
uh basically a radius of the circle kind
of set up i'd have to look up to
remember the exact um
what these different numbers represent
um but you have the the different sizes
of the circle we have a line here we're
going to draw a line
blank
in this case we have
300 400 255 and you can see a set up in
here this is again
the color the starting point the end
point and a thickness of three
so a lot of this is pretty
straightforward and this is going to
open up a new window called line because
that's what we called it instead of
putting it on the blank
and then we'll do text
now on each one of these we're adding
the line to blank
so it's in the original blank square
that we call blank
but on each one of these we're putting
it opening it up in a new window we
could easily continue to put them in the
same window and you could turn it into a
video or some other kind of thing
and you can see down here hello my name
is jason my name isn't actually jason
and we have our location that we're
going to print jason on there and
the font and the size and the color and
dimensions of it and then show text and
let's go ahead and run so you can see
how all these show up on here
and if i open up my screen a little
wider uh you can see that we have our
code and we did certainly put add a
circle on here here's our circle we
added a line on here here's our line and
we've added text on here hello my name
is jason
probably should have picked a different
color instead of matching it with the
square box we put on there
and just like all of this we want to go
ahead and clear the data
keep a nice clean screen and i'm not
sure why it keeps printing this stuff
underneath let me go fix that
and then the next section we want to
cover
is going to be
your gray scales
and blending and masking and stuff like
that
and let's go ahead and clear our little
palette i don't know what else to call
it
that's a good name for it palette
and here we go you remember this one
we're going to load our image in this
case we're going to load the image park
and we're going to display park
uh we get that nice view of the park
that's what we did before
and there's so many things that are
built in to open cv on here uh one we
can grayscale it and we're just going to
take and you can see here we're
converting um blue green red remember i
said there's three channels you gotta be
a little careful what order they're in
i can never remember i have to actually
pull it up every time i go in here uh
because i jump around between so many
editors and software it's just the
nature of dealing with pictures
sometimes but you really have to make
sure you catch that and double check it
and so we're just going to this is just
a conversion and that's what the cvt
stands for color
and then we'll display this in
gray gray skelet and you can see it did
a nice job there's our park
oops if i can grab it
and there's the grayscale on there
and then we can do such things as blur
so i can come in here we can go ahead
and
this uses cv gaussian blur
and there's a lot of settings as far as
how the blur works
and then you can see here we've got
border default cv border default
seven seven i believe that has to do
with the square and the pixel reigns
when you do a lot of blurring then you
start messing with it and we can see
here's the park up here
we went ahead and grayscaled it oops
there we go
gray not responding because i hit the
wrong button on this
and blur there's our blur on there so we
have a couple different setups on that
there's also edge cascade
some of these you just pretty much you
really have to know your editing on
videos i'm not a huge
video editor
so when i do a lot of this stuff i'm not
really sure what it is i'm doing
like i know a blur is obviously but i
don't know what edge cascade is
except for now that it comes out you can
clearly see that it draws lines dealing
with where the different colors meet and
how they connect
that's a really neat tool it puts a nice
matte literally creates a nice mask of
the edging and you can see where you
could use this to pull out in this case
the sky quite easily from the whole
picture
and there's dilated let me go ahead and
run that and see what that looks like
let's give it a second to pop up to the
top
and keep in mind that the dilated used
the edge
as our input so we took
the canny the blur oh there we go yeah
candy blur
dilated use the candy so we have our
blurred coming in from the cany edges
quite the terminology there if you're
trying to follow it all we have a
roading
let me just show you some of the
settings on there
we have the number of iterations for
doing a routing so let's go ahead and
run this one
and you can see how it changes the
settings or the view on there and this
brought in the dilated and then eroded
it back into
i'm guessing it kind of sharpens it from
the from the blurriness we saw in the
one before the dilated
uh and then of course probably one of
the ones that i use the most and i use
the resize
and the reason i use this a lot is
because i work in data science and so
if i have it coming in as a certain size
on there
if this if the
neural network is processing an image
with a certain size
all the images coming in have to be that
size and so we have here um resizing our
image
and let's go ahead and run that and you
can see how we took the
in this case we use the original image
and we just resized it to a smaller view
on there
and if we can resize the image we can
also crop it
again data science loves cropping this
is you could literally
crop pictures and resize them and rotate
them and make that your new import for
doing categorization
and we'll actually show you how we can
automate that when we get to the facial
recognition cross part of this tutorial
but we can see here we can also crop it
and we just take the picture and crop a
small piece off of it there
and just like we did before let's go
ahead and clean our palette started over
again
and again we're just chugging through
these
these are commands
that depending on what you're doing
depends on what you need
so if we're looking at
changing it to grayscale
sometimes processing something in
grayscale and cross is easier it's able
to pull out the dimensions better
blurring that's more of a display kind
of thing where you're going to display
it with a slight blur
finding the edges that's kind of cool
you can actually come in there and maybe
use those edges to help you find
something in the foreground and in the
background
dilated give it a little blurry a look
eroded bring it back into sharpness
resize it and crop it
all those are things that are just neat
tools to have at your fingertips and
easy to use some of them might be more
for a website and bringing up icons and
cropping the head shot or something like
that where others are are kind of more
gen generally used in just about any
industry
another feature is uh being able to
translate
transmatt float 32 remember a lot of
these things let me just full screen
this here real quick
we have our image coming in and then we
can translate it
100 in different directions on here
there's so many different things we can
do with this so as we go through this oh
my goodness i
hit a button on here okay give me just a
second there we go
okay so let's go to translate on
translate on there and we have the cat
and you can see how we translated it
down instead of the full image of the
cat that we had before
we can also rotate
rotation like i mentioned earlier is a
fun thing to do
and we'll actually do that when we do
the cross thing because you can process
the same image at different angles and
then you've just multiplied your input
as far as doing identification
in this case you can rotate on here we
have the angle the rotation point
none
i believe it puts it in the center i'd
have to look that up and then you have
the image shape height width rotate
point is none with height so this is
actually going to put the rotate point
in the middle
if we send it a none to this little
routine that they put together in the
back
and then we're going to warp
this is the actual command here warp a
fiend
and you have the image you have your
rotate map and you have your dimensions
on here
and if we go ahead and plug that in we
put the rotate in
image at -45 let's see what happens and
we're going to run that
and you can see how it nicely rotated
the cat's head although it's a little
creepy the way it looks like it cut the
cat's head off on there
maybe move it translate it down a notch
just so you can't see the the cutoff
point
and we already did the resize but we'll
run that again so you can see how it
gets resized on here
and be aware when you resize them i do a
lot of resizing for the
putting it into
neural networks or into some kind of
machine learning
setup
but it does squish it it squishes it and
stretches it and so if you're doing this
for say display and re-editing you might
want to be a little careful about that
uh make sure that you maintain the same
ratio unless you intentionally want the
cat to look taller and thinner
and we can also go ahead and flip it
as you can see here we just flipped it
upside down
uh minus one you can probably flip it a
couple different ways i'm curious system
minus two does
shoot same thing
maybe if we put minus
and a one is n well one is just flipping
it all the way to the opposite side from
left to right
uh so you can see here we can flip it
around a little bit that's kind of a fun
thing to have
one of those things you might have a
hotkey for if you're doing some kind of
picture editing and giving a lot of
choices
and we also already did the
see there we go cropping
so you can see here where we a cropped
image
equals the image and we just pick out
the pixels we want
and then we can show the cropped image
over here and it's just a cropping of
the face in this case we grab 200 to 400
as the upper left corner and 300 to 400
as a bottom right corner
and let's clear our palette again
and then we're going to do
contour detection
and there
is so much that goes into all this i
mean we're flashing through a lot of
things and you can see how you might
combine them and use them for different
things
so we're going to go ahead and get our
cap back up as our image
and let's go ahead and do
um
image shape we're going to take an image
shape and we're just going to create a
blank screen for it so this is just a
blank screen here based on the shape of
the cat
and strangely enough uh this is done a
lot the reason that we would create a
blank thing is you can or a blank image
is you might start filling in
information on there and using that as
your template for different things
and so it becomes almost it becomes a
mask of sorts there's an actual mask in
the program a little bit different but
you can imagine that this is your blank
screen you start with you might add
circles or squares or whatever on there
and we can do the same thing here with
we can convert our picture to gray we
did that earlier which is always kind of
fun to see the cat comes back
being that i'm messing with a lot of uh
different feeds and stuff like that it's
uh you can see you got a knot of
responding going on there when you do a
lot of this stuff that's what you'll
start seeing more of that
as you mess with it it'll eventually
come in you just got to give some time
there it is there comes in my gray one
on there
and we have the gaussian blur so we can
take it and blur the image
and in this case we fed it the gray one
so you can see the the very clear mouth
underneath on the gray one and then the
more blurry one on top on there
if you remember we did earlier
come back on here
candy edges so again we're doing
detections and things like that looking
for different things
and there's another feature called cv
threshold and or the thrust cv threshold
and in this case we're going to send it
the gray picture and let me just pull
the coding down here
there we go
and you can see here we're going to do a
cv threshold based on binary um
let's set up on here and we'll go ahead
and just run this you can see what this
looks like run
there we go that's that's actually
really cool how it picks up on that
on the threshold you can see how it just
turns it into almost a black and white
image that can be a lot of fun too
and we can also look at the contours in
the opencv
so we talk about that we have our let me
just open this up all the way so we can
see the code
we're going to return the contours and
the
hierarchies
and we're going to pull this off of
canny
the candy one that we sent up up here
earlier
and
they have the retrieve list
and chain approximate samples there's a
lot of options in here that we can
follow
let's go ahead and run that
let's go back down here where are you
up there we go
and when we run this
we get a nice setup on this it says hey
there's 74 contours found on here
and that's that's actually uh
turns this starts turning this into a
math on whoops which one did we feed it
uh we fed it the
candy up here so we start to look at
these different setups let me get this
out of the way
where's canny there's candy in the back
and you can see that this drew 74
different uh like line connections on
here
so now we're starting to actually turn
this into almost a mathematical formula
on this
and when we're looking at these we'll go
ahead and do draw contours
and here's our contour let's return the
contours up here
and we're going to put this on the blank
remember how we did the blank earlier
so we're actually going to take the
blank as remember i told you you could
use it like a
a base that set up on there and we can
now redraw the contours but in this case
we change the color
so now we're drawing the contours in red
so that's just kind of a fun thing you
can do on there to
change the
literally change the appearance and the
setup on there
and let's go of course clean up our
setup and destroy all our windows and
move on to the next section
and we're going to look at color spaces
and let's start with
in the color spaces we're going to
read an image in
and i'm going to go ahead and show
the image park let me just run that
oops i forgot to put a
um the weight key in there
a lot of times the weight key just helps
because i'm pushing all these graphics
out through
a single kernel because i'm working in
jupiter notebook
and things get hung up and so waiting
that extra 60 milliseconds can sometimes
really help
sometimes as we start flashing these
pictures up and down you'll see there's
no response and other things come up
that really is just because we're
pushing so much out there
now one of the interesting things on
this is we imported matplot library and
so matplot library
can now easily be integrated with
our imagery and you just see all we're
going to do is just dump the image into
the matplot library
and now i have the image here
showing on my matplot library setup
one of the things you're going to notice
on this is the colors all look off well
again you see that and you see that
they're supposed to be the same thing
and you should jump and say oh uh one of
these is rbg the other is gbr or
bgr or something like that and so it's
reading the the
reading the colors in a different order
that's all that means and you have to do
a transformation at some point to fix
that
uh so let's go ahead and take a look at
we're going to go back and grayscale it
again we're going to take our image of
the park
we'll put it into gray
run there we go
and in here we can convert our color and
this is what we're just talking about we
can convert the color scheme let me go
and run this
and you can see here we swapped the
scheme out and then i'm curious because
we did
up here plot it
what does this look like when we plot
this new color down here uh this new
scheme what does that look like on our
setup let me go ahead and just go down
there we go
and we call this hsv
so we'll go down here instead of image
i'm going to plot
hsv
and let's run that
and still
way off on color schemes
you can see we really mess up with this
hsv is another type of color scheme i
was curious because i did not think it
would come up correctly but i wanted to
see if it would
and we can also do a conversion to
what's called
there we go
bgr blue green red to lab
and lab is just another color scheme on
here
and so you can see we swatch the color
screen it has some really cool effects
as far as
uh what it looks like in their view uh
lab ranges from
it's kind of luminosity
and then it has like uh then the
channels coming in
so it's a little bit different setup on
this but really you have to just play
with these to see what they look like we
talk about all these different color
schemes and all these switches on here
now the one that we were talking about
earlier i mentioned was the bgr to rgb
because we use the bgr we'll just run
this
and we see the color change on that
and then we'll go back up because i'm
still curious
um
okay there we go copy
if this is the same that matplot library
uses and we'll just type in rgb down
here
because that's what we called our figure
and we'll run this and it will display
it oops it comes up there and gives us a
problem because
capitalization
whoops
rgb there we go so let's go ahead and
run that
and that looks pretty close to the
original uh so this is when we're
converting between matplot library and
from the opencv
we really want the blue green red to red
green blue that's the conversion you
want to use to get to the original
picture on there
and then we can also convert from
hsv to the lab like i said these
conversions
you have to look them up most of the
time
but it's important to start recognizing
them so the very fact that you're in
here looking at this we're talking about
blue green red versus lab
um versus the um
where was it h
hsv setup on there
when you're dealing with pictures they
come in all varieties and so really
being able to switch between them is
important on here
so let's go ahead and take that
particular setup conversions and we'll
go ahead and clean up our pallet
hopefully that will save us some
problems down the road
and we're going to start looking at the
color channels
uh and with this we'll go ahead and
reload the park back up we'll display
that just remember what the original
picture looked like
um and then
for right now let's go ahead and take a
blank
screen
and create ourselves a blank zeros
basically same shape as our park image
d type uh
u integer eight
don't really usually that's the default
anyway so you don't really need to even
put that in there but it's good to have
and this is an interesting
line here that opencv allows you to do
a cv split image and this basically just
takes the three channels in your numpy
image and you could use the numpy code
and figure it out i'm sure and splits it
into blue channel green channel and red
channel
and what we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and
there we go
we're going to do a cv merge blue green
and red
and what we're doing is we're merging
the
blank one
as far as blue
the blank green blank
blank blank red
so these are the new channels as we
combine them that's what this uh merge
thing does this is kind of fun because
you could merge you could take like your
cat with just the red whiskers
merge that with something um and then
kind of mess with the images as to far
as like you know what sticks out what
sits back on there you get pretty
creative with the um
imagery and then we're just going to go
ahead and show blue green red
we'll just do all these at once
and you can see here
same image
oops there we go i'll take it a second
to pull it down
and we can now
see uh it's either black or blue red or
blue or you know the different colors in
here green or black kind of fun i mean
really pull out the different colors and
see how you can mess with them on there
and then if we go ahead and
just do a quick print of these shapes
let me go run
uh you can see here that as you expected
uh you have the image shape which is 427
640x3
well it's only 640 by 640. so each one
of these is just the color of just the
one color that's all we're showing on
here
the fact that we use the shape on here
is very similar to your numpy and these
are actually numpy in the back end
so if you haven't messed with numpy
real powerful setup on there you can
dive in there and do a lot of stuff in
numpy that comes back right into this
over here
and then we'll merge them back in
shoot there we go and we see the
original picture give it a second to pop
to the front
and you see here we merge the colors
back we separated the colors we merge
them back same image and that's what we
expect on this because we didn't mess
with any of the colors
let's go ahead and destroy all that so
we have another clear setup
and let's go in and look at some more
alterations we can do with
blurring and and altering the image in
different ways
for this we'll go back to our cat
picture uh here's our image cv am red
cat jpeg
and if we run that and view it there's
our cat
i guess we got tired i guess the guys in
the back got tired of the cute puppy
running around
and the first thing we'll go ahead and
give a shot on here is uh averaging
these are different ways we can blur the
image
uh so if we average it it takes the
average pixels based on uh three by
three and if we change this to 30
just for fun
um you can see how it really blurs it on
there uh so this is like a 30 by 30
pixel each pixel averages around it and
we'll go back to 10.
kind of a little bit of fun stuff you
can do on there and you can see that
because i'm doing the average blur
it knows to go to this frame right here
that's why i can so easily jump in here
and just make some changes on that
that is a lot of fun when you're messing
with videos because you can so easily
throw that into
your interface
setup on there and be able to mess with
it and here's our gaussian blur
and the gaussian blur is very similar
but the
pixels that are closer are given more
weight and let's just jump this up here
to 30.
we'll run that
and whoops it didn't like 30 i guess i
jumped too high for it uh let's do
let's do five
there we go uh you start to see the
blurring on there and then
the one let's change that and see what
that does doesn't make a huge difference
on this until you start messing with
let's see
waited there we go run
uh you start to see us starting to blur
more and more depending on how we do the
weight and how it kind of
blends outward gaussian's nice because
it adds a little bit more blending to it
where this just blurs it where the
average just blurs it out
again those are the kind of things you
almost have to play with them a lot
to start seeing how they change
and there's also the medium blur
let's go ahead and run that one
as it comes up there we go
and the median works almost identical to
the average it's very similar on there
there are some differences
you really have to start looking at what
is the difference between an average and
a medium value
because that's what this is based on
this is based on the median value
if we do it run 10 there we go there's
our median i hope i didn't like the 10
i'm not sure why i must have been too
high of a value for it
run
oops
let's try 0.5
there we go
okay so and this has to be an integer
for the medium blur and you can see it's
similar to the average
but there is a difference in the way the
math actually functions in the
background
sometimes it comes out a little
different
and there's also a bilateral
filter
a lot of these you use to smooth
sharp edges if something looks really
sharp you can smooth it and this is
literally what they're doing when they
say smooth something
and you're messing around with
photoshop
these are the kind of changes that are
happening in the back end
and then we have our bilateral let me go
and run that
and the bilateral
you should that is one that's really
important to remember
uh because it works like the gaussian
but it it's like a gaussian filter on
top of a gaussian filter
and one gaussian filter
smooths out like blotches like if you
want something to have smooth skin
but keeps the sharp edges
uh and so when you're messing with this
and you're doing a lot of work
remembering the bilateral filter is
really important if you're doing images
especially
look at my complexion i really need it i
should be doing the bilateral on that
one
that's the kind of thing that you'd be
using to really bring up people's
features while smoothing out all that
fuzzy noise that shows up on their skin
and blemishes
and again let's go ahead and clear our
palette
run
another
cool feature
so we can do bit wise
set up on here and i'm going to create a
blank
setup
just so you can see what it's going on
there here's our blank box 400
400 400
it has a rectangle we're going to do
from the blank copy and then we're going
to do a circle
the circle is going to be
200 200
set up on here
so we're just building a circle and a
rectangle like we did before let me just
show you all the numbers on there so you
can see what we're doing oops let me
maximize it all right there we go
always a question do you do it before or
after the comma it really depends on
what i'm working on and who i'm working
with
i do whatever they want
so if it's sometimes it looks nice to
have the commas in front sometimes
afterwards when you're splitting rolls
it's purely visual on here
so we're gonna have we're gonna go ahead
and do build ourselves a rectangle and a
circle here and let's just go ahead and
display those so we can see what those
look like
so we're just going to show our
two images these images are based on the
blank so they're the same size as far as
the image goes and that's important when
you're working with bit wise
so how do you overlap two things if you
don't know which
which parts are overlapping so they have
to be the same size
and we can see over here let me just
pull this over
we have our rectangle in our circle
and we can do just like we do with
any kind of bit wise functionality and
let me pull i guess see if i can pull it
over here without losing
information on the screen
i always wish the screen was 10 times
bigger than it ever is it doesn't matter
how big my screen is
so here we have the bitwise and this is
where the two regions intersect and it's
like you expect you can see the white
circle on the square but where they
where they're both at but not where um
uh
the black part is so it's only it's the
and they have to have both white on both
the square and the circle
and just like that we can also do the or
and hopefully your mind's already jumped
ahead if we're doing the or cv bitwise
or rectangle in the circle
we have the combination of the two as if
you just pasted one over the other in
this particular case
and
we have uh nor
or zors is called
ctrl v
so it's not x nor
or not y
and if you look at that that kind of
makes a pretty pattern on there not x
not y
not x and y not not
but that's a zoro on there you can see
how the zor comes up on there and then
of course there's just the bit wise knot
on there
i'm going to run that one and you can
see here where the not set up on that
in this case it just inverses the circle
from black to white and just like before
let's go ahead and clear our palettes we
start with a clean palette over here
also keeps my computer running smooth
uh and we have we're now into masking oh
my gosh i use masking so much
and if you go into any program out there
that does any kind of editing masking
comes up so we want to go ahead and work
with our masking on this
and for masking let's bring the cat back
sure is a cute cat in this case we have
a bunch of cute kittens
in fact a bucket of cute kittens that's
a little scary
and we'll go ahead and create a blank
page on here and this is really
interesting in fact i'm going to stop
here and actually do
a draw and i want you to notice right
there oops
right there is the two
the shape and this is a numpy shape so
what are we talking about with this
numpy shape well this numpy shape is
zeros or ones we're really looking for a
black and white image a lot of times we
talk about mass we're talking about true
false and that is the same as in numpy
like a true false mask just like you
have a numpy
and we'll go ahead and create the blank
image over here and it's just like you'd
think it's a black
and then we can easily do both the
circle and rectangle
and you can see here we did an image
shape
this isn't too important right now
because we're going to create the mask
separately in just a second
but you can see where we're creating um
our image here there we go so you can
see all the different things in the
window and it's going to create both a
circle and a rectangle mask on here and
let's go ahead and do a
bit wise
we're going to create the mask out of
the bit wise out of the circle and the
square we'll go ahead and run that so
you can see what the mask looks like
and in fact let's let's go back to
let's clear up our things because our
palette here we'll just go run that
um we're gonna play with the
let's see where are the kittens
gotta have our cute kittens on our
display
there we go there's our kittens come
back okay our bucket of kittens that
cracks me up a bucket of kittens uh and
here's our mask run
you see we have an interesting mask
showing on there and then i'm gonna
we're gonna take and
uh combine these
let's see here we go
and we're going to do a bit wise where
we have the image the image and masked
equals mast
uh so here's a bit wise set up on here
and let's see what that looks like
and it's just kind of fun i've created
this mask adding all these things
together and you can see how
easily we can actually just kind of zero
in there and show just the kitten on the
mask
so that's that's a lot of fun and you
could also reverse this and have an
image without the kitten on there and
just a black hole where the cat was
so those are both things that can happen
on here
let's go ahead and clear our setup and
masks can get so complicated you can see
we added two masks together a square and
a circle and got a half circle on there
i tell you i've gotten into
so many layers of masks that i can't
even track what's going on anymore
so you gotta be a little careful with
your masks and how you add them together
and bring them together
but there's a lot of things you can do
with them you could just as easily swap
the green channel in for one
so you have just certain areas where you
have like just a circle or it's just
green or maybe the whole background is
green and one area is actually full
color
so there's a lot of cool things or you
could mask
take the mask of the
of a black and white image and then mask
a section of it in color i've seen that
done to make some really cool photo
photographs
histograms not something i normally
think of when dealing with photographs
but you can do a histogram of the
information on there
so let's bring back the kittens because
they're just so cute
and let's uh grayscale it
bring them back in our gray-skilled cats
and then what we can do with this
is we can go ahead and do a grace a
histogram on the grayscale
boy we can get so much into histograms
because histograms have so much cool
data that you can bring in
uh so a lot of times you can take images
of something you can start looking at
the number of pixels uh
the bins that they fall in different
setups as it pulls in but you can see we
have a grayscale the histogram of the
grayscale here
and just like we do the grayscale we can
also do a histogram of the
colored skill too
boom there we go and the same setup we
got our plot figure our title we're just
doing a histogram we're just going to
throw in the colors blue green red
and then we just go through each of the
colors and we go ahead and mask them
and then plot them on here let me just
pull that over so you can easily see
what's going on and the same thing with
the grayscale all we did was come in
here and just drop the grayscale right
on here
um with the setup and so we have our
figure our bins and our number of pixels
and if we plot the red uh
histogram of the colors uh you can see
here some really kind of fun patterns
and you could analyze these patterns
on different things to
i don't know about kittens
i don't really think of kittens with
histograms i don't really wouldn't
really do a histogram of a cat
but you could see if this image was like
a heartbeat image or something like that
the histogram would really be showing
and telling you exactly what's going on
and we'll keep the cute kittens up there
and look at thresh holding
so we have the threshold the thresh
and the you can do a threshold on here
as far as uh
there we go let me just bring that down
so you see some of the numbers that go
into there and we're going to use the
grayscale
and just do a simple thresholding view
on here and what we're looking at is the
colors that come forward you can do
different thresholds on different colors
and here we're just saying hey if it's
uh
because we're dealing with grays
if the certain color is over 150 or 255
you can see we have a knife or if it's
over 150
then it just turns it black otherwise
it's white and so we create a nice
threshold and you can actually turn
around and use this as a mask back on
the original picture
and it would bring the cats out and make
some interesting pictures on there
but that's a basic threshold on there
there's what they call an inverse
threshold
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that looks like so you have an idea
we'll run this
and this is just you'll see right here
up here we had
threshold gray
very similar
but when we get down to there we go
uh thresh binary uh inverse there's the
key that changes it so it's still still
is thresh in inverse equals the same
call the same module cv threshold is
just how do we process it on the end and
if we run that
if you guessed it inverse means inverse
then you are correct give it a second to
pop back up here on top
there we go uh so very similar to the
original thrush inverse but opposite and
also makes for kind of a cool picture
you could imagine
taking either one of these and doing
some cool things with them over the
original pictures
and then finally there's an adaptive
threshold on here uh
in the adaptive threshold let me just
pull that over here
there we go
it doesn't quite show up on this
we have adaptive threshold gaussians
we're going to use the gaussian if you
remember gaussian means that it is uh
slow
to bring it up um slow that's not even
quite the right word
um
there we go okay i wanted to bring that
over so you could see a little bit
better
gaussian means it's adaptive so that the
weight closest to the pixel is very
different than as you get further and
further away as far as adaptive
threshold
and then the adaptive is based
more on the difference between the
pixels as opposed to
the grayness on there
and let's go ahead and we run it let's
take a look on this and see what that
looks like
and we can see just quite the wild
imagery again it almost makes it like a
black and white etch etching or
something like that so it has a really
cool effect
so
a lot of these things are designed
to help find
edges which is our next section we're
going to go over is
pulling out the edges and finding the
edge detection
and so you can see how complicated it is
it's not an easy thing to find the edges
on these pictures what is the edge what
are the colors how do you find that with
the histogram we saw in the color scheme
how they did a certain setup and you
might be able to pull that information
and use it to find an edge
and so there's a whole thing on edge
detection
this is so central to a lot of stuff
being worked on now
because
well let's face it if you're doing like
any kind of imagery you want to know
where the edges are so you can draw a
box around it whether you're trying to
program it to do a facial recognition as
we'll do in the third section we're
going to cover we're in the first
section
but let's go ahead and bring back our
park run that
and we're also going to do a nice gray
picture on here oops let me put um
the weight key back in there i don't
know why it does not
when i run it without giving it that
extra 60 milliseconds or whatever to
pull it in there it sure gives me a lot
of problems on on this machine
and again it's because i'm doing the
jupiter notebook
when i put this into a widget or
something like that and start using
opencv or use as a backend for code i
don't see these kind of problems it has
a lot to do with just using it in
jupiter notebook
and so let's start with the uh
sobel uh the subalx or
the solo line detection on here uh we're
going to put in
our grayscale setup on here
there's a lot of different settings on
the subalx sibley
and combining them back together
so let's go ahead and take that
and we want to go ahead and show oops i
forgot to bring my shows over
and i'm doing sobel first and the reason
i wanted to do sobel first
is because the other one is based on the
math behind sobel uh that we're going to
hit the the second one which is a
which happens to be the laplacian
and so this works on the intensity from
one pixel to the next
and it kind of creates a formula for it
and as you can see as we get into the
intensity from one set up to the other
let me bring this down
we can start to see some lines in here
and we have from the y direction and the
x direction and we combine them and you
can see there's an interesting kind of
pattern set up in here
now for a scene like the park it's not
really pulling it in that good
and
like i said each one of these has a
different
strength to it
with this one you might do images a
little bit better
close-up shots
but let's look at the laplacian now the
application is very similar how it works
in the background as a sobel as far as
intensity we take that formula for
generating the intensity on there
and whoops
what happened there
okay uh we take the intensity for that
laplacian
there it is
and they use the second derivative
and you can see how it really transforms
the edges on this image
and there's a lot of things we could do
with this if you remember from earlier
we talked about taking out noise
blurring
if you use some of those features on
here like the foreground would just
disappear with the right blurring
technique or the right transposition
technique
and it really becomes an art form uh
trying to jump between all these and
figure out which one's going to work for
your picture
and your
setup on there um and then you run the
histogram to kind of maybe find some try
to find a mathematical thing behind it
it's really a challenge to take the
background out or bring the background
in and sort those things out
and all these tools are slowly being
built and that's what opencv works so
good
uh just because to just to address that
and then we already did the canny setup
we'll go ahead and run the
line detection under canny
and the cany literally combines all of
the different math functions of our
of the
ablation
and the sobel setup and you can see here
does a really good job of drawing lines
and putting in areas on there
and again this is just a starting point
one of the cool things you can do with
here is blur it and then
like get rid of the bumps in the
beginning and clean it up and do all
kinds of things to create a mask on
there
and let's go ahead and clean up our
screen or pictures and images
and then we're going to dive into
the next the second step stage of this
which is motion detection now we covered
a huge amount in all these tools
that they have on there from our canny
edge detection to
bit wise mapping to
masking that's a lot of stuff to cover
some of those tools we're going to use
in the next setup or the next two one of
the next two setups
but we're going to start with motion
detection
which is kind of fun if you have a web
camera or you have
there's all kinds of reasons you could
use it an outdoor webcam that's my what
i've always wanted to put one up there
to because i live up in the mountains
it'd be fun to track the animals going
by
but you could also use the motion
detector to track somebody coming into
an area and then do facial recognition
on them
so you can see the motion detector has a
lot of cool tools on there and the fact
that we're going to grab from the camera
is really helpful also so let's go ahead
and go in here and open up a new let's
see
new
python 3.
and we'll go ahead and rename this real
quick
opencv
motion
detector there we go
so let's dive into our uh motion
detector and there's
so many we're gonna actually use a lot
of the tools we looked at earlier uh so
um let's go ahead and start by importing
our opencv and we went ahead and just
did opencv 2. remember last time i said
sometimes we leave it as cv
or import
cv2 as cb and so on we're just going to
import it as cb2 in this one
and we're going to do date time for
tracking
we have this thing called static back
it's uh
we want to be able to reset something to
none and so having it as a global
variable here makes sense
and then i'm going to have current
motion
and motion list
and what it is is the current motion is
going to have a start time and an end
time that's when it detects a motion
going on
and then the motion list is just going
to keep tagging those on so we have a
new one and an ending one
now we're looking at a lot of code here
so the first piece of code that's i
really want to draw your attention to
is this one right here
cv2 dot capture video
and then the number is if you had
multiple videos in here you can actually
capture actually capture the video off
the different video cameras and so we're
looking for the main default one
that's going to be set up in here
this is actually kind of cool because i
always had the idea of having the
front-facing camera and a side-facing
camera so that you could flip between
them and do different things as far as a
final edit and that kind of thing
but this is the video
is looking at this camera we're just
setting this up right now for which
camera to look at
now when we're dealing with video
uh we're kind of creating an infinite
loop and so at some point we have to put
a break in it and we'll we'll do that
we'll show you that break here in a sec
in fact
i'm going to skip between the two
um
and skip the code in the middle so you
can see the beginning and the end and so
we have an infinite while loop and we're
going we're going to stack images as the
video goes and display them
and then when we get to the end of this
infinite while loop we need a way out
in other words you don't want it just to
go on forever until you hit the escape
key
you could do that if you want
but we like to actually add something in
there and we'll go ahead and do
here we go
this
we're going to tag on the end here
key weight
key q2 and then just break
now
this won't work like this unless we're
actually displaying a video and that
video screen is highlighted
all this does says is if we are active
in the active video screen when we do
the display when we get to that
break now i kind of jumped ahead because
we actually have to create a display in
the middle but i wanted to put this all
together so you could see it all in one
shot here
we have our while loop we're working
with
we're going to go ahead and initiate our
frame outside of here says hey this is
video
whenever i do video this is what we're
looking at then we're going to read the
video and you'll have two returns on
here check and frame
and the frame is nothing more than the
image coming in that's what that is and
the check is hey is do we have an image
coming in um if you remember from
earlier we played the dog video it came
up with check would come up false when
you got to the end of the video
because this is an indefinite loop we
never do anything with the check
we don't have to worry about that too
much
so here's here's our kind of our wrapper
and we're going to add a couple more
things before the end of the break on
this
and then we're going to initialize
our motion
so up here i initialized the current
motion as having nothing in it so this
is a current motion there's no action
going on we haven't started an action
there's no end of the action
and then when these fill up we'll put
them into the motion list
and so we're going to go ahead and add
in our motion equal to zero so we're
initializing the motion in the loop and
it starts out and says there's no motion
going on
now
we're going to go ahead and do some fun
stuff here and this stuff comes these
next lines of code come off of what we
just went over
we're going to grayscale it uh very
straightforward so whatever's coming in
the camera is going to have a grayscale
to it
and then we're going to do a gaussian
blur
this makes it easier to find the changes
um
we're looking for sharp edges that are
moving that's how we're going to do our
motion detector
and if everything's a little blurry
that means the edges are going to stick
out when they move
because everything because they're kind
of blurring it to those edges
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a
if static back is none static back
equals gray so we're going to
assign our very first value to the first
frame that comes in that's all this is
doing on here
and then continue on there
now i'm kind of zipping through these
steps i'm going to go back through them
in just a second so it'll make it a
little bit more understanding as we go
a difference between static background
and the current frame which is a
gaussian blur
so we want the difference between the
nice things this is just kind of a fun
abstract way of finding hey what's the
original frame and how much has it
changed
and then if there's a change and you're
going to hopefully already have guessed
that there's some problems with this
piece of code
right here
and i've run into this what if your
image is your outdoor cam and the grass
is blowing in the wind
or the lighting changes because the sun
rises and sets
so it might work great in a room that
has consistent lighting not so good for
a wilderness cam and you've got to start
thinking about these things and there's
ways around it
and if there's a change between static
background and the current frame is
greater than 30 it will show
white color so this is kind of fun where
here's our first threshold we're looking
for a threshold between the background
and the foreground
so we're starting to find a little bit
there on the setup and then we're going
to go ahead and take
our threshold frames the difference from
the background and the foreground
and we're going to put that into
the thresh
frame copy that
into a find contours and we're going to
use the chain approximate sample for
finding the contours
so this is going to find some contours
for us
and then what we want to look at is on
the contours
so we're counting lines we're counting
how many contours or how many lines are
in here and if there's over 10 000 of
these lines that are the different um
initial frame and the new frame
then the motion's going to be one
wow that's a lot to unpack
so let's go back up here and just go
over that real quick because i did each
line as we went in there first thing
we're doing is we're converting it to
gray why it's easier to see gray you can
see the differences in movements and
things like that in gray a lot better
than in color
next we're going to blur the gray this
just makes it so it's easier to see
the changes going on
we've reset our static back to none so
we initialize our background to gray
so if it's none then we want the static
back to be
whatever the gray value is of our first
frame so when i turn the camera on i'm
going to be outside the camera so you
can see the back wall of my office which
is
still under construction
just a wall socket and some weird stuff
back there
and that's what i'm going to use for my
basic setup and then when i go back in
and move around or actually i'll just be
in it and just try to hold still and
move around a little bit
and then we have the difference between
the static background and the gray frame
so this is the gray frame coming in
versus aesthetic background
and then we take that and we make our
threshold
and we basically create a bunch of
lines we find the contours of the
threshold the difference between those
and so that's where we get our nice
lines and if we have enough lines on
there then that means we have a motion
equals one
so that's a lot of fun motion equals one
so the next stage is if we have a motion
equals one
we want to track it
and so
we'll go ahead and do that here just
throw that one in
and it says hey if this is a motion
equals one
and our current motion that we're
looking at on our zero slot has nothing
in it
and the motion equals one then we want
to go ahead and stamp the date time in
there
so now we're tracking the start of
movement we have the beginning of
movement
and we can do a bunch of really fun
things and this next part we're going to
use
for a bounding rectangle
and this is going to come up in a
display we're going to show you in a
second this this one like you know
tracking the current motion
uh you know it's it's kind of cool you
can if we see their zero one
really looking at the contour area
and figuring out how much value to put
this at we put it at 10 000. that's
really part of the opencv
another thing with the opencv is we're
going to start looking at these contours
and we're going to create a rectangle
around them
and then cv2 rectangle
we're just going to take the frame and
write a rectangle right on top of that
frame
now
if for some reason
i stopped
moving we want to know about that so now
we've created a rectangle around
movements we've detected our motions
if it didn't detect any motions and
there's nothing going on
then we want to go ahead and take and
append the end time so if motion equals
zero and current motion equals of zero
is not equal to an empty set
then we've had movement going on and the
current motion of one needs to equal the
date time
we'll go ahead and just tag the current
motion right on top
and then the current motion is reset to
an empty set
so that's all it is is we're just
creating an array
of the emotions
and this is just kind of fun right now
um we're going to go ahead and do
displaying the images we'll start with
uh image gray
frame and there's our gray on there and
if you remember up here
we drew a box on it so you're going to
start seeing the rectangle
on the frame
coming in and then we're going to go and
display start displaying the gray frame
because we converted everything to frame
we want to go ahead and display the
differential
so you can see what what's going on in
there and why that looks different
we want to spray both the
threshold frame and the color frame so
we're going to do all of these up here
there we go okay
so we basically are showing up
everything that we put together so that
it's going to show up on the screen in
little boxes
and then we have our key weight and i
said i need to fill some more stuff in
here
well if we're in the middle of detection
of motion and i hit the q button
it'll be nice to know that it'd be nice
to tag that on to the end
so we'll go ahead and tag that on to the
end here
and if motion equals one and current
motion of zero is not equal to an empty
set then current motion of one equals
date time now
and motionless append the current motion
and then break that takes us out of
the loop completely
and then once we hit the break
we'd like to see what's going on with
our motionless that's what it's all
about is the motion list
so do a quick display on our motion list
i don't want to go past 30 if i do too
many start and stops
this is important let me go ahead and
highlight this right here
we want to release the video
and of course destroy all our windows
okay and that's just cleaning up always
good to clean up on there
and these are nothing more
let me go back up to the top here we go
we've already talked a lot about the
show
so we're showing the gray frame that we
created
we're showing the difference frame that
we created we're showing the threshold
frame
and then we're showing the actual uh
color frame that's actually coming in
the frame that's coming in
so wow that's a lot to break down let's
go ahead and run it hopefully i didn't
miss something when i was coming over
here
and we should see it coming through it's
setting up it's accessing the window
and i have to minimize excess behind it
and there we are
still moving there we go move back and
forth this is kind of cool because you
can see as i move back and forth look at
the lines around my face
especially on the
difference frame you can see where it's
putting nice contours on there and
setting it up so i need to go ahead and
click on one of these boxes because i
move the mouse on the other one and
we'll push the q button
and then we'll bring back up our
opencv and you can see here every time i
start and stop
i put the start time and an end time and
we could have easily put the frame count
you can put just about anything you want
on there
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
one more time
and then move
then hold still
and then click on and then go and hit
the q
and we can see here that instead of
having um
there we go boom
that it it picked up on a number of
different starting stops on here one two
three four five six seven start and
stops
so not bad you know a little motion
detector
um again you can see up here where we're
capturing the video we're looping
through and finding the video on each
one
and then we do all of our fun
transformations on creating the
grayscale and gaussian blur
anything to make it cleaner as far as
counting up the threshold lines to see
whether we should make it a motion or
not
and then of course we tack the emotion
the motion on there
we added these little boxes around the
contours
that was kind of fun because you could
see as i moved how it changed and
there's still like this weird blur in
the background
and then of course if we stop it tags on
an n value
and here's all of our displays
and voila we have a motion detector or
at least a start to one
you got to mess with it a little bit
there's obviously you might want to do
like every
one of the tricks that i use is where
you have the static right here
is we revert to the gray static view
this one is if it's um
you might just revert this to a new
frame every so many frames
that kind of thing so there's a little
bit lots of play in here that you can do
with this we're going to help you
prepare for interview questions dealing
with deep learning and we're going to go
from the very basics of neural networks
and deep learning into some of the more
commonly used models so you can have an
understanding of what kind of questions
are going to come up and what you need
to know in interview questions we'll
start with a very general concept of
what is deep learning this is where we
take large volumes of data in this case
on cats and dogs or whatever a lot of
times you use a training setup to train
your model remember it's kind of like a
magic black box going on there then we
use that to extract features or extract
information and in this case classify
the image of a cat and a dog so the
primary takeaway we're talking about
deep learning is it learns from large
volumes of structured and even
unstructured data and uses complex
algorithms to train neural network it
also performs complex operations to
extract hidden patterns and features and
if we're going to discuss deep learning
in this very uh simplified overview and
we also have to go over what is a neural
network this is a common image you'll
see of a drawing of a forward
propagation neural network and it's it's
a human brain inspired system which
replicates the way humans learn so this
is inspired how our own neurons in our
brain fire but at a much simplified
level obviously it's not ready to take
over the human uh population and be our
leader yet not for many years it's very
much in its infant stage but it's
inspired by how our brains work and they
use a lot of other inspirations you can
study brains of moths and other animals
that they've used to figure out how to
improve these neural networks the most
common one consists of three layers of
network and this is generally how you
view these networks is you have an input
you have a hidden layer and an output
and the neural network is uh broken up
into many pieces but we focus just on
the neural network it's always on the
hidden layers that we're making all the
adjustments and figuring out how to best
set up those hidden layers for their
functions to both train faster and to
function better when we look at this of
course we have our input hidden and
output each layer contains neurons
called as nodes perform various
operations and you can see here we have
the list of the nodes we have both our
input nodes and our output nodes and
then our hidden layer nodes and it's
used in deep learning algorithm like cnn
rnn jn etc we'll address some of these
models a little closer at least the most
common models as we go down the list and
we study the deep learning and the
neural network framework
let's start with what is a multi-layer
perceptron or mlp a lot of time is
referred to and you'll see these
abbreviations i'll be honest i have to
write them down on a piece of paper and
go through them because i never remember
what they all mean even though i play
with them all the time what is a
multi-layer perceptron well if you look
at the image on the right it's very
similar to what we just looked at you
have your input layer your hidden layer
and your output layer and that's exactly
what this is it has the same structure
of a single layer perceptron with one or
more hidden layers except the input
layer each node in the other layers uses
a non-linear activation function what
that means is your input layers your
data coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
it sends that error backwards from where
it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to
train this based on that error and how
that error goes backwards in the notes
so forward is you get your answers
backward is for training you see this
every day even my uh google pixel phone
has this it they train the neural
network which takes a lot more data to
train than it does to use and then they
load up that neural network into in this
case i have a pixel 2 which actually has
a built-in neural network for processing
pictures and so it's just the forward
propagation i use when it processes my
photos but when they were training it
used the back propagation to train it
with the errors they had we'll be coming
back to different models that are used
for right now though multi-layer
perceptron mlp put that down as your
vocabulary word and of course back
propagation
what is data normalization and why do we
need it this is so important we spend so
much time in normalizing our data and
getting our data clean and setting it up
so we talk about data there's a
pre-processing step to standardize the
data so whatever we have coming in we
don't want it to be a
one gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do but when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say -1 and 1 and we change them
and refit them to those values it helps
get rid of that bias helps fix for some
of those problems and then finally we
restructure the data and improve the
integrity we want to make sure that
we're not missing values or we don't
have partial data coming in one way to
look at this is
bad data in bad data out
so we want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts the weighted sum of
the inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the y-coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function and this
dev function this is where i remember i
said it's going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just the
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like re the ray of from
the sun and lu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three a zero
or one and in the last one it's either a
minus one or a one and you can easily
convert that to a zero one yes no true
false and on this one of the most common
ones is the step function itself because
there is no middle value there is no
discrepancy that says well i'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but i see the relu used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non-zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a point six not a one and uh
even though the one is what's going into
the next neural network or the next
hidden layer as an input the 0.6 value
might also be going in there to let you
know hey this is not a straight up 1 or
straight up 0 is someplace in the middle
this is a little uncertain what's coming
out here so it's a very powerful tool
but the basic neural network you usually
just use the step function it's yes or
no let's take a a big step back and take
a kind of an overview the next function
is what is a cost function that we're
going to cover this is so important
because this is your end result that
you're going to do over and over again
and use to decide whether the model is
working or not whether you need to try a
different step function whether you need
to try a different activation whether
you need to try a fully different model
used so what is the cost function cost
function is the measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is
you know real quick if you haven't done
statistics this is not a percentage it's
not a percentage of how accurate it is
it's just a measurement of the error and
we take that error for training it and
we push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we gotta look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do initial testing but you also want
to open that up and make sure you follow
up with the testing on the larger scale
of data because it will change it might
not fit the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's over fitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to
figure out the error on it based on the
square means usually although there's
other functions used so we want to talk
about what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the cop based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
costs of each piece of data coming in
and figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course uh we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and based on case of square means
was one of the functions we looked at
one of the activation functions based on
cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them we'll change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of the one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the way it's going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the error into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error and moving it backwards on the
neural network to change the weights and
help program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right uh but let's just take a
little detour let's see what is the
difference between a feed-forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network um in
reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although i'm not sure
why your x goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer for
part of the answer from that it
generates feeds back into the hidden
layer so now you have an input of both x
and part of the hidden layer and then
that feeds into your output now if we go
back to the forward let me just go back
a slide and we're looking at our forward
propagation network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a time sequence that's a
good term to remember are a time series
meaning that a sequential data each term
comes after the other you can trick this
by creating your input nodes as with the
history so if you know that you have
values 1 five and seven going in and you
know what the output is from one what
those outputs are you can expand the
input to include the history input
that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you do with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words together some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses
kids are playing football or soccer as
we call it in the us rn can help you
caption an image so based on previous
information coming in it refeeds that
back in and you have a image setter and
then time series problems like
predicting the prices of stocks in a
month or quarter or sell a product can
be solved using an rnn and this is a
really good example you have whatever
your stocks were doing earlier this
month will have a huge effect on what
they're doing today if you're investing
so having an rnn model a recurrent
neural network feeding into itself what
was happening previously allows it to
take that model and program in the whole
series without having to put in the
whole a month at a time of data you can
only put in one day at a time but if you
keep them in order it will look back and
say oh this because what happened
yesterday i need some information from
that and i'm going to use that to help
predict today's and so on and so on
we're going to go back to our activation
functions remember i told you rayleigh
was one of the most common functions
used so let's talk a little bit more
about relu and also softmax softmax is
an activation function that generates
the output between 0 and 1. it divides
each output such that the total sum of
the outputs is equal to 1. it is often
used in the output layers soft max l of
the n equals e to l on the n over the
absolute value of e to the l so what
does this function mean i mean what is
actually going on here so we have our
output notes and our output nodes are
giving us let's say they give us 1.2 0.9
and 0.4 as a human being i look at that
and i say well the greatest value is 1.2
so whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or well let's say it's a cow maybe
we had cats and dogs earlier why the
cats and dogs are hanging out with a cow
i don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a better whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be 1
on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to 1. and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never going to be less than zero and so
you can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be um an automated car that's
picking up images and it says that image
in front of us is probably a big truck
we should deal with it like it's a big
truck it's probably not a motorcycle um
or whatever those categories are that's
the soft max part of it but now we have
the relu well what where's the relu
coming from well the relu is what's
generating the 1.2 and the 0.9 and the
0.4 and so if you remember our relu
stands for rectified linear unit and is
the most widely used activation function
we looked at a number of different
activation functions including tangent h
the step function remember i said the
step function is really used if that's
what your actual output is because then
you know it's a zero or one but the ray
loop if you have that as your output you
now have a discrepancy in there and if
that's going into another neural network
or another process having that
discrepancy is really important and it
gives an output of x if x is positive
and 0 otherwise so it says my x value is
going to be somewhere between 0 or 1 and
then the usually unless it's really
uncertain the output's usually a one or
zero and then you have a little piece of
uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another network or you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the
convolutional neural network the cnn
you'd have to go to another video to
review the relu is the most common used
for
convolutional part of that network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters well
this is a great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most the time once you've gotten
the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error and how much you
want to change the weights we talked
about or i mentioned it early just
briefly you don't want to just make a
huge change otherwise you're going to
have a biased model so you only take
some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is
those small incremental changes epics
how many times are you going to go
through all the data in your training
set so one epic is one trip through all
the data and there's a lot of other
things depending on which model you're
working with and which programming
script you're working with like the
python sk learn package we'll have it
slightly different than say google's
tensorflow package which will be a
little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
get an unbiased model or we can have a
better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here so the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides earlier
that's what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so i just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable divergent behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates and
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they flip back and
forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced two new terms converge
and diverge a converge means that our
model has reached a point where it's
able to give a fairly good answer for
all the data we put in all those weights
have adjusted and it's minimized the
error diverged means that the data is so
chaotic that it can never manage to to
train to that data the data is just too
chaotic for it to train so we have two
new words there converge and diverge are
important to know also what is dropout
and batch normalization dropout is a
technique of dropping out hidden and
visible units of a network randomly to
prevent overfitting of data it doubles
the number of iterations needed to
converge the network so here we have our
standard neural network and then after
applying dropout now it doesn't mean we
actually delete the node the node is
still there and we're still going to use
that node what it means is that we're
only going to work with a few of the
nodes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is twenty percent uh
so you'll drop out twenty percent of the
nodes when you do your training you
reverse propagate your data and then
you'll randomly pick another 20 nodes
the next time you go through an epic
data training so each time you go
through one epic you will randomly pick
20 of those nodes not not to mess with
and this allows for less overfitting of
the data so by randomly doing this you
create some i guess it just kind of
pulls some nodes off to the side it says
we're going to handle the data later on
so we don't over fit batch normalization
is a technique to improve the
performance and stability of neural
network the idea is to normalize the
inputs in every layer so that they have
mean output and activation of zero and
standard deviation of one this question
covers a lot of different things which
is great it's a great uh interview
question because it pulls in that you
have to understand what the mean value
is so a mean output activation of zero
that means our average activation is
zero so when you normalize it remember
usually we're going between minus one
and one on a lot of these it's a very
standard setup so you have to be very
aware that this is your mean output
activation of zero and then we have our
standard deviation of one so we want to
keep our error down to just a one value
the benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster higher
learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batches a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data end but you
still go through a full epic you still
go through all the data on there so
batch gradient descent means you're
going to use it to fit all the data and
look for convergence there stochastic
gradient descent stochastic gradient
computes the gradient using a single
sample it converges much faster than
batch gradient because it updates weight
more frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when the model
learns the details and noise and the
training data to the degree that it
adversely impacts execution of the model
on the new information it is more likely
to occur with non-linear models that
have more flexibility when learning a
target function an example of this would
be if you're looking at say cars and
trucks and motorcycles it might only
recognize trucks that have a certain
box-like shape it might not be able to
notice a flatbed truck unless it's only
a specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and
starting is not very functional outside
of your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
under fitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less an
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting re-sampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold
cross-validation having a validation
data set to evaluate the model so we do
the re-sampling we're randomly going to
be picking out data and we'll run it a
few times to see how that works
depending on our random data and how we
sample the data to generate our model
and then we want to go ahead and
validate the data set by having our
training data and then keeping some data
on the side testing data to validate it
power weights initialized in a network
initializing all weights to zero all the
weights are set to zero this makes your
model similar to a linear model so if
you have linear data coming in doing a
basic setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so i'm going to detail exactly
how to see the convolutional layer works
on the cnn as far as creating a number
of smaller picture windows to go over
the data uh the second step is as a
rayleigh layer relu brings non-linearity
to the network and converts all the
negative pixels to zero output is
rectified feature map so it goes into a
mapping feature there pooling layer
pulling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map so we have all our relu
layer which is pulling all these little
maps out of our convolutional layer it's
taking that picture and little creating
little tiny neural networks to look at
different parts of the picture then we
need to pull it together and then
finally the fully connected layer so we
flatten our pulling layer out and we
have a fully connected layer recognizes
and classifies the objects in the image
and that's actually your forward
propagation reverse propagation training
model usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of go
over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces um and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a 2785 each one of those is a map so
it might be the first one might be a map
looking for cat ears the second one
looking for human eyes when it does this
you then have this rectified feature map
looking at these different features and
the max pooling with the two by two
filters and a stride of two stride means
instead of skipping every pixel you're
going to go every two pixels you take
the maximum values and you can see over
here we look at a pull feature map one
of the features says hey i had a max
value of eight so somewhere in here we
saw a human eye labeled as eight pretty
high label and maybe seven was a human
hand and maybe four was cat whiskers or
something that we thought might be cat
whiskers four is kind of a low number in
this particular case compared to the
other ones so you have your full pool
feature map you can see the process here
is we have our stepping we look for the
max value and then we create a pool
feature map of the max values how does a
lstm network work that's long short-term
memory so the first thing to know is
that an lstms are a special kind of
recurrent neural network capable of
learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default behavior we did
look at the rnn briefly talked about how
the hidden layer feeds back into itself
with the lstm has a much more
complicated feedback and you can see
here we have the hidden layer of t minus
one and hidden layer that's what the h
stands for hidden layer of t and the
formula is going in as we can see here
we have the hidden layers we have t
minus 1 and then h of t where t stands
for time so this is a series remember
working with series we want to remember
the past and you can see you have your x
your input of t and that might be a
frame in a
video as a frame comes in the usually
using this one the tangent h activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
omega formula and so when it combines
these that then goes into the next layer
your next hidden layer that then goes
into the data that's submitted to the
next input so you have your x of t plus
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your h values coming forward
from the last process and depending on
how many of these omega structures you
put in there depends on how long term
the memory gets so it's important to
remember this is more for your long-term
recurrent neural networks the three
steps in an lstm step one decides what
to forget and what to remember step two
selectively update cell state values so
based on what we want to remember and
forget we want to update those cell
values and then decides what part of the
current state make it to the output so
now we have to also have an output on
there what are vanishing and exploding
gradients this is a great question that
affects all our neural networks while
training an rnn your slope can become
either too small or too large and this
makes the training difficult when the
slope is too small the problem is known
as vanishing gradient so our slope we
have our change in x and our change in y
when the slope decreases gradually to a
very small value sometimes negative and
makes training difficult when the slope
tends to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between epic batch and iteration and
deep learning epic an epic represents
one iteration over the entire data set
so that's everything you're going to go
ahead and put into that training model
batch we cannot pass the entire data set
into the neural network at once so we
divide the data set into a number of
batches and then iteration if we have 10
000 images as data and a batch size of
200 then the epic should run 10 000
times over 200 so that means we have our
total number over the 200 equals 50
iteration so in each epic we're running
over all the data set we're going to
have 50 iterations and each of those
iterations includes a batch of 200
images in this case why tensorflow is
the most preferred library in deep
learning uh well first tensorflow
provides both c plus plus and python
apis that makes it easier to work on has
a faster compilation time than other
deep learning libraries like cross and
torch tensorflow supports both cpus and
gpus computing devices so right now
tensorflow is at the top of the market
because it's so easy to use for both
programmer side and for hardware side
and for the speed of getting something
up and running what do you mean by
tensor in tensorflow tensor is a
mathematical object represented as a
rays of higher dimension these arrays of
data with different dimensions and ranks
that are fed as input to the neural
network are called tensors you can see
here we have a tensor of dimensions five
comma four so it's a two dimensional
tensor coming in you can look at an
image like this that each one of those
pixels is a different value if it's a
black and white so it might be zero and
ones and then each one represents a
black and white image in a color photo
you might
either find a different value system or
you might have a tensor value that has
the x y coordinates as we see here plus
the colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensorflow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf.constant command
example a equals tf.constant 2.0 tf
float 32 so it's a tensorflow value of
32. b equals tf constant 3.0 print a b
if we did a print of a b we'd have
tf.constant and then of course b is that
instance of it variables variables allow
us to add new trainable parameters to
graph to define a variable we use
tf.variable command and initialize them
before running the graph in session
example w equals tf variable 0.3 d type
tfloat32 or b equals the tf variable
minus 3 comma d type float32
placeholders placeholders allow us to
feed data to a tensorflow model from
outside a model it permits a value to be
assigned later to define a placeholder
we use tf placeholder command example a
equals tf placeholder b equals a times
two with the tf session as sess result
equals session run b comma feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result so
we have a nice example there replace
holder session a session is run to
evaluate the nodes this is called as the
tensorflow runtime so for example you
have a equals tf constant 2.0 b equals
tf constant 4.0 c equals a plus b and at
this point you'd go ahead and create a
session equals tf session and then you
could evaluate the tensor c print
session run c that would input c as an
input into your session what do you
understand by a computational graph
everything in tensorflow is based on
creating a computational graph it has a
network of nodes where each node
performs an operation nodes represent
mathematical operation and edges
represent tensors since data flows in a
form of a graph it is also called a data
flow graph and we have a nice visual of
this graph or graphic image of a
computational graph and you can see here
we have our input nodes our add multiply
nodes and our multiply node at the end
and then we have the edges where the
data flows so we have from a going to c
a going to d you can see we have a two
flowing four flowing explain generative
adversarial network along with an
example suppose there is a wine shop
that purchases wine from dealers which
they will resell later so our dealer
going to the wine or shop owner that
then sells it for a profit but there are
some malfactor dealers who sell fake
wine in this case the shop owner should
be able to distinguish between fake and
authentic wine the forger will try to
different techniques to sell fake wine
and make sure certain techniques go past
the shop owner's check so here's our
forager fake wine shop owner the shop
owner would probably get some feedback
from the wine experts that some of the
wine is not original the owner would
have to improve how he determines
whether a wine is fake or authentic goal
of forger to create wines that are
indistinguishable from the authentic
ones goal of shop owner to accurately
tell if the wine is real or not there
are two main components of generative
adversarial network and we refer to as a
noise vector coming in we have our
forger who's going to generate fake wine
and then we have our real authentic wine
and of course our shop owner has to
figure out whether it's real or fake the
generator is a cnn that keeps producing
images that are closer in appearance to
the real images while the discriminator
tries to determine the difference
between real and fake images the
ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the network's
target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensionality reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're gonna have our
training data and our test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model three and so on in
boosting the emphasis is to select the
data points which give wrong output in
order to improve the accuracy so in
boosting we have our data set again we
split it to test data and train data and
we'll take a bag one and we'll train the
model data points with wrong predictions
then go into bag two and we then train
that model and repeat so that brings us
to the end of this video tutorial on ai
and deep learning full course i hope you
enjoyed watching this video if you have
any questions please feel free to put
them in the comments section our team
will help you thank you for watching and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you